AND RECONVENE AS A JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING SENATE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE.
NUMBER.
TWO WES CENTER WHITE HOUSE GIVES
CHAIR CULTURE IN THIS MEETING
WITH ME.
SO WE WILL [inaudible]
CONVENE -- THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
SO WE LIKE TO HAVE A EVERYBODY --
SETTLE DOWN IN.
TWO DISCUSSING THIS AND BOB YEAH.
OKAY -- HELLO EVERYONE THANK YOU
FOR COMING TO OUR MEETING TODAY
WE I LIKE TO FURTHER.
TAKE KNOWLEDGE -- THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE TESTIFYING BEFORE
INFORMATIONAL COMMITTEE MEETING
TODAY WE HAVE THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY THE STATE AUDITOR.
THE PEER REVIEW REVIEW GROUP --
LA -- AND MANY MANY LOCAL
OFFICIALS -- THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND AND MAKE YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE -- TODAY'S HEARING IS TO
GET A STATUS UPDATE.
ON A HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
AND WE'LL HEAR FROM THE
PANELISTS TODAY.
REGARDING PROGRESS ON THE
PROJECT WHAT.
ARE THE CURRENT CHALLENGES THE
PROJECT IS FACING.
AND WHAT OPTIONS -- ARE THERE
FOR MOVING FORWARD.
THE CONSTRUCTION OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT IS A MY
MONUMENTAL TASK.
AND THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY HAS A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD OF THEM.
ADDITIONALLY WE ALL KNOW THERE
WILL BE CHALLENGES ALONG THE WAY.
IF THE CONSTRUCTION OF THIS
PROJECT -- IS KEPT MOVING
FORWARD AND THEN BE SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED NOT ONLY WHAT WILL THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY BUT
THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS
AMENDED ADMINISTRATION ALL HAVE
A PART IN ADDRESSING THESE
CHALLENGES. TO MAKE THIS PROJECT
A SUCCESS I CANNOT STRESS THIS
ENOUGH AS THE LEGISLATURE IS THE
FUNDING PARTNER.
AND HAS A RESPONSIBILITY TO
CONDUCT OVERSIGHT OVER THE
AUTHORITY I WANT THIS COMMITTEE
DISCUSSED THE CHALLENGES -- IN
AN HONEST WAY THAT THE AUTHORITY
HAS IT CURRENTLY FACING THE
OPTIONS WE HAVE IN MOVING
FORWARD PRIOR TO THE DECISION --
BEING MADE ON MOVING FORWARD SO
THE LEGISLATURE SHOULD --
EXPRESS THEIR OPINION AND THIS
IS THE PURPOSE OF THIS FIRST
INFORMATIONAL HEARING -- THIS IS
BECAUSE CONSTRUCTION IS ALREADY
HAPPENING.
THE PROJECT IS BEING BUILT RIGHT
AWAY IS BEING ACQUIRED. FOR
WORKING WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE PROPER
OVERSIGHT.
OVER THESE ACTIONS AS CHAIR OF
OUR COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING FROM
THOSE TESTIFYING TODAY.
ON THE STATUS OF THE PROJECT AND
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
PROJECT AND THANK YOU WILL BE --
HAVING OUR FIRST PANEL -- CENTER
Y. KOWSKI -- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE SOME OPENING REMARKS THANK
YOU I WOULD -- CHAIRMAN OF BELL
AND DOES THE BUDGETS OF TWO YOU
KNOW WE HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
RESOURCES ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION AND THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS A BIG BOLD --
PROJECT THAT HIS HAS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT THAT THE IDEA OF BUILDING
AND CONNECTING TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS -- THAT WILL ENABLE
CALIFORNIANS TO MOVE FREELY --
FROM ONE PARTY STATE TO THE
OTHER IS IS IS WONDERFUL BUT
LIKE MANY TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS OF THIS
SCALE IT HAS HAD MORE OF ITS
CHEER SHARE OF CHALLENGES.
ON ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES RIGHT OF
WAY ISSUES AND OF COURSE.
ISSUED INDICATED FUNDING --
ISSUES I SEE MERIT IN BUILDING --
A TRANSPORTATION NETWORK THAT
WILL EVENTUALLY LINK -- THE
SYSTEMS OF THE BAY AREA WITH
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BUT I SHARE MANY OF THE CONCERNS
THAT OUR COLLEAGUES.
IN THE GENERAL PUBLIC -- HAVE
EXPRESSED ABOUT THE PROGRESS IS
BEING MADE -- SINCE THE VOTERS
APPROVED PROP ONE A IN. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT R. FEDERAL
PARTNERS QUITE FRANKLY HAVE NOT
BEEN -- ARE COOPERATING AND IS
GROWING INCREASINGLY HOSTILE TO
THE POINT THAT WE'VE GOT.
THE THREAT OF PULLING AWAY.
NINE HUNDRED PLUS MILLION
DOLLARS -- IN AND WARNING US
THAT THEY MAY TRY TO CLAW BACK.
THE OUR OWN ADDITIONAL TWO POINT.
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS THE AND WE
KNOW THAT THEIR SLOW.
WALKING A SOME OF THE PROCESS IN
TERMS OF ENVIRONMENTAL.
REVIEW UNDER NEPA -- IN OUR%
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS AND
OTHER ISSUES HAVE TO BE SIGNED
OFF SO.
AND I GUESS WE COULDN'T PASS BUT
HAVING THAT IS TO SAY THE
PRIVATE INVESTMENT HAS BEEN
LETHARGIC WHICH IS VITAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE THE PROJECT.
IT HASN'T MATERIALIZED -- TO
DATE -- AS WELL AS THE SMELL
OTHER LEGISLATORS HAVE FIVE
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE A OF
EARLY PRIVATE INVESTMENT SO THIS
SPRING AS ARE.
VIEW HAS SAID IS MAY FIRST IS.
CRITICAL TIME FOR THAT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL -- PROJECT -- I
PRESUME THAT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS TODAY -- IN
THE PRESENTATION WE WILL HAVE
YOU IN FRONT OF SUB.
TO NEXT MONTH.
ON SO WE GET A FURTHER FURTHER
UPDATE ON THAT AND I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT OF THAT THE
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE IN
SEPT TWO WILL BE TALKING ABOUT
THE GREENHOUSE GAS FUN ON
THURSDAY IN.
IN IN DETAIL AND HOW I KNOW
PORTION OF THE PRESENTATION THAT
WILL HAVE TO DAY WE'LL TALK
ABOUT THAT SO.
ALTERNATE BACK TO YOU CHAIRMAN
BELL LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU SENATOR -- NOW.
I LIKE TO CALL THE FIRST PANEL
UP -- LOU THOMPSON IS -- GROOVY
REVIEW GROUP.
ELAINE HOW OUR STATE AUDITOR --
WITH YOUR ASSISTANT -- MARK WREN
RD.
AND HELEN BERNSTEIN PRINCIPLE
FISCAL POLICY ANALYSIS ANALYST
FROM THE LA -- LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST.
SO -- WELL -- WE'LL HEAR FIRST
FROM LOU THOMPSON -- THE STATUTE
CREATING I BELIEVE LIEU THE
STATUTE CREATING THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL -- AUTHORITY -- CREATED AN
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE PEER
REVIEW GROUP -- WHICH LUIS LOOP
THOMPSON IS BEEN THE CHAIR OF TO
PROVIDE -- OPINIONS TO
LEGISLATURE HIS RESPONSIBILITY
IS -- TO PROVIDE AN INDEPENDENT
VIEW OF THE HIGH SPEED REAL
PROJECTS ALL TURN OVER.
TO LUKE THOMPSON -- WE ARE WE
ARE ALSO JOINED BY -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS SALAS WHO IS CHAIR OF
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE -- AND IS JOINT THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US RUDY.
THANK YOU SIR -- LUTON'S AND YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR AND THEN WE'LL GO
DOWN THE LINE TO THE AUDITOR.
AND THE LA -- SALUTE YOU HAVE
THE FLOOR PLEASE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK THIS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
HAD. THREE TO TESTIFY TO I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR BEFORE YOU TODAY.
I HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A COLD I
WARN YOU SO I MAY HAVE A HOARSE
VOICE.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THE PEER
REVIEW GROUP THE LA -- AND THE
STATE AUDITOR HAVE REVIEWED AND
REPORTED ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT.
ALTHOUGH THERE WERE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN EMPHASIS THEY
WERE REMARKABLY SIMILAR AND
SAYING THAT THE PROJECT IS IN
CRISIS.
BECAUSE OF THE ORIGINAL AND
CONTINUING FUNDAMENTAL MISMATCH
BETWEEN PROGRAM OBJECTIVES AND
AVAILABLE FUNDING.
THIS PROBLEM HAS AMONG OTHER
THINGS MEN A BECAUSE OF THE
MANAGEMENT PROBLEMS IDENTIFIED
IN THE AUDITOR'S REPORT.
THERE ARE TWO CRITICAL ISSUES
ONE DEVELOPING AN AGREED VISION
FOR PASSENGER RAIL
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDING HIGH
SPEED RAIL BUT NOT ONLY.
AND TO MATCHING THAT VISION WITH
AN ADEQUATE AND STABLE FINANCING
PLAN.
THE GOVERNOR STATE OF THE UNION
OF STATE OF THE STATE ADDRESS
WAS APPARENTLY ATTENDED THE
START A PROCESS OF THINKING
ABOUT AN ALTERNATIVE VISION FOR
THE PROJECT.
BUT IT LEFT IMPORTANT QUESTIONS
UNANSWERED.
GIVEN THAT THE NEW US DOT AND
NOW TO MEMBERS OF CALIFORNIA'S
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION OR
ATTEMPTING TO WITHDRAW OFF OR
REPROGRAM FEDERAL FUNDING
COMMITMENTS.
CLARIFYING AND COMMITTING TO THE
FUTURE VISION OF THE PROJECT
ALONG WITH A COMPATIBLE FUNDING
PLAN HAS BECOME EVEN MORE URGENT.
THE GOVERNOR SAID I QUOTE RIGHT
NOW THERE SIMPLY ISN'T A PATH TO
GET FROM SACRAMENTO TO SAN DIEGO
LETTER WHAT LITTLE LOAN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO LA.
I WISH THERE WERE.
IT IS NOT CLEAR WHAT HE INTENDED
TO SAY BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT HE
WAS REFERRING TO FINANCE SOME
CONTEXT WOULD BE USEFUL.
A RECENT PROPOSITION IN LOS
ANGELES ADDED A HANSON SALES TAX
AND GENERATED A HUNDRED TWENTY
BILLION DOLLARS FOR TRANSPORT.
THAT'S TWICE THE COST OF THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT.
EVERY ONE CENT PER GALLON
ADDITION TO GAS AND DIESEL FUEL
TAXES AS A HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
[inaudible]
OF A ONE DOLLAR PER VEHICLE
ADDITION TO THE REGISTRATION TAX
WOULD ADD THIRTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS AND TRUCK WAIT FEES OR
ONE POINT ONE BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
GOING BEYOND TRANSPORTATION AS
THEY DID IN LOS ANGELES A 1%
ADDITION TO THE STATE SALES TAX
WOULD ADD SIX BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR.
MORE THAN FINANCING THE PROJECT
AND I WANT TO ADD HERE.
THE TWO THOUSAND BUSINESS PLAN
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL ACTUALLY
CALLED FOR FINANCING THE PROJECT
FROM A QUARTER CENT SALES TAX OF
THIS ISN'T A NEW OR A RADICAL
IDEA.
A 1% SURCHARGE ON INCOME TAXES
WOULD ADD A BILLION ANNUALLY A
TENTH OF A PERCENT IN CRIMINAL
IN PROPERTY TAXES OR EXCLUSION
OF BUSINESS PROPERTY FROM PROP
THIRTEEN LIMITS.
WE DEAL BETWEEN FIVE AND ELEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
A 25% HYDRAULIC FRACTURING IN
SEVERANCE TAX WOULD ADD THREE TO
SEVEN BILLION.
EVEN AT 2% STATE WIDE SO THE TAX
WOULD ADD TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY.
OUR REVIEW FOR SENATOR BILL OUR
REVIEW OF THE IS ISSUE REAL
ESTATE AND STATEWIDE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT DOES SUPPORT.
THE ARGUMENT THAT HIGH SPEED
RAIL WOULD LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT
LOCAL DEVELOPMENT AND STATION
AREAS.
AND WOULD HAVE MANIFESTS
BENEFITS TO THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENT AND ACCESS TO
EMPLOYMENT.
AT THE SAME TIME IT SEEMS
UNLIKELY THAT THESE BENEFITS
HOWEVER GREAT.
WOULD BE ABLE TO YIELD A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION TO THE
CONSTRUCTION COST OF THE SYSTEM.
FINDING MORE FEDERAL MONEY WILL
BE A HEAVY LIFT.
THERE IS CURRENTLY LITTLE
SYMPATHY FOR A REQUEST FOR MORE
GRANT MONEY FOR TRANSPORTATION
ESPECIALLY CALIFORNIA.
EVEN IF THIS CHANGES NEW FEDERAL
PROGRAMS STATE HIGH SPEED RAIL
WOULD NEED TO BE ESTABLISHED IN
THE FACE OF LARGE FEDERAL BUDGET
DEFICITS.
EXISTING GRANT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
TIGER AND BUILD ARE BEING
DOWNSIZED OR ELIMINATED AS OR
THE TO FEEL LOANS.
RIFF LOANS MIGHT PAY SOME ROLE
BUT THEIR LOANS NOT GRANTS IN
THIS YEAR THAN ANYONE STATE
PROJECT MY CLAIM.
IN THE TOTAL PROGRAM IS NOT
LARGER NICK LIKELY A LARGE
ENOUGH TO MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTION.
THE PROJECTIONS OF DEMAND AND
COST ARGUE THAT THERE WILL
EVENTUALLY BE PRIVATE INVESTMENT
BUT THE AMOUNTS ARE NOT CLEAR
AND IN ANY CASE.
THE SYSTEM MUST BE BUILT AND
OPERATED FOR SOME PERIOD OF TIME
BEFORE THE COST AND DEMAND RISK
CAN BE EVALUATED.
PRIVATE ACTIVITY BONDS MAY ALSO
BE POSSIBLE ESPECIALLY IN
FINANCING STATION DEVELOPMENT
BUT NOT ON A SIGNIFICANT SCALE
TO SUPPORT CONSTRUCTION OF THE
SYSTEM.
AT THE VERY LEAST THERE S A GAP
OF SEVERAL TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WILL HAVE TO BE
COVERED BEFORE THE SYSTEM COULD
BEGIN GENERATING INCOME.
A SIMPLE STATEMENT WOULD BE THAT
IF WE WANT HIGH SPEED RAIL THE
STATE WILL NEED TO FIND A WAY TO
COVER THE FINANCING GAP.
BEYOND WHAT WE ALREADY AND HAVE
BEEN HANDY IF WE GET TO KEEP
EVEN THAT.
THERE ARE PLENTY OF OPTIONS FOR
PAYING FOR THE SYSTEM AND SOME
COMBINATION OF THE ABOVE OR
OTHERS THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
DEVISE WOULD CLEARLY WORK.
THERE IS A PATH IT'S JUST A HARD.
ONE THE PEER REVIEW GROUP HAS
CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED THE IDEA
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL AS AN
APPROPRIATE PART OF A STATEWIDE
PASSENGER RAIL SYSTEM INCLUDING
TRANSIT AND LOCAL COMMUTER
TRAVEL.
UNFORTUNATELY BE A PROP ONE A
AND THE FEDERAL ERA PROGRAM WE
GOT THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE.
HIGH SPEED RAIL WITHOUT LINKAGE
TO THE OTHER PARTS OF THE SYSTEM.
INSPIRING VISION OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL REPLETE WITH DRAMATIC
PICTURES OF SPEEDING GOLD AND
BLUE TRAINS.
BUT PRESENTED IN ADVANCE OF A
CREDIBLE FINANCING PLAN IS NOW
MEETING REALITY.
THEN THE ACTION BY THE
LEGISLATURE IS BADLY NEEDED.
HIGH SPEED WILL CONSTITUTE TO
YOUR A DILEMMA OR AN OPPORTUNITY
WE THINK IT COULD BE THE LATTER.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO WORK
WITH THE GOVERNOR TO ESTABLISH A
NEW VISION FOR THE ROLE OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
WITHIN THE OVERALL STATE RAIL
PASSENGER TRANSPORT SYSTEM.
GET THE HORSE BACK IN FRONT OF
THE CART.
WITH THE REALISTIC VISION BASED
ON EXPERIENCE TODAY AND A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING BY EVERYBODY OF
WHAT WE WANT OUT OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM.
IT SHOULD BE POSSIBLE TO DEVELOP
A SCOPE IN FINANCING PLAN THAT
WOULD PERMIT STABLE MANAGEMENT.
EXPERIENCE ALSO SHOWS THAT A NEW
VERSION SHOULD BE ACCOMPANIED BY
A MUCH MORE EFFECTIVE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
THERE ARE OPTIONS.
THE REAL DANGER IS STUMBLING
AHEAD WITH NO CLEAR AND AGREED
GOAL.
IF THE LEGISLATURE CANNOT AGREE
WITH THE GOVERNOR ON A VISION
THAT IS ACCEPTABLE.
AND PROVIDE A CREDIBLE FUNDING
APPROACH BASED ON A COMMITMENT
FROM THE STATE.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO SEE HOW
THE PROGRAM CAN GO FORWARD
SUCCESSFULLY.
I WISH I COULD BE MORE
OPTIMISTIC BUT I THINK THAT'S A
VERY REALISTIC STATEMENT OF
WHERE WE STAND [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IT OVER THE OF OUR STATE WATER
LANE HOW LINE.
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN CHAIR WACO SKI AND
CHAIR SALAS US SENATORS FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME'S ELAINE HOWELL
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR
AND WE'RE GOING TO MIGHT MY
COLLEAGUE AND I ARE GOING TO DO
IT VERY HIGH LEVEL REVIEW.
OF THE AUDIT REPORT WE ISSUED IN
NOVEMBER OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
THE CURRENT STATUS OF RESPONSES
THAT WE'VE RECEIVED FROM THE
AUTHORITY REGARDING.
OTHER PROGRESS IN IMPLEMENTING
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE MADE IN
THAT REPORT SO AT A HIGH LEVEL
WE HAD THREE KEY ISSUES THAT I'M
GONNA TALK ABOUT TODAY.
THE FIRST IS RELATED TO
CONSTRUCTION RISK MANAGEMENT
CHANGE ORDERS THE PROCESS.
FOR MANAGING THE PROJECT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF THE PARTICULAR
PROJECT AND AS WE CONCLUDED IN
THE REPORT AND AS AS THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER NOTED.
THE AUTHORITY REALLY MOVED AHEAD
WITH CONSTRUCTION PRIOR TO
REALLY ANALYZING OR
UNDERSTANDING ALL OF THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH DOING SO.
AND THE THREE EXAMPLES THAT WE
IDENTIFY THE REPORTER THREE
ELEMENTS HIS ACQUISITION OF LAND --
ABILITY TO DETERMINE HOW IT
WOULD RELOCATE UTILITIES WHAT
TE WHAT THE COST OF THAT WOULD
BE.
AND THEN ENTERING INTO
AGREEMENTS WITH EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS SUCH AS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS OR OTHER RAIL ROAD
AND UNION PACIFIC FOR EXAMPLE IS
WHAT WE MENTION IN THE REPORT.
AND BECAUSE THE AUTHORITY.
MOVED FORWARD WITH CONSTRUCTION
BEFORE REALLY UNDERSTANDING ALL
OF THE RISKS MITIGATING TRYING
TO DO EVERYTHING THEY COULD TO
MITIGATE THOSE RISKS WHAT WE
HAVE SEEN AND THE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT THE THREE
PROJECTS THAT WE LOOKED AT
DURING THE AUDIT -- A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF COST
OVERRUNS DELAYS IN THE TIME --
FOR COMPLETING THE PROJECT THE
COST OVERRUNS AS OF JUNE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE FINISHED OUR
FIELD WORK WAS AROUND SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT
WAS ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE THREE
ELEMENTS I JUST TALKED ABOUT AS
FAR AS ACQUIRING LAND -- WORKING
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT.
THERE IS THE ABILITY TO RELOCATE
UTILITY SYSTEMS SO SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN COST OVERRUNS
DELAYS IN THE PROJECT AND AS WE
SHOW IN THE REPORT.
THE MOST RECENT -- ANALYSIS THAT
WE HAD SEEN WITH FROM HIGH SPEED
RAIL WAS THE ABILITY TO COMPLETE
THE VALLEY TO VALLEY AS IT'S
CALLED THESE THREE PROJECTS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY WAS BEING
PUSHED OUT TO MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THE CONCERN WITHOUT
THAT WE RAISE AND DISCUSSING THE
AUDIT REPORT AND THE AUTHORITIES.
WELL AWARE IS THE FEDERAL
DEADLINE -- FOR MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE RECOVERY ACT
THE ERA MONEY IS DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO WE'RE
PUSHING UP AGAINST THAT
PARTICULAR.
DEADLINE ALSO WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THE PACE OF CONSTRUCTION WE
CONCLUDED THAT BASED ON PAST.
HISTORY AND ABILITY TO CONSTRUCT
SKEWS ME THAT THE AUTHORITY
WOULD HAVE TO WORK TWICE AS
QUICKLY AS IT HAS IN THE PAST TO
BE ABLE TO MEET.
ON THAT PARTICULAR DEADLINE SO
CERTAINLY HAD CONCERNS WITH RISK
MANAGEMENT.
CONSTRUCTION ETCETERA WE ALSO
LOW WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE CHANGE
ORDERS LOOK AT THE PROCESS THAT
THE AUTHORITY HAD FOR APPROVING
KNOWS CHANGE ORDERS THEY
CERTAINLY HAVE CONSULTANTS ON
BOARD. TO ASSIST THEM IN
ASSESSING THOSE CHANGE ORDERS IN
DETERMINING WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE FULLY JUSTIFIED.
IN SOME CASES WE SAW THAT THE
AUTHORITY HE DID THAT ADVICE
FROM CONSULTANTS BUT IN OTHER
CASES WE SAW THAT THEY DID NOT.
AND THEY ULTIMATELY APPROVED
CHANGE ORDERS THAT WERE HIGHER
HIGHER DOLLAR AMOUNTS THAN WHAT
THEIR CONSULTANTS -- SUGGESTED --
AND WHAT WE WERE LOOKING FOR IS
JUSTIFICATION RATIONALE FOR WHY
THE THE AUTHORITY FELT THEY
NEEDED -- TO EXCEED THE THE
RECOMMENDATION OF THEIR OWN
CONSULTANTS AND WE DIDN'T SEE
THAT KIND OF EVIDENCE SO WE FELT
THERE REALLY NEEDS TO BE.
A STRENGTHENING OF SOME OF THEIR
CONSTRUCTING CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT THE CHANGE ORDER
PROCESS.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST AREA.
THE SECOND AREA WE LOOK AT HIS
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT CENTRE BELL
IS ONE OF THE REQUESTED THIS
AUDIT REALLY ASKED US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS HIGH SPEED
RAIL WHAT KIND OF STRUCTURE DO
THEY HAVE IN PLACE. TO MANAGE
ALL THE VARIOUS CONTRACTS THAT
THEY HAVE THE CONTRACTOR'S --
THAT THEY'VE ENGAGED TO A SYSTEM
IN THIS PROJECT AND AS WE HAD
IDENTIFIED BACK IN TWENTY TWELVE
WHEN WE ISSUE A REPORT WE FOUND
SOME OF THE SAME CONCERNS -- IN
THE CURRENT AUDIT THAT WE HAD
IDENTIFIED IN PREVIOUS AUDITS
WHERE THE AUTHORITY WAS HIGHLY
DEPENDENT UPON CONSULTANTS.
DIDN'T HAVE ENOUGH IN HOUSE
STATE STAFF TO OVERSEE THOSE --
CONSULTANTS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WERE PROPERLY MANAGING
CONTRACTS ALSO SOME OF THE
ISSUES WE IDENTIFIED WERE REALLY
POOR CONTRACT MANAGEMENT -- NOT
NECESSARILY REVIEWING ALL OF THE
INVOICES EVEN THOUGH THAT WAS
PROBABLY THE STRONGEST AREA THAT
WE LOOKED AT WHERE WE WERE
REALLY CONCERNED IS.
MONITORING CONTRACTS MAKING SURE
THAT THE DELIVERABLES THAT WERE --
DILIP PROVIDED TO THE AUTHORITY
HER COMPLETED -- WERE OF THE
RIGHT QUALITY THE APPROPRIATE
DELIVERABLE SO THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF REALLY.
THESE CONTRACT MANAGERS ARE
SHARING THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY WAS GETTING -- WHAT
THEY WERE PAYING FOR SO WE
REALLY HAD SOME PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS IN THE
CONTRACT -- MANAGEMENT.
ARENA THE LAST THING I'LL TALK
ABOUT WITH RESPECT TO THAT IS --
WHEN WE ASK CONTRACT MANAGERS
FOR EVIDENCE OF AMENDMENTS AND A
REVIEW AND APPROVAL OF AN
AMENDMENT NOT ONLY FOR FOUR
DOLLARS BUT FOR THE AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT WAS GOING TO BE ADDED
ON TO A PARTICULAR PROJECT?
WE WERE AGAIN WE'RE NOT SEEING
SUFFICIENT EVIDENCE IN MOST
CASES OF WHO REVIEWED THAT WHAT
THE JUSTIFICATION WAS WHETHER
THERE WAS LEGITIMATE RATIONALE --
FOR APPROVING THAT PARTICULAR
AMENDMENT.
SO REALLY SOME ARE CONTINUING
CONCERNS WITH RESPECT TO
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT THE
AUTHORITY DID CREATE ITS OWN
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT -- UNIT
SUPPORT UNIT TO REVIEW CONTRACTS
AND CONTRACTORS BUT AGAIN WHEN
WE LOOKED AT THE STRUCTURE OF
THAT UNIT WE FOUND THAT.
YOU KNOW HE SUPERVISOR OF THE
UNIT IS A STATE EMPLOYEE MOST OF
THE OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS WERE CONTRACTORS WHO
WERE ULTIMATELY REVIEWING OTHER
CONTRACTORS WORK SO THE
STRUCTURE ITSELF -- WAS
PROBLEMATIC SO WE HAVE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS RELATED TO THAT.
THE THIRD AREA THAT WE WERE
ASKED TO LOOK AT WAS -- THE
AUTHORITIES POLICIES WITH
RESPECT TO SUSTAINABILITY AND
THERE TRANSPARENCY IN THE
REPORTING OUT ABOUT THE ECONOMIC
BENEFITS OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT -- AND AND WE CONCLUDED
IN THIS PARTICULAR AREA THAT WE
HIRED A CONSULTANT TO ASSIST US
WITH SUSTAINABILITY.
AND OUR CONSULTANT INFORMED US
AND WE JUST DESCRIBED IN THE
REPORT THAT THE POLICIES THAT
THE AUTHORITY DEVELOPED WITH
RESPECT TO SUSTAINABILITY WERE
ACTUALLY QUITE STRONG.
AND ALIGNED WITH BEST PRACTICES
WHAT WHAT THEY WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THERE WAS NO SEPARATION
BETWEEN.
THE SUSTAINABILITY IN THE
POSITIVE IMPACTS OF A FULLY
FUNCTIONING HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM VERSES THE IMPACT THAT
CURRENT CONSTRUCTION IS HAVING
WITH RESPECT TO SUSTAINABILITY
SO WE HAVE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS --
THAT ARE CONSULTANT ASSISTED US
WITH TO THE AUTHORITY OF GOT A
SEPARATE THOSE TWO OUT AND BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY WHAT THE IMPACT
IS WITH RESPECT TO
SUSTAINABILITY.
AND AND YET AT THE IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT DURING CONSTRUCTION
CERTAINLY CAN AND HAVE THE
ANALYSIS OF THE INTENDED
BENEFITS OF A HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM GETTINGPEOPLE OUT OF
CARS.
NOT TAKING AIRPLANES IT CETERA.
THE OTHER -- ISSUE RELATED
TRANSPARENCY THE SENATOR AND AND
THE OTHER REQUEST THURS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ON BELOW AND
PATTERSON ASKED US TO LOOK AT
THE INVESTMENT SMALL BUSINESS
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS A
DISADVANTAGE BUSINESSES MICRO
BUSINESSES ARE THOSE BUSINESSES.
ARE GAINING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
WHAT WE FOUND IN THE REPORT IS
THE ANSWER IS YES -- THERE WERE
A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF SMALL
BUSINESSES DISABLED VETERAN
BUSINESSES DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESSES FOR CONTRACTING WITH
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
PRIMARILY AND AND PERSONAL
SERVICES CONTRACTS WHICH MAKES
SENSE.
A LOT OF SMALL BUSINESSES DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO TO PROVIDE
CONSTRUCTION SERVICES -- BUT
THEY CERTAINLY CAN PROVIDE
PERSONAL SERVICES OUT TO THE
AUTHORITY SO -- THE AUTHORITY
SET A VERY.
HIGH BAR I MEAN THEY WANTED TO
ACHIEVE A 30%.
ARE UTILIZATION RATE AND WHEN WE
LOOKED AT THE ANALYSIS WE SAW
THAT IT WAS APPROACHING 30% SO
THEY WERE REALLY HAVE DONE.
A RELATIVELY GOOD JOB AND
WORKING WITH THOSE TYPES OF
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN AND CONTRACT WITH
THE AUTHORITY.
WITH RESPECT TO CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS WE SAW ABOUT A 16%
UTILIZATION RATE THERE SO AGAIN
RELATIVELY GOOD.
RESPONSE FROM THAT.
THE LAST ISSUE IS THE ECONOMIC
MODELLING THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
AND AGAIN WHEN WE LOOKED AT
THEIR MODELS AND THEIR
METHODOLOGY -- WE FELT THAT IT
WAS VERY STRONG -- CERTAINLY
AGAIN ALIGNED WITH BEST
PRACTICES THEY ARE REPORTING OUT
THE ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROJECT AND CONTINUE
TO DO SO.
SO THOSE ARE THE THREE HIGH
LEVEL ISSUES WE HAD A VARIETY OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AS YOU KNOW
MEMBERS WHEN MY OFFICE ISSUES AN
AUDIT REPORT -- WE HAVE GIVE THE
ENTITY THAT WE'VE AUDITED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND AS PART
OF THE OUR REPORT BUT WE HAVE A
FOLLOW UP PROCESS SIXTY DAYS SIX
MONTHS ONE YEAR SUBSEQUENT. TO
THAT PUBLICATION WE HAVE
RECEIVED THE SIXTY DAY RESPONSE
FROM THE AUTHORITY AND I'M GONNA
HANDED OFF TO MR REINER TO HE
WILL GO THROUGH AT A HIGH LEVEL.
THE NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MADE IN EACH OF THOSE THREE
AREAS AND BASICALLY THE STATUS --
OF THE THE AUTHORITIES PROGRESS
IN IMPLEMENTING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR A MISTER SURE
MISTER CHAIR MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MARK
CRINER DE AND THE SENIOR AUDITOR
WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE --
AS A STEPDAUGHTER -- SUMMARIZED
WE HAVE THREE AREAS -- AND WHICH
WE'VE GROUPED OUR OUR
RECOMMENDATION TO SUMMARIZE THEM
FOR YOU TODAY -- BY WAY OF A
HIGH LEVEL SUMMARY ABOUT ALL.
OUTSTANDING RECOMMENDATIONS WE
MADE SEVENTEEN RECOMMENDATIONS
TO THE AUTHORITY ACROSS THE
STREET SUBJECT MATTER AREAS --
AS OF THE SIXTY DAY MARK WHICH
WAS A JANUARY TWENTY FIFTH
JANUARY FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN WE HAVE TO TURN AT TEN
OF THOSE SEVENTEEN OF BEEN
PARTIAL PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED.
AND AND SEVEN ARE PENDING IN
INSOFAR AS WE ARE.
STILL WORKING WITH YOU FOR
DETERMINE -- STEPS THEY'VE TAKEN
IN THAT PROPERTY TAKEN DOCUMENT
FOR US -- WITH RESPECT TO THE
CONSTRUCTION AND CHANGE ORDER --
AREA TO THIS AREA -- FOCUSES
PRIMARILY ON THE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS
AND THE ASSOCIATED RISK
MANAGEMENT PROCESS SEES FOR BOTH
THOSE CONTRACTS AND YOU FUTURE
PLANNED A DESIGN BUILD A
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS.
THE THIRTY HAS PERSON COMMITTED
TO OF THE SIX RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU MADE IN THIS AREA. ONE HAS
TO DO WITH THE CHANGE ORDER
REVIEW AND APPROVAL PROCESS AT
THE STATE AUDITOR SUMMARIZED --
INSURING THAT THE ACTIONS OF THE
THE DETERMINATION IS MADE BY THE
AUTHORITY WITH RESPECT TO
REQUESTED CHANGE ORDERS.
ARE IN LINE TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE APPROPRIATE WITH THE
THE CONSULTANTS THE OVERSIGHT
FIRMS THAT HIRES TO TO ASSIST IN
THIS WAY.
THE OTHER RECOMMENDATION WHICH
HAS BEEN PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED
BY THE AUTHORITY HAS TO DO WITH
QUARTER REPORTING TO THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING.
THE PROGRESS IT IS MAKING IN
COMPLETING CENTRAL VALLEY
CONSTRUCTION AS TRACKED AGAINST
THE SCOPE OF WORK THAT IT IT
CURRENTLY A PROJECT IT WILL NEED
TO COMPLETE.
AND DOING SO.
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWO DEADLINE FOR THE ERA
A GRANT -- IN THAT IN THAT
RESPECT TO THAT RECOMMENDATION
THE AUTHORITY ISSUED A REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND PUBLISH ON
ITS WEBSITE AT THE END OF
JANUARY -- THAT -- THAT REPORT
TO CONTAIN ASPECTS OF THE
METHODOLOGY THAT WE RECOMMENDED
THE REPORT CONTAINED WITH
RESPECT -- TO THE URBAN VALUE
MODEL OF OF OF REPORTING ON
CONSTRUCTION PROGRESS HOWEVER WE
PROVIDED FEEDBACK IN OUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS.
THAT THE AUTHORITY NEEDED TO
UPDATE THE DATA IN -- IN THAT
MODELING TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
THE MOST UP TO DATE AND ACCURATE
POSSIBLE MINUTE REFLECTS -- THE
BEST IDEA CAN POINT TIME FOR
OUTSTANDING RISKS EXPECTED COSTS
AS WELL AS TO PROVIDE.
THE LEGISLATURE IN OTHER USERS
OF THAT REPORT WITH A A BETTER
IDEA OF HOW PROGRESS HOW IT HOW --
THE WORK IS ACCELERATING ORG OR
ALTERNATELY DECIPHERING THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AGAIN WITH THE
THE END GOAL BEING THAT DECEMBER.
TWENTY TWO DEADLINE.
OTHER RECOMMENDATION THIS IN
THIS AREA HAVE TO DO WITH THE
OVERSIGHT BY THE AUTHORITY OF
THOSE FIRMS IT EMPLOYS TO HELP
IT -- MONITOR CONTRACT
PERFORMANCE -- CONSTRUCTION
PERFORMANCE AS WELL AS SOME RISK
MITIGATION STEPS THAT WE
RECOMMENDED THE AUTHORITY TAKE
PRIOR.
TO EXECUTING FURTHER
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS AND OTHER
PORTIONS OF THE OF THE SYSTEM.
WITH RESPECT TO THE GENERAL
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT WE PERFORMED
AND AN EVALUATION OF THE
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT PRACTICES BY
THE AUTHORITY -- WITH RESPECT TO
OTHER NON CONSTRUCTION RELATED
CONTRACTS THESE WERE.
NINE LARGE CONTRACTS RELATED TO
A CONSULTING SERVICES THE REAL
DELIVERY PARTNER INCLUDED --
ALSO FINANCIAL ADVISING
CONTRACTS OF MANY OF THE
REGIONAL CONSULTING CONTRACTS
ARE ASSISTING WITH OBTAINING --
DIRECTOR OF DECISION THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PLANNING APPROVAL.
AND AS THE STATE AUDITOR --
SUMMARIZE WE FOUND.
FAIRLY WIDESPREAD NONCOMPLIANCE
WITH THE AUTHORITIES OWN.
PRACTICES IN THAT AREA ON THE
THIRTY HAD ACTUALLY PRIOR TO OUR
ENGAGEMENT -- DEVELOPED A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE SUITE OF POLICIES
ABOUT WHAT CONTRACT MANAGERS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE DOING IN A WITH
MANY OF THE SAME THINGS THAT WE
SAW WE SAW THEM HOW IT IS THAT
THEY WERE NOT PERFORMING SUCH AS
REVIEW OF OF INVOICES.
ENSURING THAT DELIVERABLE
QUALITY WAS OF A HOT BUT YOU
KNOW WAS APPROPRIATE AND TIMELY.
SO OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
AUTHORITY THAT AREA HAVE TO DO
MORE WITH SHORING UP THE
PROFESSIONAL A FULL TIME
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT STAFF THAT A
A PROGRAM THAT RELIES HEAVILY ON
ON OUTSIDE RESOURCES THAT HAS
THIS DOLLAR AMOUNT ASSOCIATED
WITH IT REALLY WARRANTS. TO THAT
END THE AUTHORITY HAS PARTIAL
IMPLEMENT ITS THREE OF OUR SIX
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THIS AREA HAS
TAKEN STEPS TO DRAFT.
A DUTY STATEMENTS ASSOCIATE WITH
FULL TIME CONTRACT MANAGER --
POSITIONS AS WE RECOMMENDED HOW
THEY HAVE INITIATED TRAINING FOR
THE SUPERVISOR TO CONTRACT
MANAGERS TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
ARE SUPERVISORS ARE EQUIPPED TO
EVALUATE THEIR SUBORDINATES
PERFORMANCE IN THIS AREA --
THEY'VE ALSO LAID OUT A SCHEDULE
BY WHICH THEY ARE ASSESSING THE
THE WIDE RANGE OF CONTRACTS THAT
WE WERE UNABLE TO GET TO BECAUSE
THEY'RE JUST THE SHEER VOLUME --
SO THAT AREAS WHERE THEY ARE
STILL WE'RE STILL WORKING WITH
THEM TO SEE DEMONSTRATE
IMPROVEMENT HAVE TO DO WITH THE
COMPLETION OF THOSE ASSESSMENTS --
THE THE ACTUAL -- TOOLS THAT YOU
ARE USING TO PROVIDE THOSE
ASSESSMENTS.
AS WELL AS TO BRING STATE STAFF
INTO POSITIONS THAT OVERSEE
CONTRACT MANAGERS AND BY
EXTENSION OTHER CONTRACTORS.
THE AUTHORITIES INDICATED IS
TAKEN STEPS IN IN THOSE AREAS WE
HAVE YET TO SEE IT ACTUALLY
EXECUTE ANY OF THOSE PLANS.
I SHOULD I SHOULD MENTION THAT.
A HIGH LEVEL THE AUTHORITY HAS
INDICATED TO US THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS IT PLANS TO HAVE
IMPLEMENTED FULLY BY THE SIX
MONTH MARK IN MAY TWENTY
NINETEEN SO -- THAT WILL BE.
SOMETHING THAT WILL BE LOOKING
FOR AND WORKING WITH THEM
LEADING UP. TO TO THAT DATE.
FINALLY IN THE SUSTAINABILITY
AREA AT THE AUTHORITY HAS
PARKING FERMENTED ALL FIVE OF
THE RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE.
FOUR OF THOSE HAVE TO DO WITH
THE SUSTAINABILITY POLICY
DELINEATING CONSTRUCTION IMPACTS
FROM.
THE THE PROJECTED IN A
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS OF AN
OPERATING SYSTEM.
AND AT A MORE GRANULAR LEVEL --
IMPROVING THE QUALITY OF ITS
DATA COLLECTION AND I TRACKING
AND REPORTING OF CONSTRUCTION
IMPACTS TO DATE.
OF THE AUTHORITY HAS PROVIDED US
WITH.
AT SIX AT SIXTY DAYS PROVIDE US
WITH DRAFT VERSIONS OF OF A
VARIETY OF NEW REPORTS AS WELL
AS NEW POLICIES RELATED TO
VALIDATING ITS DATA.
THE QUALITY OF ITS CONSTRUCTION
RELATED DATA -- THOSE THOSE
PROJECTS ARE IN DIFFERENT STATES
OF OF COMPLETION BUT ALL ARE
CONSISTENT WITH OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS AS WE CONCLUDED
IN THE REPORT.
AND THEN FINALLY THE AYE WITH
RESPECT TO SMALL BUSINESS
REPORTING.
IT IS IS VERY MUCH TRUE THAT THE
AUTHORITY IS.
IS REACHING OUR OUR PER PROTEIN
IT'S CALLED 30% THE TIME OF OUR
REVIEW.
HOWEVER -- THAT NUMBER DOES NOT
INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF
OF CONTRACTING MONEY THAT'S
GOING TOWARDS.
OTHER PUBLIC ENTITIES PUBLIC
PARTNERS LOCALITIES -- WHO MAY
OR MAY NOT HAVE THEIR OWN A
SMALL BUSINESS OR A DISABLED
VETERAN BUSINESS OR
DISADVANTAGED BUSINESS
REQUIREMENTS SO WE MADE A
RECOMMENDATION TO THE AUTHORITY
THAT THEY?
JUST SIMPLY BE MORE INCLUSIVE IN
THEIR REPORTING HAVING MORE
TRANSPARENT ABOUT WHICH CONTRACT
AMOUNTS THEY DAY EXEMPT FROM THE
30% REQUIREMENT AND THEY HAVE --
DENTURES JUST IN THE PROCESS OF
DOING THAT THEY HAVE.
CREATED A METHODOLOGY FOR MAKING
THOSE CALCULATIONS AND
PRESENTING THEM AND SO WE WILL
BE LOOKING TO SEE THOSE
CALCULATIONS IN PLACE NOT
REPORTING A PLACE AT SIX MONTHS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU OF FROM THE
SENATE FROM THE STATE ORDER OKAY
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO TO YOU AN
ALTERNATE OVER.
TO HELEN FOR CHRISTINE --
PRINCIPLE FISCAL POLICY ANALYST
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE HELLO ANY OTHER.
FOR GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRS AND
SENATORS HI CHRISTINE AGAIN WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
YOU SHOULD HAVE A HAND OUT THAT
PARALLELS MY REMARKS.
I MEAN IT PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT
OF AN UPDATE ON THE PROJECT ALL
STAR WHICH IS A VERY RIEF
BACKGROUND ON THE PROJECT I KNOW
MANY OF YOU ARE DEEPLY FAMILIAR
WITH THAT BUT JUST TO MAKE SURE
EVERYONE SORT OF OPERATING FROM
THE SAME BASE UNDERSTANDING.
ALL PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
INFORMATION ON THE FUNDING
THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO THE
PROJECT AS FAR AND HOW MUCH
MONEY HAS BEEN SPENT.
ALL ALSO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT-THE STATUS OF THE PROJECT AND
THEN I'LL CLOSE WITH SOME ISSUES
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
MOVING FORWARD.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE -- ONE
WITH RIGHT JUST SOME BRIEF
BACKGROUND AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
STATE LAW REQUIRES THE AUTHORITY
TO PREPARE A BUSINESS PLAN EVERY
EVEN YEAR AND THE LAST BUSINESS
PLAN THAT WAS -- PROVIDED BY THE
AUTHORITY WAS IN JUNE.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE'S
ALSO A REQUIREMENT FOR PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT AND THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BASICALLY UPDATE A
BUSINESS PLAN -- TYPICALLY
THAT'S EXPECTED IN MARCH WHERE
IN YOUR WE UNDERSTAND THAT THAT --
HAS BEEN DELAYED A BIT AND
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE IN MAY AND
WE'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT IN A FEW MINUTES.
SO -- THE PROJECT DELIVERY
PLANNED I DESCRIBE HERE -- IS
BASICALLY WHAT'S REFLECTED IN
THE TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN IT'S CHANGED A
LITTLE BIT OVER TIME -- REALLY A
KEY COMPONENT IS THAT THE
PROJECT IS DIVIDED INTO TWO MAIN
PHASES OF PHASE ONE WOULD GO
FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO ANAHEIM
IT'S A TO ANTICIPATED TO COST
ABOUT SEVENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS ALTHOUGH THERE'S A RANGE
THAT THE AUTHORITY IS PROVIDED.
AND THE COMPLETED BY -- TWENTY
THIRTY THREE THERE'S ALSO A
PHASE TWO WHICH WOULD EXTEND TO
SACRAMENTO AND ALSO TO SAN DIEGO --
CURRENTLY THERE'S NO SCHEDULER
COST ESTIMATE FOR THAT PHASE IF
YOU LOOK AT PAGE Q. WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A MAP THAT SHOWS PHASE ONE
AND THAT'S THE THE PORTION
THAT'S IN.
KIND OF A GRAY -- A GREAT AREA.
THEN PHASE ONE IS DIVIDED INTO
SEGMENTS -- YOU'LL SEE THAT'S
ACTUALLY SHOWN WITH THE LITTLE --
KIND OF THE THE EDGES THERE --
THE INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT IS
IS WHERE -- OPERATIONS ARE
INTENDED TO BE AGAIN THAT'S
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND
BAKERSFIELD -- AND THAT'S ALSO
KNOWN AS ABOUT ABOUT A LINE O
YOU'LL BE OF HEARD A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT AS WELL THAT'S
ANTICIPATED TO BE COMPLETED BY
TWENTY TWENTY NINE AND COST
ABOUT TWENTY NINE POINT FIVE
BILLION.
AND THEN THE INITIAL OPERATING
SEGMENT IS FURTHER AND DIVIDED --
WITH THE FIRST CONSTRUCTION
OCCURRING ON WHAT'S KNOWN AS THE
INITIAL CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT
THAT EXTENDS HERE AS YOU CAN SEE
IN THE DASHED LINE BETWEEN
MADERA.
AND CHAPTER.
THAT'S ANTICIPATED TO BE
COMPLETED BY TWENTY TWENTY TWO I
CAUGHT ABOUT TEN POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE TWO IF
YOU ALONG WITH A MAP WE JUST
MENTIONED THAT THERE'S A BOOK
AND THEN CONNECTIVITY PROJECTS
THESE ARE PROJECTS THAT.
ARE THE TORTILLAS UNDERTAKING
WITH LOCAL PARTNERS -- TO
IMPROVE THE USEFULNESS AND
FACILITATE CONNECTIVITY TO THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT YOU'LL
HEAR MORE ABOUT THAT ON A
SUBSEQUENT PANEL BUT JUST WANTED
TO REFERENCE THAT.
SO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE THREE WE
BRIEFLY SUMMARIZE THE THREE MAIN
SOURCES OF FUNDING THAT THE
PROJECT HAS RECEIVED.
SO THE FIRST ONE IS PROPOSITION
ONE A BOND FUNDS SO PROPOSITION
ONE A WAS APPROVED BY VOTERS IN
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT IT
PROVIDED TEN BILLION DOLLARS IN
GENERAL OBLIGATION BONDS NINE
BILLION WAS FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECT ITSELF.
ABOUT A BILLION WAS FOR
CONNECTIVITY PROJECTS AND THEN
THAT NINE BILLION -- WAS FURTHER
DIVIDED ABOUT ONE POINT ONE
BILLION WAS SET ASIDE FOR THOSE
BUT CAN PROJECTS THAT WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT LATER.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS APPROPRIATED
ABOUT FIVE POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OF THIS ABOUT TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION HAS BEEN SPENT
ABOUT TWO POINT ONE BILLION OF
THAT ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT ITSELF.
AT ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
ON THOSE CONNECT TO BE PROJECTS.
THE SECOND CATEGORY OF FUNDS
THAT THE PROJECT HAS RECEIVED I
THINK WE'LL PROBABLY BE TALKING
ABOUT THAT -- MORE TODAY IS THE
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS AWARDED THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY TO MAJOR
GRANTS TOTALING THREE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FIRST THE STATE
RECEIVED TWO POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
AND FROM THE AMERICAN RECOVERY
AND REINVESTMENT ACT OR ARE A
GRANT.
PROCESS.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IS
FULLY EXPENDED THESE FUNDS AND
IS ANTICIPATING MATCHING OF
THOSE FINES AND MEETING THAT
MATCH REQUIREMENT BY.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY
THEN SECOND THE STATE RECEIVED
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE MILLION FROM A SECOND GRANT
THAT'S OFTEN REFERRED TO AS THE
FY TEN FEDERAL GRANT.
THAT EXPIRES IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AS WE'VE HEARD THAT KIND OF
A KEY DATE FOR THE AUTHORITY --
THAT GRANT HAS OF RADIO
PROVISIONS AND REQUIREMENTS A
FEW THE KEY ONES INCLUDE THAT --
BEFORE THIS THE STATE CAN SPEND
THAT MONEY WE HAVE TO COMPUTER
MATCH ON THE AIRCRAFT SO THAT'S
WHY WE HAVEN'T SPENT ANY OF THAT
MONEY YET WE HAVEN'T COMPLETED
THAT MATCH -- BUT ONCE WE
COMPLETE THAT MUCH WE CAN ACCESS
THOSE FUNDS.
SECONDS THOSE FUNDS CAN HAVE TO
BE USED TO SUPPORT INTER CITY
RAIL PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE --
AND THEN THIRD WE HAVE TO
COMPLETE ALL THE ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS FOR PHASE ONE BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO SO WHETHER OR
NOT WE COMPLETE THE CONSTRUCTION
OF ALL PHASE ONE WE HAVE TO DO
ALL OF THAT -- BERMAN REVIEW
PROCESS.
THE AGREEMENT DOES HAVE SOME
PROVISIONS THAT ALLOW THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TERMINATE
THAT GRANT AGREEMENT -- FOR
EXAMPLE IF THE STATE FAILS TO
MAKE WHAT'S KNOWN AS REASONABLE
PROGRESS ON THE PROJECT.
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALERTED THE STATE THAT IT
INTENDED TO EXERCISE THAT
PROVISION AND TERMINATE THOSE
FUNDS -- AND THAT THAT
NOTIFICATION CAME IN FEBRUARY
THE AUTHORITY HAS RESPONDED WITH
A COUPLE OF LETTERS.
WITH A POINT BY POINT REBUTTAL
OF THAT -- BUT STILL THERE'S
SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT EXACTLY
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
GONNA DO WITH THOSE FUNDS AND SO
THE STATE IS IS IS WAITING TO TO
FIND A CONCLUSION ON ON WHAT
HAPPENS WITH THOSE FUNDS.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR WE
HIGHLIGHT THE THIRD MAIN SOURCE
OF FUNDS THAT'S AVAILABLE TO THE
AUTHORITY INTO THE PROJECT WHICH
IS CAP AND TRADE FUNDS AT CENTER
WHAT HOUSE YOU MENTIONED.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
STATE BEGAN TO PROVIDE CAP AND
TRADE AUCTION PROCEEDS TO THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT THIS
INCLUDES SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME CAP
AND TRADE FUNDS.
AS WELL AS CONTINUES
APPROPRIATION OF 25% OF REVENUES
I'M A NOT BEGAN AND AND TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SO TO DATE THE
PROJECT HAS RECEIVED ABOUT TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
CAP AND TRADE REVENUES AND SPENT
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FIVE WE HAVE
A A SUMMARY OF SOME OF THE
RECENT -- PROGRESS IN THAT AS
STATUS OF THE PROJECT FIRST WITH
REGARD TO ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS
THE AUTHORITY HAS TO COMPLY WITH
NOT ONLY THE STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL REGULATIONS
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACTORS
SEAQUEST.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW INCLUDING THE
NATIONAL ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
ACT OR NEED BACK.
WE'VE HEARD A LITTLE BIT FOR
REFERENCE TO THAT -- AND SOME OF
THAT THE CHALLENGES THE STATE'S
HAVING IN TERMS OF GETTING THE
ABILITY TO SORT OF A MINISTER
THAT PEACE.
BUT BOTH OF THOSE LAWS REQUIRE
THE AUTHORITY TO REVIEW THE
PROJECT TO DETERMINE IF IT COULD
POTENTIALLY HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT. TO THE
FORTY HAS COMPLETED A BUYER
MIDDLE REVIEWS OF MERCED TO
FRESNO AND FRESNO TO BAKERSFIELD
THOSE SECTIONS.
BUT IT'S STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
COMPLETING THE REMAINING REVIEWS
FOR PHASE.
ONE NEXT RIGHT OF WAY
ACQUISITION AND I BELIEVE
THERE'S ALSO REFERENCE TO THIS
IT'S A VERY COMPLICATED AND
DIFFICULT PORTION OF COMPLETING
ANY MAJOR FAT CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS SUCH AS THIS.
ONE THE AUTHORITY HAS IDENTIFIED
OVER EIGHTEEN HUNDRED SEPARATE
PARCELS JUST FOR THE INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT AND TODAY
HAS ACQUIRED OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED OF THOSE BUT THAT LEAVES
ABOUT.
FOUR HUNDRED OF THOSE PARCELS
THAT STILL NEED TO BE ACQUIRED.
WITH REGARD TO CONSTRUCTION THE
AUTHORITY -- BEGAN CONSTRUCTION
OF THAT INITIAL CONSTRUCTION
SEGMENT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN IS IT SPENT ALMOST FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS AT THREE POINT
NINE BILLION DOLLARS ON
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES.
I'D COMPLETED SOME MAJOR
STRUCTURES AND IT'S ALSO WHAT
REALIGNED A PORTION OF THE
NINETY NINE FREEWAY -- YOUR
FRESNO.
IF YOU TURN TO PAGE SIX WE
HIGHLIGHT FOR MAJOR ISSUES FOR
LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
THE FIRST ONE IS THAT THE
PROJECT FACES A SIGNIFICANT
FUNDING CAP AND YOU'VE HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT ALREADY
BUT THIS TABLE KIND OF SHOWS
SHOWS THE NUMBERS HERE THAT
WHICH HOPEFULLY WILL BE HELPFUL --
SO BASED ON THE NUMBERS IN THE
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN THERE'S A FUNDING
GAP PROBABLY HAVE ABOUT -- WELL
UPWARDS OF FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
OR MORE -- AT THE LOW END IT
COULD BE FIFTY FIVE BILLION AT
THE HIGH END MAYBE FIFTY EIGHT
BILLION -- AND IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TERMINATES THAT GRANT
FY TEN GRANT THAN THE FUNDING
GAP WOULD PROBABLY BE ABOUT A
NOT ANOTHER NINE HUNDRED MILLION.
A LARGER TO AT THIS TIME THE
AUTHORITY HASN'T IDENTIFIED HOW
THIS CHECKED FUNDING SHORTFALL
WOULD BE MATT.
AND THERE CERTAINLY SIGNIFICANT
RISK THAT THE STATE WOULD HAVE
TO COVER THE SHORTFALL I'M
PRIVATE FUNDING HASN'T YET
EMERGED -- SO IT'S LIKELY THAT
THE STATE THROUGH THE GENERAL
FUND OR THROUGH SOME OTHER --
MEANS IF THERE'S ANOTHER
AVAILABLE FUNDING SOURCES WOULD
LIKELY HAVE TO COVER THAT.
ALSO WE WOULD KNOW THAT THEIR
SIGNIFICANT -- UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
THAT THIS COST ESTIMATE -- THIS
IS A VERY LARGE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT THOSE TYPES OF PROJECTS
CAMERON -- AND YOU EXPERIENCE
COST OVERRUNS AND SO -- THERE'S
CERTAINLY A RISK THAT THAT THE
COST COULD BE ON THE HANDS
FEDERATION ONE OF THEM IS THE
PEER REVIEW GROUPS CONSISTS
CONCERNS ABOUT WHICH MISTER
THOMPSON MENTIONED --
ESSENTIALLY FOCUSING ON THE
CHALLENGE OF OF MOVING FORWARD
WITHOUT A RELIABLE AN ADEQUATE
FUNDING STREAM FOR THE PROJECT
GIVEN THAT AND GIVEN THAT
FUNDING GAP THAT WE TALKED ABOUT.
ALSO THE PEER REVIEW GROUP DID
IDENTIFY SOME POTENTIAL OPTIONS
FOR LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION.
I I I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THOSE
WORK AS EARLY -- TOTALLY
COMPREHENSIVE THERE ARE SOME
THINGS TO START THE CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT COULD BE DONE
CERTAINLY THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS AS WELL -- THE NEXT
ISSUE THAT WE WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THE GOVERNOR THE
SHIFT THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS --
HAS INDICATED HE'S MAKING IN
TERMS OF HIS HIS APPROACH TO
THIS PROJECT IN THAT STATE OF
THE STATE ADDRESS.
A AS IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT A
GREAT LIKE THERE'S SOME
UNCERTAINTY ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
THAT -- YOU APPROACH IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE -- HE DID MENTION THAT
THE PROJECT AS PLAN WOULD COST
TO MATCH AND TAKE TOO LONG --
AND HE EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR
STARTING WITH THIS MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD SECTIONS THAT EXPECT.
LARGER STRETCH THAN THE INITIAL
CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT BUT NOT THE
ENTIRE INITIAL OPERATING
SEGMENTS.
SO STARTING WITH THAT COMPLETING
THE BOOK IN PROJECTS THAT THE
LOCALS ARE UNDERTAKING AND
COMPLETING THAT ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK FOR PHASE ONE WHICH IS
REQUIRED FOR THE FEDERAL GRANTS --
AGAIN THE SPECIFICS OF THAT
PROPOSAL ARE UNCERTAIN WE'RE
EXPECTING TO SEE MORE IN MAY AND
PERHAPS THAT OR YOU CAN ALSO
PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ON THAT.
SO THE FOURTH ISSUE -- THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO HIGHLIGHT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S A CONSIDERATION IS
THAT THIS SHIFT IN AN PLAN AND
APPROACH THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
MAKING WE THINK REALLY PROVIDES
THE LEGISLATURE WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY A STEP BACK.
AND CONSIDER.
WHAT IT WOULD LIKE TO DO AND HOW
THE PROJECT WISE WITH ITS
PRIORITIES -- GIVEN THE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING GAP WE DO
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER --
WHETHER IT'S COMFORTABLE FINDING
THOSE REVENUES WHEN THEY'RE
CERTAINLY A VARIETY OF WAYS THAT
THEY COULD BE GENERATED
ADDITIONAL REVENUE COULD BE
GENERATED ORG OR OTHER
PRIORITIES COULD BE SHIFTED.
BUT IT'S A SIGNIFICANT FUNDING
GAP AND SO THE LEGISLATURE WANT
TO THINK ABOUT WHETHER IT IS
COMFORTABLE PROVIDING THOSE
FUNDS -- IF NOT IT WILL WANT TO
CONSIDER.
VARIOUS OTHER APPROACHES AND
THAT THAT COULD BE THE GOT WHAT
THE GOVERNOR HAS SUGGESTED IT
COULD BE ONE OF THE ALTERNATIVES
THE PEER REVIEW GROUP BOB
POINTED OUT.
IT COULD BE SOME ALTERNATIVE
APPROACH -- BUT WE DO THINK THAT
IT MAKES SENSE TO TRY.
TO MAKE SOME -- SOME CLEAR
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE THE
STATE'S GOING TO GO ON THIS
PROJECT SO WE DON'T END UP I'M
SPENDING MONEY ON ACTIVITIES
ULTIMATELY WE DECIDED NOT. TO
MAKE YOU SEVEN THE FUTURE AS WE
THINK THOSE DECISIONS HOPEFULLY
INFORMED BY THE INFORMATION THAT
WE RECEIVE IN MAY -- WILL BE
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE STATE
TO UNDERTAKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE CAN ASK A FEW QUESTIONS NOW
OF COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- OF BLUE
TARPS AND IN TERMS OF OPTIONS
WE'RE WHAT DO YOU SEE AS A BASIC
OPTIONS WE HAVE.
AT THIS POINT -- COMING FROM
YOUR PERSPECTIVE.
TIONS FOR SCOPE OR FOR PAYING
FOR THIS GOAL AND HOW HOW.
HOW SHOULD WE PROCEED?
AT THIS POINT -- TO OF DEAL WITH%
THE ISSUES AT HAND THE LACK OF
FUNDING FOR THE WHOLE PROJECT.
OF THE GOVERNOR YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR'S TRYING.
TO COME UP WITH A REVISION TO
THE BUSINES PLAN.
WHAT KIND OF OPTIONS SHOULD WE
LOOK AT BEFORE YOU MAKE THAT
FINALDECISION?
I WISH I THOUGHT I COULD ANSWER
THAT QUESTION AND IT AND OF
COURSE ARE GOING ON AND ANY.
USE BUT WHAT WHAT WE RECOMMEND
pIS THAT YOU ASK THE STATE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION TO
WORK WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. TO TELL YOU WHAT THE
FUTURE OF RAILPASSENGER
TRANSPORTATION AND CALIFORNIA
SHOULD LOOK LIKE INCLUDING HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
BUT NOT ONLY HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
I EMPHASIZE THAT WHAT IS THAT
WHAT SHOULD THE SYSTEM LOOK LIKE
AND WHAT ROLE SHOULD A HIGH
SPEED RAIL PLAY.
I THINK THE SECOND THING IS NOT
TO GET TOO HUNG UP ON DOING IT
RIGHT AWAY.
THE END OF THE DISH THAT WE CAN
TAKE OUR TIME WE CAN PLAN FOR IT
WE CAN TAKE SEVERAL YEARS OR
MULTIPLE YEARS IF WE NEED.
TO AND THEN THE THIRD THING IS --
I WOULD I WOULD CITE THE FEDERAL
INTERSTATE HIGHWAY PROGRAM IS
BEING ONE OF THE BEST EXAMPLES
FOR HOW TO DO A SYSTEM LIKE THIS
AND THAT IS.
THEY HAVE AN OVERALL VIEW OF
WHAT THEY WANTED TO DO THEY HAD
A FUNDING MECHANISM THAT THEY
COULD RELY ON FROM YEAR TO YEAR
THEY HAD TO ADJUST SCOPE TO
FUNDING FROM TIME TO TIME.
BUT THEY HAD A FUNDING WRECKED
MECHANISM THAT THEY COULD RELY
ON SO PEOPLE THE MANAGERS COULD
HIRE PEOPLE THAT CAN TRAIN THEM.
THEY COULD MAKE COMMITMENTS TO
CONTRACTS THEY COULD LIVE UP TO
THOSE CONTRACTS THEY DIDN'T HAVE
TO CHANGE THE SCOPE OF THE
PROGRAM EVERY OTHER YEAR WHEN
THEY WERE.
WERE RUNNING UP AGAINST A HARD
BUDGET CONSTRAINT THAT IS NO WAY
TO MANAGER PROJECT.
SO -- WHICH OF THE ALTERNATIVES
I SUGGESTED I THINK DEPENDS ON
WHICH JERRY WANT TO HIDE BEHIND
BUT BUT ONE WAY OR THE OTHER
SOME STABLE SOURCE AND
PREDICTABLE SOURCE OF FUNDING SO
THAT THE PROJECT CAN BE MANAGED
RESPONSIBLY.
IS IS ABSOLUTELY VITAL.
I LIKE THIS STATE ORDER QUESTION --
OF DO YOU SEE PROGRESS -- ARE
YOU SATISFIED THE PROGRESS IN
COMPLETING -- THE RESPONSE TO
YOUR AUDIT AND ARE THE
PROCEEDING -- DILIGENTLY AND
RESPONDING TO THE CONCERNS --
AND RECOMMENDATIONS MADE IN YOUR
AUDIT.
SO MR TRAIL OF FEEL THAT -- YES
THE THIRTIES BEEN
EXTRAORDINARILY COMMUNICATIVE
WITH US LEADING UP TO THE SIXTY
DAY PERIOD AND ACTUALLY AND
SINCE THAT TIME.
AS WE AGREE TO BEING IN A YOU
KNOW HAVING A HIGH LEVEL OF
COMMUNICATION APPROACHING THE
SIX MONTH MARK.
AS I SAID.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE PROGRESS TO SHOW --
THAT THEY PARTIALLY IMPLEMENTED
TEN OF SEVENTEEN RECOMMENDATIONS
ALREADY THEY EXPRESSED
REPEATEDLY AN INTENTION TO GET
AS MANY OF THOSE THAT --
RECOMMENDATIONS FOLLOWING THE
IMPLEMENTED BY THE SIX MONTH
MARK AS POSSIBLE.
NOW WITH RESPECT TO THE THE
RECOMMENDATION RE REGARDING
REPORTING TO TO YOU THE
LEGISLATURE -- THEY HAVE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH US.
ON A ONE ON ONE ON ONE AND WITH
OTHERS IN ORDER TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE IS COMFORTABLE
WITH THE THE AMOUNT OF DETAIL
METHODOLOGY USE THERE.
OUGHT TO ENSURE THAT IT IS
USEFUL AS POSSIBLE TO THE POLICY
MAKERS AND TO THE PUBLIC SO YES
THAT THERE'S BEEN A HIGH LEVEL
OF COMMITMENT FROM THEM AND AND
WELL THAT'S BEEN.
ENCOURAGING AS WE GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS -- NOT LA --
QUESTIONS FOR YOU WHAT KIND OF
OPTIONS SHOULD WE BE LOOKING OUT.
FOR THIS PROJECT IN YOUR OPINION
AND YOU -- HOW HOW WHEN YOU
REVIEW THE -- THE NINE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT -- IS BEING JEOPARDIZED AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
DO YOU SEE ANY AVENUES.
FOR OF MAKING SURE THAT -- JUST
ON A LOGICAL BASIS -- THAT WE
MEET HE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
TO OF RETAIN THAT THOSE FUNDS --
THAT SEEM TO BE IN JEOPARDY.
OUR N. IN ON TALK I I DON'T I
DON'T WANT TO ADD A SHIP
QUESTION FROM A POLITICAL
STANDPOINT.
BUT A RATIONAL STAFFS EMPLOYED
OKAY.
DO WE MEET THE REQUIREMENTS IS
IT.
THE PROCESS NORMALLY. TO TO SIT
DOWN AND WORK OUT THE THESE
KINDS OF THINGS -- AND HOW HOW.
HOW CLOSE ARE WE TO MEETING THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THOSE GRANT
AGREEMENTS?
SO -- WITH REGARD TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION IT SEEMS LIKE ALL THE
OPTION SHOULD BE ON THE TABLE IN
TERMS OF PROCEEDING -- AND SOME
OF THEM HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED --
BY OTHERS I'D BE THE GOVERNOR'S
SERVED IDEA FOR EXAMPLE GOING
FOR MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD THAT'S
THAT'S CERTAINLY AN OPTION THAT
WOULD CONNECT TO THE A STRAIN TO
POTENTIALLY BECAUSE THE ACE --
CURRENT DAYS TRAIN IS EXPECTED
TO EXTENDED SERVICE TO MERCED SO
THAT WOULD PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL CONNECTIVITY OF IT
WOULD ALSO PROBABLY BE KIND OF
WITHIN THE RANGE OF OF THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT THAT.
IS CURRENTLY AVAILABLE FOR THE
PROJECT AND THEN CONNECTING DOWN
TO BAKERSFIELD WOULD CONNECT TO
ANOTHER -- KIND POPULATION
CENTER SO THAT'S WHAT CERTAINLY
ONE OPTION IS CERTAINLY NOT THE
ONLY OPTION -- THE PART AT THE
STATE COULD -- STOP AFTER THE
INITIAL CONSTRUCTION SEGMENT AND
WE COULD TIE IN TO THE TO THE
EXISTING SAN JOAQUIN SERVICE
THAT'S ONE OF THE OPTIONS THAT
THE PEER REVIEW GROUP I
MENTIONED -- ADDITIONALLY YOU
COULD TAKE ONE OF THOSE I MEAN
YOU COULD JUST EXTEND UP DIDN'T
MERCED OR JUST DOWN TO
BAKERSFIELD -- YOU COULD DO MORE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE BAY AREA OR
IN THE LA AREA -- I MEAN THERE
ARE A WHOLE HOST YOU COULD
IMPROVE SERVICE SACRAMENTO -- SO
I THINK THERE ARE A WHOLE HOST
OF DIFFERENT ALTERNATIVES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PROBABLY SHOULD
CONSIDER-- IT DOES SEEM LIKE.
WE WILL HAVE HOPEFULLY MORE
INFORMATION IN MAY FOR THERE'S
SUPPOSED TO BE AN EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR OF PROVIDING
INFORMATION ON RIDERSHIP ON
THROUGH FEASIBILITY -- ISSUES OF
FOR SOME OF THESE DIFFERENT
OPTIONS AND SO I THINK OUR HOPE
IS THAT THE INFORMATION THAT'S
PROVIDED IN MAY WILL HELP INFORM
THE LEGISLATURE'S DECISION ABOUT
WHICH OF THESE OPTIONS TO PURSUE.
ULTIMATELY IT'S GOING TO BE A
POLICY CHOICE THINKING ABOUT THE
RELATIVE COST OF THOSE -- AND
THERE'S YOU KNOW QUITE A BIT OF
DIFFERENCE IN COST TO THERE AS
WELL AS THE MOBILITY BENEFITS
AND ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
AND OTHER KINDS OF ECONOMIC
BENEFITS.
OF FOR THESE IT PRIDE IF YOU
KNOW THIS PROJECT VERSES YOU
KNOW WHAT THE OPPORTUNITY COST
OF THESE BUTTONS -- WHAT ARE THE
OTHER KINDS OF IMPROVEMENTS I
THINK -- MISTER THOMPSON'S
COMMENT TO ABOUT HOW THIS FITS
IN WITH THE THE STATE'S LARGER
WELL PLANS MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
SO I THINK ALL THOSE THINGS --
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED PROBABLY
NONE OF THESE OPTIONS SHOULD BE
OFF THE TABLE -- IT'S ONE OF
THOSE THINGS THAT WE WE PROBABLY
JUST NEED TO SORT OF STEP BACK
AND THINK ABOUT -- GOING FORWARD
WHICH ONE MEET THE STATE'S NEEDS
THE PAST IN WHICH ONE MATCHES UP
BEST WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES
FOR THOSE FUNDS -- WITH REGARD
TO YOUR SECOND QUESTION ABOUT
THE NINE HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE
MILLION OF THE AUTHORITY DID
PROVIDE A PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE
UPPER BOTTLES TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S.
A LETTER AND REALLY -- KIND OF
OUTLINED ALL OF THE THINGS THAT
THE STATE HAS DONE -- SO I THINK
THAT IT SEEMS THAT THEY PROVIDED
A PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE
DESCRIPTION OF SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE THAT SEEM
TO BE COUNTER TO WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- HAD ARGUED
AND AT LEAST I'M NOT AN ATTORNEY
BUT IT SEEMED LIKE THEY MADE
SOME SOME PRETTY -- PRETTY
STRONG ARGUMENTS ON THAT POINT
OF COURSE THERE IS SOME -- THE
WAY THAT THE GRANT AGREEMENT IS
WRITTEN PROVIDE SOME KIND OF
GRAY AREA WHAT IS REASONABLE
PROGRESS I'M AGAIN NOT AN
ATTORNEY BUT IT SEEMS LIKE
REASONABLE MINDS CAN DISAGREE
ABOUT WHAT CONSTITUTES
REASONABLE PROGRESS AND SO.
SOME OF IT MAY ULTIMATELY BE --
YOU KNOW UNFORTUNATELY MAY
ULTIMATELY BE LITIGATED IF
ULTIMATELY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DECIDES.
TO CONTINUE FORWARD WITH THAT
PATH AND THEN IT WOULD BE --
ANNA HE WOULD BE A CHALLENGER --
HE WOULD COULD MAKE THAT
DETERMINATION BUT IT DOES SEEM
THAT THE STATE HAS ON AT THE
AUTHORITY HAS HAS PUT TOGETHER A
PRETTY COMPREHENSIVE REBUTTAL.
TO THOSE ARGUMENTS -- IN TERMS
OF THE THE STATUS OF THAT --
JUST BASED ON MY EXPERIENCE
PERHAPS SOME OF YOU CAN COMMENT --
WHEN THERE'S?
THESE KIND OF MAYBE
DISAGREEMENTS ABOUT.
THE GRANT CONDITIONS.
AND THOSE KINDS OF THINGS BASED
ON MY EXPERIENCE THE SIT DOWN
WORK COME OUT.
AND THEN THEY HAVE A A LIKED OUT
FIRST BEFORE.
THERE'S SOME KIND OF CONCLUSION --
A KIND OF APPROACH WHERE THEY
JUST SAY THE GRANTS GOING TO BE
CANCELLED -- I THINK THAT PART
OF THE DISCUSSION IS KIND OF
MISSING HERE -- AND THAT'S WHY I
ASKED THE QUESTION OF HOW.
IT CLOSE THE SEEM TO BE OR
THERE'S THE YOU THINK IT'S WHERE
THE ISSUES THAT YOU FELT.
OR PERHAPS THE OTHER PANELISTS
FELT THE COULD BE WORKED OUT IF
THERE WAS A STRONGER ATTEMPT TO
DO SO.
I DON'T KNOW -- MAYBE YOU CAN
COMMERCE HELLO.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT ROLE FAX
PLAYED IN THIS DECISION AND WE
DON'T WANT TO CONSIDER THAT BUT
THAT THAT.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
POLITICAL SCENE THERE IS THERE
IS HEART TALKING ABOUT.
WHEN YOU DO GRANTS FOR A TRANSIT
PROJECT?
YOU KNOW LIKE IT WHETHER IT'S LA
OR DETROIT OR NEW YORK WHEN THEY
HAVE.
SERVE A DIFFERENCE ON THE
PROJECT -- CONDITIONS OF THE
GRANT.
USUALLY THERE'S A PERIOD OF TIME
WERE.
THERE'S A DISCUSSION TO WORK OUT --
THOSE DIFFERENCES AND PEOPLE ARE
GIVEN TIME AND I'VE TALKED TO
MANY PEOPLE.
ABOUT THIS OF GONE THROUGH THE
GRANTS PROCESS.
AND I THINK THIS PERIOD OF TIME
WHERE THERE'S THIS.
DISCUSSION THAT TAKES PLACE IS
MISSING.
HERE SO I WANT TO FIND OUT WHAT
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT IF YOU
HAVE ANY THERE'S NO DOUBT IN MY
MIND THAT IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WNTS.
TO NEGOTIATE A SETTLEMENT.
A SETTLEMENT AS POSSIBLE.
I DON'T I DON'T DOUBT THAT I
WANTED IN ONE PIECE OF
EMPHASISED -- OF WHAT -- THIS
KIRSTEIN SAID [inaudible]
OPTIONS.
LET ME URGE YOU TO ASK FOR
OPTIONS IN WHATEVER INFORMATION
YOU GET IN THE PAST YOU'VE
TENDED TO GET A RECOMMENDATION
OR THIS IS WHAT WE WANT TO DO.
WITHOUT KNOWING WILL WATER MY
CHOICES WHAT ELSE COULD I DO AN
HOUR LATER A YEAR AGO.
WE TRIED TO LAY OUT FOR OPTIONS
THOSE WERE NOT MEANT TO BE THE
ONLY OPTIONS BUT THEY WERE MEANT
TO REPRESENT THE FACT THAT YOU
DO HAVE CHOICES.
AND WHATEVER YOU CONSIDER IN THE
FUTURE.
I URGE YOU TO ASK FOR ONE OF MY
CHOICES NOT WITH IS JUST ONE
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
OKAY.
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THE
GRANT SUIT.
I FIGURE PROJECTS LIKE THE
BOSTON.
TRANSIT PROJECT IN YORK SUBWAY
PROJECT THE SEATTLE PROJECT.
I CAN GO ON AND ON AND ON WHERE
THERE WAS PROBLEMS WITH THE
PROJECTS.
LOT OF PROBLEMS [inaudible]
BUT IN EACH CASE THERE WAS A
DISCUSSION AND THERE WAS A
PROCESS.
TO TRY TO RESOLVE.
THE GRANTS -- CONDITIONS AND
WORK OUT A SOLUTION LIKE THAT
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT ON THAT NOT MUCH ELSE TO
ADD BEYOND WHAT WAS YOUR TIMES
IMAGE I THINK THAT YOU KNOW HE'S
HE'S CORRECT IN HIS.
ASSESSMENT -- IN MANY WAYS I
THINK IT'S ONE OF THOSE THINGS
THAT PERHAPS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COULD IT'S COULD
CERTAINLY COME TO AGREE WITH
THAT I THINK THAT ISSUES THAT
THEY RAISED WERE NOT UNUSUAL
ISSUES FOR PROJECTS -- YES THE
PROJECT'S BEEN DELAYED SOMEWHAT.
PROJECTS ARE DELAYED -- YOU KNOW
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS --
CERTAINLY THE PROJECT MADE
PROGRESS A LONG LIST OF PROJECTS
HAVE BEEN DELAYED I'LL TELL YOU
THAT RIGHT NOW IT'S VERY YEAH
VERY TRUE AND AND SO IT IT DOES
SEEM LIKE.
THESE ARE NOT NECESSARILY ISSUES
THAT COULDN'T BE OVERCOME IF
THERE WAS -- AN INTEREST -- BUT
BUT THEY'RE PROBABLY HAS TO BE
AN INTEREST ON THE PART OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT -- OTHERWISE
IF THEY IF THEY CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD -- NEAR MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE AUTHORITY IS
PREPARED. TO TAKE LEGAL ACTION
IF THEY IF THEY IF THEY ARE IF
THEY END UP -- TRYING TO TAKE
BACK THOSE FUNDS THAT THE STATE
FEELS A WE WE A HAVE A CLAIM.
TO THERE'S A MOVIE THAT IS IN
THE BEST INTERESTS OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO TRY TO
RECONCILE.
ON THOSE GRANTS AND TRY TO
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE THE NINE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS.
SO THAT WE DON'T LOSE THAT MONEY --
I I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN YOUR
ARCHER THE GRAND CELEBRATION
COMMITTEE OF THE THAT THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION.
SITTING WAS THE CENTER DODD AND
OTHERS -- WE ALWAYS TRY TO
MAINTAIN THAT -- IF THERE IS
SOME SCHEDULE CHANGES ARE SOME
ISSUES THAT HAD TO BE DEALT WITH.
THAT WE WOULD SIT DOWN TO
RESOLVE THEM.
AND TAKE THE PROJECT MOVING
ALONG SO WE CAN COMPLETE THE
PROJECT.
AND MAYBE EVEN CATCH UP AND IF
THE PROJECT ON TIME AND ON
BUDGET -- AND WE HAVE DONE THAT
MANY CASES IN CALIFORNIA -- IT
SEEMS WE NEED TO HAVE THAT
ATTITUDE HERE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN MY OPINION.
AND WE ARE BOTH NEED TO HAVE
THAT -- TOO SO WE CAN.
GET DOWN TO BUSINESS AND FIGURE
OUT HOW.
TO SOLVE RESOLVE THIS IT WOULD.
I JUST ANOTHER.
COMMENT AS LOOKING AT THE
PICTURE OF FEDERAL MONEY THAT
COMES TO CALIFORNIA WE DON'T
REALLY GET OUR FAIR SHARE
ACCORDING TO THE FORMULAS.
OF TAXES THAT'S NEVER.
BEEN TRUE THAT CALIFORNIA'S GUN
IT'S FOR SURE BASED ON THE
FORMULA ALLOCATIONS.
BUT WE ALWAYS MADE UP A LITTLE
BIT OF THAT DEFICIT.
BY GETTING GRANTS FOR VARIOUS
PROJECTS AND SO AT THE END OF
THE DAY THE NAT.
WOULD BE CLOSE TO GETTING YOU
KNOW THE IT NEVER.
EXCEEDED BUT CLOSE TO GETTING --
OVER A LONG RANGE FOR THE TIME
THE AMOUNT OF TAXES THAT
CALIFORNIANS THE IN TWO OF THE
FEDERAL TRANSIT FUNDS.
WE NEVER REALLY RETRIEVE THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OVER TIME BUT JUST.
TO BY GETTING GRANTS FOR VARIOUS
PROJECTS SUCH AS THIS -- ONE WE
MANAGED -- TO GET CLOSER TO THE
100%.
pHAD A 100% WE MIGHT A FEW YEARS
BUT I THINK THAT'S KIND OF THE
WAY I LOOK AT THIS IN A BIG.
BIGGER PICTURE FOR GOVERNOR IN
THOUGH MY COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE.
EVEN OUR CONGRESSIONAL
DELEGATION SHOULD BE.
ADVANCING THE PRINCIPLE THAT
CALIFORNIA FIGURES FOR SURE OF
THE FEDERAL TRANSPORTATION FUNDS.
AND NOT LOSE TRANSPORTATION
FUNDS IT'S IS -- IT'S NOT FAIR
TO OUR TAXPAYERS IN CALIFORNIA.
TO PAY TAXES IN AND NOT.
HAVE SOME PROJECT.
FUNDING TAKEN AWAY WITHOUT.
THAT KIND OF CONSIDERATION.
AND NOW I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS ON THAT.
NOW FOR CAKE CENTER WHAT
CALZAGHE'S ARE RUBIO AS ALWAYS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OPTIONS.
SHOULD OF THIS THREAT OF LOSS OF
FEDERAL FUNDS TO NINE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION DOLLARS COME TO
PASS.
WHAT OPTIONS WITH WE HAVE A
COVER THAT?
OR WITH THE LA OF PINE.
CERTAINLY SO -- SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WOULD BE NEEDED -- TO TO
COVER THAT GAP AND THAT COULD BE
THE GENERAL FUND -- IT COULD BE
EXISTING TAX REVENUES IT COULD
BE NEW TAXES -- OR OTHER KINDS
OF FUND SOURCES SUCH AS THAT I
MEAN IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THERE
WILL BE ADDITIONAL FUNDS
AVAILABLE IN THE FUTURE FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR PRIVATE
INVESTORS BUT I THINK IT'S WAS
REFERENCED -- AT THIS POINT
THOSE -- THOSE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING SOURCES HAVE NOT A
MERGED AND IT'S NOT CLEAR WINNER
IF THEY THEY WELL AND SO --
PARTICULARLY FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION COMPONENTS SO IT
SEEMS LIKELY THAT THE STATE
WOULD HAVE TO YOU KNOW FIND SOME
ADDITIONAL REVENUE STREAM AND
WHETHER THAT BE THE GENERAL FUND
OR SOME ADDITIONAL NEW.
TAXES.
A SO RUBIO THANK YOU.
NOT A LOT OF PERMISSION AHEAD
COMING OUR WAY BUT I JUST WANT
TO GO BACK TO I BELIEVE MISS.
CHRISTIAN STATED EARLIER I
BELIEVE YOU SAID ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES IS THE
UNCERTAINTY OF THE COST.
NOT BELIEVE YOU STATED ALO THAT
IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO BE IN THE
HIGHER AND AND I THOUGHT I HEARD
MISTER THOMPSON SUGGESTS THAT WE
NEEDED.
TO WELL MAYBE THE BEST COURSE OF
ACTION WOULD BE TO SLOW DOWN AND
TAKE OUR TIME I'M JUST WONDERING
IN TERMS OF JUST ANY GENERAL
PROJECT.
THE LONGER WE WAIT THEN YOU HAVE
TO ACCOUNT -- FOR THE HIGH COST
OF MATERIALS LABOR.
I JUST WONDER HOW DO WE
RECONCILED THE BOTH WAITING FOR
THE PROJECT AND THEN THE HIGH
COSTS HOW DO YOU ACCOUNT FOR
THAT I'M JUST A LITTLE CURIOUS
TO SEE IF YOU'RE.
TAKING THAT INTO ACCOUNT.
WELL IT'S ALWAYS A BALANCE.
OF THEIRS IS SITTING IN
CONSTRUCTION YOU WANT IT BAD YOU
GET IT BAD.
AND SO YOU HAVE TO HAVE THIS
BALANCE BETWEEN BEING PREPARED
AND HAVING EVERYTHING ORGANIZED
IN AWARDING CONTRACTS OF THE
RIGHT SIZE AND HAVING THE RIGHT
MANAGER YOU'LL CAPABILITY.
AND THE EXPOSURE YOU HAVE DO
INFLATION.
THIS YEAR EVERY YEAR OF
INFLATION THIS PROJECT IS
EXPOSED TO IS ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS BUT AS FOR THE COST OF
THE PROJECT ROUGHLY.
WHICH TELLS YOU SOMETHING ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL EDUCATION YOU
MIGHT WANT TO THINK ABOUT BUT
BUT NO IT'S A BALANCE YOU DON'T
WANT TO RUSH IN YOU DON'T WANT
TO GO TO GO OFF BEFORE YOU'RE
PREPARED TO GO YOU DON'T WANT.
TO TO GET PUT THE CART BEFORE
THE HORSE AS I SAID BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IDEALLY YOU'D LIKE TO
GET IT THE PROJECT DONE IN A
REASONABLE PLAN THE MANAGEABLE
WAY.
THERE IS SUCH A THING AS GOING
TOO FAST THERE IS SUCH A THING
AS HAVING SO MUCH MONEY OUT
THERE THAT YOU CAN'T MANAGE IT
WITHOUT THE RESOURCES YOU HAVE
AVAILABLE -- BUT GOOD PROJECT
MANAGERS KNOW HOW TO DO THAT IF
THEY KNOW WHAT THE RESOURCES ARE
AND IF THEY CAN DEPEND ON THEM
IF THEY CAN PLAN AROUND -- STONE
SIR GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- YOU
KNOW THE THE CARD BACKS ARE ARE
CERTAINLY CONCERNED A NINE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
CERTAINLY A CONCERN AND AND ONE
THING MISTER HERMAN I'VE I'VE
I'VE MENTIONED AND IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS THAT WE'VE HAD A
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THAT WE NEED --
TO BE A LITTLE BIT KINDLER AND
GENTLER TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WITH RESPECT -- TO
LAWSUITS ARE FILED AGAINST
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ARE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FILES LAWSUITS ABOUT
ONCE A WEEK.
AND SO I WOULD SAY THAT THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS EXTREMELY STRAINED
AND I DON'T THINK UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE'VE BEEN
WITNESSING OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS THAT.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
GOING TO BE ANY BETTER --
SENSITIVE -- TO HELP BEING AS
BILL OUT OF A PROJECT THAT HAS
BEEN.
FRANKLY MISMANAGED -- AND AND
AND NOT PLANNED WELL
[inaudible]
AND SO -- THE MESSAGE I GOT FROM
OUR GOVERNOR IN THE STATE OF THE
STATE ADDRESS IS THAT THIS
PROJECT IS NOT GOING TO COME TO
FRUITION ANYTIME SOON.
AND IS A GIGANTIC PROJECT AND
WHILE I UNDERSTAND HIS NEED TO
COMPLETE A SEGMENT BETWEEN
BAKERSFIELD MERCED TO PRESERVE
WHAT FEDERAL FUNDING IS COMING
THAT PROBABLY WAS PROBABLY A
WISE ALTERNATIVE IN A WISE
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible] FOR
HIM.
I'VE NEVER UNDERSTOOD -- EVEN
BEFORE I CAME IN THE LEGISLATURE
WHY WE START A SEGMENT FROM
BAKERSFIELD NORTH -- TO RESET
AND THEN THE SAN FRANCISCO
INSTEAD OF STARTING IN A MORE
POPULATED AREA LIKE MAYBE GOING
FROM SAN FRANCISCO -- SOUTH FOR
LOS ANGELES SOUTH THE ANAHEIM.
BECAUSE MAYBE THE AUDITOR IN THE
ALLEY -- CAN ANSWER THIS
QUESTION THAT THAT IF WE BUILT
THOSE SEGMENTS.
THE ACTUARIAL COST OF A TICKET.
BUT PROBABLY HAVE A LOT LESS.
THAN WITH THE ACTUARIAL COSTS
ARE GOING TO BE IF WE COME TO
THE CONCLUSION BETWEEN
BAKERSFIELD IMMERSE THAT.
KNOWS WANTING IF YOU'VE DONE ANY
ANALYSIS ON THAT AT ALL SO WITH
THOSE ACTUARIAL COSTS WILL BE.
TALKING ABOUT A PROJECT AS CLOSE
TO A HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS NOW.
BUT NOBODY'S TALKING ABOUT OKAY
IF WE INCREASE WE INVEST THAT
KIND OF MONEY WHAT IS THE
ACTUARIAL COST IS GONNA BE FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR THE STATE TO
BREAK EVEN. TO GO FROM LOS
ANGELES TO SACRAMENTO VERSUS
GETTING ON A FLIGHT FOR SIXTY
NINE DOLLARS -- OR TWO HUNDRED
FORTY NINE DOLLARS AT THE STATE
PAYS FOR US THEY PAY FULL PRICE
FOR THE PRO FOR THOSE TICKETS --
OBVIOUSLY THE STATE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO SUBSIDIZE THE COST OF
THESE TICKETS WHICH IS NOT
UNCOMMON FOR GOVERNMENTS TO
SUBSIDIZE PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
IS DONE.
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA'S DONE
THROUGHOUT EUROPE -- SO I WOULD
LIKE TO GET YOUR OPINION ON
THOSE.
WE HAVEN'T DONE IN AN
INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS OF THE
AMOUNT THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED
PERHAPS -- AS IT AS IT NAM
SUBSIDY TO OPERATE THE DIFFERENT
SEGMENTS -- AND HOPEFULLY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AND IN
MAY WILL PROVIDE SOME ADDITIONAL
RIDERSHIP DATA THAT'LL HELP
UNDERSTAND BETTER WHAT THOSE --
WHAT THOSE WOULD BE BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING AT LEAST IS THAT
FROM THE DECISIONS TO START A
CENTRAL VALLEY -- WERE RELATED
TO THE SOME OF THE FEDERAL
FUNDING REQUIREMENTS AND AND
TRYING TO MEET THOSE -- AND I
AND THE STATE TOOK A NUMBER OF
STEPS AS WAS REFERENCED I TO TRY
TO MEET THE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS --
IN ADDITION I THINK THERE WAS
SOME THOUGHT AS I UNDERSTAND IT
THAT THAT WOULD BE -- PERHAPS A
MORE DURABLE SEGMENT ON SOME OF
THAT THE SEGMENTS. FIVE FOR
EXAMPLE I'M IN THE LA AREA AS
WELL AS IN THE BAY AREA REQUIRE
TUNNELING AND SOME MORE
DIFFICULT -- KINDS OF
ENGINEERING WORK THAT I THINK
HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED TO BE MORE
CHALLENGING THAN.
THE RELATIVELY FLAT CONSTRUCTION
IN AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY SO I
THINK THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
FACTORS THAT WENT INTO THE
DECISION TO START THEIR PROBABLY
THE ABILITY OPERATE WITHOUT A
SUBSIDY -- YET AS A STANDALONE-SEGMENT WAS NOT WAS NOT THE READ
THE MAIN REASON -- BECAUSE IT
DOES SEEM LIKE THAT WOULD BE
MORE DIFFICULT WITH THAT CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT THEN.
PERHAPS A SEGMENT THAT THAT
MIGHT HAVE MORE RIDERSHIP YEAH
THAT THAT CERTAINLY ISN'T GOING
TO BE ONE OF MY CONCERNS THAT --
WITH IF WE WERE TO GET THIS
THING BUILT ON THE ACTUAL COST
OF THE TICKET IS GOING TO BE --
ASTRONOMICAL -- AND THEN BUT I I
STILL BELIEVE THAT IF WE'RE
pPROJECT I AGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR WE SHOULD BE BREAKING
IT UP INTO SEGMENTS MAKING MAYBE
THREE OR FOUR SECONDS FIVE
SEGMENTS AND BUILDING IT AS WE
CAN AFFORD TO BUILD AND
CERTAINLY PRESERVE.
FROM THE FUNDING WE'RE WE
CERTAINLY CAN BUT I WOULD JUST
GET -- CAUTION THE THE THE STATE
TO STOP KICKING PRESIDENT TRUMP
IN THE GROWING EVERY TIME YOU
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY -- TO LET'S
TRY TO WORK WITH HIM.
AND MAYBE MISTER CHAIRMAN WE GET
A SUBCOMMITTEE OF SOME
REPUBLICANS ALBEIT WERE A
MINORITY HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT WE HAVE THE KEY.
TO GETTING INTO THE WHITE HOUSE
IF WE NEED TO GET IN THERE AND
YOU KNOW WHAT WE ALL WANT.
GOOD THINGS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE'VE GOT TO WORK
COOPERATIVELY TOGETHER TO GET
WHAT WE NEED. TO TO BUILD A
FIRST CLASS TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SO I I WELCOME THAT
OPPORTUNITY -- JUST RESPOND TO
MR CENTER STONE -- THOUGHTS ON
THERE ARE -- OF COURSE.
SIR WORK HOURS CAN I COME FROM
THE GREAT MENTOR THAT WE HAD --
ON ON EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE TWO GERMANS -- WERE
MENTORED.
BY -- CONGRESSMAN AND THEN
SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION
NORMAN MINETA.
AND NORMAN MINETA THIS STYLE WAS.
TO WORK ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS
WITH THE THE MINORITY -- A
MEMBER IN THE PUBLIC WORKS
COMMITTEE -- WORK WITH THE
MEMBER ON WAS ACCEPTABLE IN
TERMS OF A MAJOR PROPOSAL.
AND HE OFTEN GOT OVER FOUR
HUNDRED VOTES FOR HIS -- ICED
TEA SURFACE TRANSPORTATION BILLS.
OUR HE WENT AND VISITED
EVERYBODY'S DISTRICT -- BY THE
WAY I DO THAT IS YOU KNOW.
AND I TAKE HIS -- STYLE
LEADERSHIP -- AND I THINK --
PERHAPS WE NEED -- TO GET HIS
ADVICE AS A CALIFORNIA THE NOSE
WASHINGTON.
I WOULD SAY THAT -- AND I
CERTAINLY REACH OUT TO THEM. TO
GET IS A VICE.
BECAUSE HE SERVED DOES SO.
A SECRETARY IN THE CABINET --
FOR PRESIDENT CLINTON AND THEN
[inaudible]
PRESIDENT -- BUSH OF MADE HIM
THE SECRETARY OF TRANSPORTATION
FOR UNITED STATES [inaudible]
SO -- HE WOULD BE A GUIDE A YOU
KNOW GET SOME ADVICE FOM ABOUT
THIS EXACT SUBJECT SO CENTER
GALGIANI -- FIRST OF ALL I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY FOR EVERYONE THAT
THE FRA HAS BEEN TREMENDOUS
PARTNERS WITH CALIFORNIA I
AUTHORED THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
BOND AND I WAS BACK IN DC SINCE
SHORTLY AFTER PRESIDENT OBAMA
HAD MADE A COMMITMENT TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL FUNDING. FOR THE
NATION AND THE FRA HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN HELPING US TO
ACHIEVE MANY OF OUR GOALS
THEY'VE BEEN FLEXIBLE WITH US
WHEN THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THE
DOLLARS.
NOBODY IN THE NATION NEW HOW TO
BUILD A SYSTEM THERE IS NO
BLUEPRINT WE'VE NEVER BUILT ONE
BEFORE.
AND THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY ALONG WITH SOME
OF OUR IMHO YOU PARTNERS FROM
OTHER COUNTRIES WORKED WITH THE
F..
THE F. R. A. SOUGHT REQUEST FOR
EXPRESSION OF INTEREST FROM
THESE OTHER -- COUNTRIES LIKE
FRANCE SNCF FROM FRANCE
SUBMITTED A COPY THAT I HAVE TO
THIS DAY AND SO I JUST WANT TO
CLEAR UP FOR ANYBODY THAT HAS
DOUBTS THE FRA HAS WORKED VERY
DILIGENTLY WITH US.
I THINK THERE WAS SOME GREAT
MISCOMMUNICATION -- IN JANUARY
AND I'M CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL
REACH SOME KIND OF RESOLUTION --
SECONDLY TO SPEAK TO SENATOR
STONES -- COMMENTS I WILL TELL
YOU WHY WE STARTED IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY -- THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS ACTUALLY THE ONLY
PLACE IN THE ENTIRE NATION AT
THAT TIME THEY HAD THE ABILITY
TO REACH THE SPEEDS OF TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY MILES PER HOUR.
AND THAT'S CRITICAL BECAUSE AT
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY MILES PER
HOUR THAT'S THE LEVEL AT WHICH
HIGH SPEED RAIL CAN BE
COMPLEMENTARY TO AIRLINE TRAFFIC.
AND OR AIRLINE TRAVEL AND
THEREFORE.
GENERATE A PROFIT THE PRESIDENT
COMMITTED TO HIGH SPEED RAIL AND
LATER HAD TO SAY AND ALSO THE
GRANTS ARE FOR HIGHER SPEED RAIL
BECAUSE IT CALIFORNIA WAS
ACTUALLY THE ONLY STATE THAT
COULD COMPETE.
AND AGAIN I REPEAT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WAS THE ONLY PLACE TO DO
THAT.
SECOND REASON FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WE NEEDED A TEST TRACK TO
TEST THE HIGH SPEED TRAINS.
WE NEEDED A HUNDRED MILES AT
LEAST A HUNDRED MILES TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT AGAIN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY WAS THE ONLY PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT.
THIRD THE REQUIREMENT WAS TO
HAVE INDEPENDENT UTILITY AND
THAT'S IN THE EVENT THAT THERE
WAS MONEY BUT THE ECONOMY
CHANGED FUNDING CHANGED.
THE PRESIDENT AT ADMINISTRATION
WANTED TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE THAT
WHATEVER INFRASTRUCTURE WE BUILT
IT WOULD BE ABLE TO CONNECT BACK
AGAIN WITH A PASSENGER RAIL
SERVICE SUCH AS BNSF OR THE U.
P. LINE.
AND SO WHEN THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY WAS PROMISED MONEY NOT
ONLY FOR CALIFORNIA BUT WE
ACHIEVED MONEY FROM OTHER STATES.
THAT WERE ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THEIR PROJECTS IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT WHATEVER WE
BUILT IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
COULD CONNECT BACK INTO THE BNSF
LINE.
AND WHAT I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU TWO DAYS IF WE DID NOTHING
MORE TODAY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
INFRASTRUCTURE STILL COULD
CONNECT INTO THE B. AND A SEVEN
AMTRAK.
OF CORRIDOR WITH DIRECTLY WITH
ONCE WE GET UP TO MERCED WHICH
IS JUST ANOTHER TWENTY FIVE
MILES AS THE GOVERNOR IS WISHING
TO DO. TO DAY WE WILL BE ABLE TO
HAVE PASSENGERS COMMUTE FROM
BAKERSFIELD.
CONNECTED MERCED WITH AMTRAK UP
TO SACRAMENTO AS THE FIRST LEG
OF THE STOOL THE SECOND LEG OF
THE STOOL WOULD BE CONNECTING AT
MERCED INTO OAKLAND WHICH AGAIN
IT DOES TODAY.
AND ONCE WE FINISH THE
CONSTRUCTION OF ACE DOWN TO
MERCED WHICH THIS BODY HAS
APPROVED FUNDING FOR THAT WILL
PROVIDE US WITH THE THIRD LEG OF
THE STOOL.
YOU MENTIONED THE COST OF
TICKETS DANNY DO TAE -- GOD REST
HIS SOUL HE WAS A TREMENDOUS
PARTNER AT WITH CALIFORNIA
BEFORE HE PASSED AWAY AND HE WAS
WITH THE SNCF
COMPANY OUT OF FRANCE SOME OF
YOU BEEN WHO'VE BEEN INVOLVED
FOR A LONG TIME WILL REMEMBER
HIM.
AND HE TALKED TO US ABOUT HOW TO
STRUCTURE THE COST OF THE TICKET
AND THE LEGISLATIVE BODY NEEDS
TO MAKE A DECISION AS TO WHETHER
IT'S IF.
WE INTEND TO MAKE A PROFIT FROM
HIGH SPEED RAIL TO BILL TO PUT
BACK IN THE SYSTEM AND BUILD
MORE OR IF WE INTEND TO PROVIDE
A PUBLIC BENEFIT.
AT THE TIME IT WAS BELIEVED THAT
HIGH SPEED RAIL TICKETS WOULD
COST ABOUT HALF OF WHAT AN
AIRLINE TICKET WOULD BE.
BUT THAT COULD GO LOWER OR
HIGHER DEPENDING ON WHETHER WE
WANTED TO HAVE THE INFLUENCE THE
END. TO EMPHASIZE THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT PORTION OR EMPHASIZE THE
PROFIT PORTION -- IN NEXT I
WANTED -- TO ADDRESS MISTER LOU
THOMPSON -- EARLY ON WHEN WE HAD
THE MY VISION FOR THE PERIOD
VIEW COMMITTEE THAT I PLACED IN
AB THREE OH THREE FOUR WAS TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAD MEMBERS ON
THE COMMITTEE WHO HAD.
INTERNATIONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL IT WAS VERY
EXPLICIT THAT THE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE MEMBERS WOULD BE WOULD
HAVE THAT BACKGROUND AND
EXPERIENCE.
AND PART OF THAT THOUGHT PROCESS
WAS BECAUSE AT THE TIME
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHS ROLE FORTY
DID HAVE EMOJIS WITH JAPAN
GERMANY FRANCE.
ITALY CHINA -- AND I AND OTHERS --
SOUTH KOREA I BELIEVE AND THEY
WERE VERY ACTIVE AND VERY
INTERESTED IN CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
AT THE TIME WHAT THEN HAPPENED
BECAUSE WE HAD MONEY.
IS THAT COMPANIES THAT DID HAVE
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
EXPERIENCE IN BUILDING
STRUCTURES WERE INTERESTED IN
COMPETING FOR THE CONTRACTS AND
SO THEN IT WAS NO LONGER
APPROPRIATE FOR THE SAME
INDIVIDUALS TO BE MEMBERS OF THE
PEER REVIEW COMMITTEE.
AND I REMEMBER BEING --
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MEMBERS WHO
WERE WILLING TO SERVE ON THE
COMMITTEE BUT AT THE SAME TIME
DISAPPOINTED THAT WE DIDN'T ND
UP HAVING INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD
THIS INTERNATIONAL EXPERIENCE.
WITH ACTUALLY BUILDING SYSTEMS I
THINK THAT -- WHERE THE TIME NOW
WHERE WERE WE WE HAVE A CAN
SEIZE ON THE PEER REVIEW
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
CORRECT.
YES AND THE CONTRACTS HAVE NOW
BEEN LET. FOR THE CONSTRUCTION --
PROJECT ONE TWO THREE FOUR AND I
THINK IT'S TIME THAT WE OUGHT TO
LOOK AT WHO AND WHO WE CAN ADD
TO THE PEER REVIEW COMMITTEE WHO
DOES IN FACT HAVE SOME OF THIS
EXPERIENCE.
AND NOW THAT WE HAVE AN OPERATOR
THAT WE BROUGHT ON BOARD THAT
DOES HAVE EXPERIENCE I THINK
IT'S TIME FOR THE FORTY TO TAKE
A LOOK AGAIN AS WE DID IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WE DID THE
BUSINESS PLAN.
AND WE HAD WE ASKED RESPONDENTS
TO PARTICIPATE AND REQUEST FOR
EXPRESSION OF INTEREST WHERE
THEY WOULD.
COMMENT ON CALIFORNIA'S -- HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT THEY WOULD
COMMENT WHETHER WAS DOABLE
WHETHER MATCH THINGS THAT WERE
DONE IN OTHER COUNTRIES.
AND EXPRESSLY -- WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO HAVE THESE PRIVATE
SECTOR COMPANIES?
BE INTERESTED IN MAKING
INVESTMENTS AND CALIFORNIA'S
PROJECT I THINK WE ARE AT THE
POINT IN TIME WHERE WE NEED TO
REALLY MAKE A STRONG EMPHASIS.
ON THIS BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE SEEN
HERE TO FOUR IS.
A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN PASSENGER RAIL
COMMUTER RAIL -- CALTRANS TYPE
PROJECTS THOSE ARE VERY VERY
DIFFERENT THAN A LARGE MULTI
BILLIONDOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECT SO I THINK IT'S TIME TO
GET BACK TO FOCUSING ON THE SAME
THINGS THAT WE FOCUSED ON WHEN
WE WERE ASKING OTHERS -- TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE REQUEST FOR
EXPRESSION OF INTEREST AND I'D
LIKE TO HAVE YOUR COMMENT ON
THAT [inaudible]
WELL.
COMMENT IS THAT IT HAS BEEN
ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND PEOPLE
WITH INTERNATIONAL HIGH SPEED
RAIL DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
EXPERIENCE THAT ARE ALREADY
WORKING FOR CONTRACTORS TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY.
SO TIME AFTER TIME WE FOUND
PEOPLE BUT THEY'VE BEEN
CONFLICTED ONE WAY OR THE OTHER --
IN FACT THOUGH WHAT THE PROJECT
IS RIGHT NOW IS NOT SO MUCH OF
RAIL PROJECT AS IT IS A VERY
STRAIGHT HIGHWAY PROJECT.
AND WE HAVE TWO PEOPLE WITH
CALTRANS EXPERIENCE WHO I THINK
ARE VERY WELL SET UP TO ADVISE
US ON THAT PART OF THE PROJECT --
HOPEFULLY IN THE FUTURE WE WILL
FIND PEOPLE WITH THE KIND OF
EXPERIENCE YEAR MENTIONING.
BUT AS OF NOW I SUPPOSE I'M THE
ONLY ONE ON THE COMMITTEE WHO'S
BEEN INVOLVED IN A HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND ALL OF ITS ASPECTS AS
WELL AS THE ENGINEERING AND
ECONOMIC ISSUES.
WHAT I HAVE FOCUSED ON IS ALSO
TRYING TO GET PEOPLE WITH
ECONOMIC EXPERTISE BECAUSE?
THAT'S REALLY WHY WE'RE BUILDING
THE PROJECT IT'S NOT AN
ENGINEERING PROJECT AS A
BUSINESS THE WHOLE PEOPLE AROUND.
AND I HOPEFULLY WE HAVE --
EXPERTISE TO ANALYZE THE PLANS
FOR THE FLOW OF THE PROJECT FROM
THAT POINT OF VIEW [inaudible]
HI I NEW GUINEA DO TEAM DO TAE
VERY WELL AND I AM VERY WELL
FAMILIAR WITH THE FRENCH
EXPERIENCE IN -- CONTRIBUTIONS
THAT THEY'VE MADE.
AND THEY CERTAINLY DID.
OUR AND MATT BRINGS UP AS WE
LOOK AS WE GO IN THE FUTURE
HOPEFULLY WE CAN FIGURE SOME WAY
TO GET THAT KIND OF EXPERTISE.
ESPECIALLY THE EXPERTISE OF THE
EARLIER OPERATOR FROM THE
AUTHORITY INTO THE FORMULATION
OF THE OPTIONS IN THE PLANS THAT
I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE.
THE F. R. A. HAD ISSUE THEIR OWN
REQUEST FOR EXPRESSION OF
INTEREST IN HAD RECEIVED --
INPUT FROM MANY COUNTRIES AT THE
TIME AND I I DO KNOW THAT THAT
SO MANY ARE WORKING ON THE
PROJECT THAT IT CONFLICTS AMOUNT
I DO UNDERSTAND THAT -- BUT
PERHAPS WE SHOULD BE ASKING OUR
FRA PARTNERS -- TO WORK WITH US
TO SOLICIT ONCE AGAIN.
OUR REQUEST FOR EXPRESSION OF
INTEREST FROM THOSE WHO ARE IN
OTHER COUNTRIES WHO ARE WATCHING.
THIS SYSTEM AND WHO HAVE THE
ABILTY TO COMMENT ON AND
PERHAPS THAT SOMETHING OUR OUR
NEW OPERATOR CAN HELP US WITH.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT.
THE FIRST STUDY DID THE FRA DID
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA
WAS ONE THAT I SEPARATE
SUPERVISED AT THE F. OR A IN
SEVERAL OF THE STUDIES THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE OF HIGH SPEED RAIL IN
THE UNITED STATES AT THE OFFER A
HAS DONE.
HI SUPERVISOR WAS INVOLVED
[inaudible]
ALL.
IT AGAIN THE PROBLEM WITH HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN THE UNITED STATES
IS THAT PEOPLE SEE A PICTURE OF
MOUNT FUJI ON ON THEY THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE THAT AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT WE NEED.
AND THAT'S NOT WHAT ARE THE
ISSUES ARE IN THE UNITED STATES
ARE QUITE DIFFERENT.
SO WHILE ARE YOU CERTAINLY
VALUED INTERNATIONAL EXPERTISE --
EXPERTISE IN US CONSTRUCTION
ISSUES EXPERTISE IN U. S.
DEMOGRAPHIC ISSUES US DEMAND
MODELING.
OF THOSE ARE IN SOME WAYS MUCH
MORE IMPORTANT TO THE PROJECT
RIGHT NOW I'M NOT ARGUING WITH
YOUR WITH YOUR POSITION THAT WE
NEED.
MORE INTERNATIONAL EXPERTISE BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO BUTTRESS THAT
WITH PEOPLE WHO KNOW WHAT
AMERICAN CONDITIONS ARE.
WHAT AMERICAN DEMAND AND AND
RESPONSE CONDITIONS ARE?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KAT OF CIRCLE JOHNNY
OH OKAY WELL THANKS I LIKE TO
THANK THE PANEL -- PERHAPS AT
THE PROPER TIME THE LA -- COULD.
SUMMARIZE SOME VARIOUS OPTIONS.
THEY'RE AVAILABLE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY.
TERMS OF AN INDEPENDENT LOOK AT
THE HALF.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
CALL THE NEXT PANEL OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY THEMSELVES --
WE HAVE -- THE WHO'S ON A
PANELIST ON LANNY.
AREAS OKAY SIR I WAS WONDERING.
AND BRIAN ILLNESS OR SECRETARY
OF TRANSPORTATION [inaudible]
AND JOE HEDGES CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER -- ROSS FONG AND CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER PAM IS THE IS
A COMMA A JETER FOR THE OFFICERS.
SO WILL TURN OVER -- THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE FIRST OF ALL --
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO THE BOARD
CHAIRMAN -- AND WELCOME. TO THE
CALIFORNIA SENATE.
YOU HAVE A
FOR OKAY [inaudible]
BUT AB.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
SENATORS IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE THIS AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LENNY MENDOZA -- AS OF FEBRUARY
I WAS NAMED THE BY THE GOVERNOR
AS HIS CHIEF ECONOMIC AND
BUSINESS ADVISER AND THE
pECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT BUSINESS AGENCY AND
THEN SIX WEEKS AGO I WAS ASKED
TO CHAIR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO TODAY IS?
GIVE YOU SOME INTRODUCTORY
REMARKS TO PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF WHAT WE'RE ATTEMPTING TO DO
WITH THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND
THEN I WILL TURN OVER TO
SECRETARY AND THIS WILL GIVE A
WE WILL MARCH FORWARD TO DELIVER.
ON THAT VISION.
THIS CAN ONLY HAPPEN WOULD BE
INCREDIBLE.
CREDIBILITY MEANS.
QUALITY OF BEING BELIEVABLE AND
WORTHY OF TRUST
.
GOOD FOR YOU IS GOING TO
REESTABLISH CREDIBILITY THROUGH.
AN AGGRESSIVE COMMITMENT TO
TRANSPARENCY.
BY KEEPING OUR COMMITMENTS.
AND DELIVERING ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL TRAINS WHILE LIVING WITHIN
OUR MEANS.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IS FOR
DELIVERING HIGH SPEED RAIL IN A
WAY THAT IS TRANSPARENT
TRANSFORMATION.
AND UNLOCKING THE ENORMOUS
POTENTIAL OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
OF CALIFORNIA.
IN THE AREA OF TRANSPARENCY.
THE STORY IS ALREADY COMMITTED
TO THIS MOST OBVIOUSLY THROUGH
THE STAB WHICH MEANT OF A
FINANCE AND AUDIT COMMITTEE.
WHAT PROJECTS CHALLENGES TRENDS
AND OPPORTUNITIES ARE DISCUSSED
IN PUBLIC?
AND OF COURSE STEPHANIE
DOCUMENTS
ARE AVAILABLE ONLINE
FOR THE PUBLIC TO SEE.
AND WE HAVE AN EFFORT NAY
COMMITTEE REPORTED EVERY HIGH
SPEED RAIL BOARD MEETING.
I'VE ALSO ASKED MISTER RICHARD.
ON THE BOARD TO PROVIDE AN
UPDATED EVERY COMMITTEE MEETING
AND ADDED TO THAT'S BEEN THE
CASE THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
HISTORY OF THIS PROJECT.
WE DO NOT HAVE ALL THE FUNDING
IN HAND TO DELIVER THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM NOW.
SO WE'RE GOING TO GET THERE.
BY USING BUILDING BLOCKS.
JUST LIKE EVERY OTHER
FINANCIALLY CONSTRAINED
TRANSPORTATION PROJECT UP. TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PLAN LAID OUT
A SET OF PRIORITIES.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS TO MEET
OUR COMMITMENTS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
COMPLETE THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SEGMENT.
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS
STATEWIDE.
NUMBER WILL ADD TRACK AND
SYSTEMS AND EXTEND THE SEGMENT
FROM JUST AN ALMOND ORCHARD JUST
NORTH OF BAKERSFIELD INTO
DOWNTOWN.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN PROMISED TO EXPLORE REPORT
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR MARK EARLY
TRAIN OPERATOR ON EARLY SERVICE
OPTION.
AN UPDATE THE COST FIGURES OUT
TO REVIEW BY THE EARLY TRAIN
OPERATOR.
AND SUBJECTING THE BUSINESS PLAN.
NUMBERS TO FURTHER RESTRICT.
THE PLAN COMMITTED TO INVEST.
THE REMAINING BOOK IN FUNDS AND
PURSUE ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO
FINANCE A COMPLETE THE SYSTEM.
INDEED THE PROJECT UP REPORT
UPDATE REPORT WILL INCLUDE THIS
CONTENT IN OUR MESA MIDDLE TO
THE LEGISLATURE.
THE REPORT WILL INCLUDE A FULL
ANALYSIS AN IMPLEMENTATION
STRATEGY FOR BEST EARLY OPTION.
BEST EARLY SERVICE OPTION.
THE GOVERNOR ASKED. FORTY TO DO
MORE IN THIS AREA OF
TRANSPARENCY AND WE ARE. FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTION WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PAGE ON THE
WEBSITE.
BUDGET CHANGE ORDERS CAN BE
FOUND FOR EACH CONSTRUCTION
PACKAGE.
AS OF TODAY.
THE PACKAGE INCLUDES THE
HUNDREDS OF CHANGE ORDERS
EXECUTED TO DATE.
AND THE SITE WILL BE UPDATED
QUARTERLY GOING FORWARD.
ON KEEPING COMMITMENTS LET'S BE
CLEAR.
WE'VE COMMITTED TO FUND THE BOOK
AND IMPROVEMENTS IN THE BAY AREA
AND LOS ANGELES AND WE'RE
KEEPING THOSE COMMITMENTS
[inaudible]
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THE AUTHORITY IS A FUNDING
PARTNER THE CALTRAIN.
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT.
THE SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
PROP ONE A FUNDS PLUS AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN CAP AND TRADE
FUNDS.
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE
AUTHORITY AS DIRECTED SEVENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS TO
ROSECRANS MARXUACH GATE GRADE
SEPARATION PROJECT.
NUMBER ONE ON THE PC LIST OF
MOST DANGEROUS GRADE SEPARATIONS.
THE REMAINING BOOK AND FUNDS ARE
COMMITTED TO THE LA UNION
STATION IMPROVEMENT ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS [inaudible]
MOREOVER.
WE COMMITTED TO COMPLETE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK FOR ALL
SEGMENTS OF THE PHASE ONE SYSTEM
BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES AND I'M.
WE WERE DOING THAT.
REQUESTED NEED ASSIGNMENT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
STREAMLINE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK.
AND WORK IS SCHEDULED TO BE
COMPLETED BY THE ARE A FUNDING.
FEDERAL FUNDING AGREEMENT
DEADLINE THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER.
THE AUTHORITY WAS VERY CLEAR IN
ITS TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
BUSINESS PLAN ABOUT THE LESSONS
THAT I LEARNED.
FROM GOING INTO CONSTRUCTION
PRIOR TO FULLY ADDRESSING THE
CHALLENGES PREVENTED BY
PRESENTED BY RIGHT OF WAY
ACQUISITION.
UTILITY RELOCATION.
AND THIRD PARTY AGREEMENT ISSUES.
WE'RE SMARTER NOW.
AND COMMITTED TO NOT REPEATING
THE MISTAKES OF THE PAST.
COMPLETING ENVIRONMENTAL WORK IN
FRONT OF FUTURE CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS IS NECESSARY. TO
REFINE COST ESTIMATES TO
ADVANCED DESIGN.
TôI JENNIFER BY AND MITIGATE
RISK. TO DEVELOP STRATEGIES FOR
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT WORK.
AND TO READY SHARED QUARTERS FOR
INVESTMENTS AS FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES BECOME AVAILABLE
[inaudible]
MOREOVER.
THE AUTHORITY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
HAS BROUGHT IN A NEW LEADERSHIP
TEAM THAT IS FOCUSED ON PROJECT
DELIVERY.
UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER JOE HEDGES.
THE PROJECT CONTROLS ARE BETTER
THAN EVER BEEN ON THIS PROJECT.
RISK ISSUES ARE BEING IDENTIFIED
MANAGED UNMITIGATED.
SECRETARY ANISE WILL DISCUSS HOW.
CONSTRUCTION WILL PROGRESS THIS
YEAR IS THE RESULT OF THAT HARD
WORK.
AS YOU KNOW THE PROJECT DOES NOT
HAVE ALL THE FUNDING NEEDED TO
COMPLETE THE ENTIRE PROJECT.
AND LET'S BE CLEAR IT NEVER
HAPPENS.
PROP ONE A PROVIDED ONLY 20% OF
THE PROJECTS THAN ESTIMATED
COSTS.
TODAY WITH A STABLE CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM THROUGH.
TWENTY TEN FEDERAL FUNDS IN THE
PROP A FOUR ONE A FUNDING.
IS ALREADY HAS ACCESS NOW TO
JUST UNDER 30% OF THE PROJECT
FUNDING COSTS.
SO HOW DO WE GO ABOUT MAKING
HIGH SPEED RAIL REAL IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE FUNDING THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO US TODAY. FORTY
IT ALREADY BEEN LOOKING AT THIS
WHEN THEY BROUGHT IN THE EARLY
TRAIN OPERATOR IN. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN TO ADVISE ON
OPERATIONAL ISSUES FOR SERVICE
IN CALIFORNIA.
THE AUTHORITY DIRECTED THE VIDEO
TO ANALYZE TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR AND ROOM
SERVICE THAT MAKES THE MOST
SENSE.
THROUGH THIS WORK.
THE INDICATION IS THAT MERCED
FRESNO BAKERSFIELD.
IS THE ONLY SERVICE LINE TO MAKE
SENSE AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE ONLY PLACE IN THE STATE
WHERE THE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK IS
COMPLETE OR NEAR COMPLETE.
AND CONSTRUCTION IS WELL UNDER
WAY.
THE MERCED FRESNO BAKERSFIELD
LINE ALSO HAS THE BENEFIT OF
OFFERING A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ONE MILE HIGH SPEED SERVICE
CONNECTING THREE OF THE FASTEST
GROWING COUNTIES.
IN THE CENTER PART OF THE STATE
WHERE I GREW UP.
AND MERCED FRESNO ONE CAR
[inaudible]
SERVICE.
WOULD ALSO PROVIDE IMPORTANT
CONNECTIONS TO A SERVICE
TRAVELING TO SAN JOSE.
AN AMTRAK SERVICE TRAVELING TO
SACRAMENTO AND OAKLAND.
WHILE REDUCING THE TRAVEL TIMES
BETWEEN NINETY AND A HUNDRED
MINUTES THROUGH THE CENTRAL OUT.
ON MAY FIRST.
TWENTY NINETEEN AUTHORITY ROLE
WILL RELEASE THE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
OUTLINED THE E. TIAS ANALYSIS
FOR EARLY OPERATIONS.
BENEFITS RISKS.
COSTS AND SCHEDULES AN
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
WITH FOUR DIFFERENT PRESENTING
THAT IN MAY -- LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO SECRETARY ANISE WILL
PROVIDE MORE PROGRAMMATIC UP
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU A GERMAN MAN DONS AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE TODAY AND
TESTIFY BRIAN AND THE SECRETARY
OF THE STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY.
HIGH SPEED RAIL REMAINS THE
ESSENTIAL BACKBONE OF A BROADER
MODERNIZE RAIL AND TRANSIT
SYSTEM.
THE CALIFORNIANS DESERVING NEED
AS THE STATE CONTINUES TO GROW
TOWARD FIFTY MILLION POPULATION.
THAT MODERNIZE RAIL SYSTEM WILL
BE INTEGRATED.
AND FOR AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
TRIPS WILL BE FASTER LOWER COST
AND MORE CONVENIENT.
THAN A CAR OR A AIRPLANE TRIP.
AND A ROBUST RAIL SYSTEM IN
TRANSIT SYSTEM.
IS ABSOLUTELY NEEDED TO ACHIEVE
CALIFORNIA'S MOBILITY AND
CLIMATE GOALS.
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS
PLAN PROVIDES THE EXAMPLE.
OF SAN JOSE TO FRESNO TRIP.
THAT TRIP TAKES ABOUT THREE
HOURS BY CAR WITH HIGH SPEED
ROUTE WOULD TAKE ABOUT ONE HOUR.
AND THERE'S A SIMILAR TRAVEL
TIME SAVINGS LOOKING AT MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD.
THE SLIDE IS UP ON THE SCREEN
NOW.
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE NEW
STRATEGY DIRECTION AND APPLYING
THE LESSONS LEARNED THAT HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAS IMPLEMENTED.
COUPLE EXAMPLES.
FIRST WITH THIRD PARTY
AGREEMENTS HAS BEEN SOME
DISCUSSION OF THE THIRD PARTY
CAESAR THE PUBLIC UTILITIES.
THE RAILROAD OPERATORS -- THE
CITIES IN THE REGION.
AND THAT HAS BEEN AN AREA OF
RISKING AND COST FOR THE PROJECT
BUT THE PROJECT TEAM RIGHT NOW
IS WORKING CLOSELY WITH THOSE
THIRD PARTIES IN SOME CASES.
A REINSTITUTING THIRD PARTY
MASTER AGREEMENTS OF COOPERATION.
TO REDUCE RISK.
HIGH SPEED ROSE ALSO INCREASING
ENGAGEMENT OF THOSE THIRD
PARTIES WITH THE FINAL DESIGN
WORK THAT THE DESIGN BILL
CONTRACTORS WORKING ON BECAUSE
THAT DESIGN BUILD WORK CAN
CHANGE SOME OF THOSE.
THIRD PARTY REQUIREMENTS AND AND
AND THAT PROJECT SCOPE SO HIGH
SPEED ROSE WORKING DAY REDUCE
RISK IN THAT AREA BY GOOD
COORDINATION BOTH WITH THE THIRD
PARTIES AND THE DESIGN BUILDERS
AS THEY COMPLETE THEIR DESIGN
WORK.
AND IN FACT COMPLETING THE
DESIGN WORK IS A BENEFIT AS WELL
BECAUSE THAT REDUCES ANY
RESIDUAL RISK OF RIGHT AWAY
QUESTIONS ENVIRONMENTAL.
WORKING SENTRA SO ALL THESE
THINGS THROUGH THE PIPELINE A
PROJECT DEVELOPMENT -- BE
MANAGED BY JOE AND HIS TEAM.
pPROJECT.
IN BOTH THE TIME AND SCHEDULE.
ON THE NEXT FLIGHT HERE'S MORE
SPECIFICS OF SOME OF THE CHANGES
IN HOW THE STAFF FOR DOING THEIR
WORK.
THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER AND
THE DEPUTY CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER ARE ROUTINELY NOW IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY MEETING WITH ALL
THE PARTIES.
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE LEGACY
ISSUES WITH TO RESOLVE THOSE --
MONITORING ISSUES AS THEY COME
UP. TO RESOLVE THOSE AS WELL.
THERE IS AN ONGOING EFFORT TO
OPTIMIZE STAFF AT THE AUTHORITY
NO SOME OF THAT WAS BROUGHT UP
BY HE STATE AUDITOR.
ASSUME INCREASED FOCUS ON
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT ADD TO THAT
END IN THE SHORT TERM A HIGH
SPEED RAIL HAS REDESIGNATED SOME
POSITIONS THAT ARE VACANT TO
CONTRACT MANAGEMENT POSITIONS.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AS WELL IN
THE LONGER TERM APPROACH TO
STAFF IN THIS AREA.
AND HIGH SPEED RAIL HAS
IMPLEMENTED TO GET TO WORK
SCHEDULES AND PLANS. TO INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND MONITOR WORK
AS WE GO.
AND THIS NEXT SERIES OF SLIDES
SHOWS DETAIL ON WHAT WORK HAS
BEEN DONE IS BEING DONE AND SOME
OF THE REMAINING AREAS WHERE WE
NEED TO CLEAR.
THE SEGMENTS FOR CONSTRUCTION.
THIS IS A CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE
ONE AND THIS CHART INDICATES THE
PROGRESS OF THE WORK AS OF
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR.
THIS SEGMENT INCLUDES MANY OF
THE ICONIC STRUCTURES THAT YOU
MIGHT SEE IF YOU'VE DRIVEN DOWN
HIGHWAY NINETY NINE IN FRESNO
RECENTLY.
AS SUCH AS THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
VIDAK: CAN PERGOLA THAT'S JUST
TO THE SOUTH OF THAT -- THEN
REALIGNED HIGHWAY NINETY NINE
PROJECT.
AND ALSO THE CEDAR VIADUCTS.
DON THIS CHART AT THERE'S A
TOTAL MILEAGE -- THIS IS A
TWENTY FIVE MILE SEGMENT.
ABOUT SEVEN MILES OF THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN PROGRESS FOR
GRADING.
AND THE EMBANKMENT WORK AND THEN
YOU SEE -- BY THE COLORS
DIFFERENT PROJECT STRUCTURES
SWITCHES BRIDGES GRADE
SEPARATIONS EXCEPT TRUCK -- SOME
THAT ARE COMPLETED SOME THAT ARE
UNDER WAY AND SOME THAT ARE
STILL IN THE FUTURE.
NOW THE PROJECT TEAM IS FOCUSING
ON RISKS TO THIS.
PARTICULAR SEGMENT AND ON ON
THIS SEGMENT THIRD PARTY ISSUES
WITH UTILITY RELOCATION.
AND ADJACENT RAILROADS ARE ONE
OF THE IDENTIFIED RISK.
THE TEAM IS WORKING TO FINALIZE
ISSUES WITH THESE THIRD PARTIES
TO RESOLVE THESE ISSUES AND
ADDITIONALLY ADDRESSING CRITICAL
DESIGN NEEDS BY FORMING A FOCUS
TEAM TO DRIVE COMPLETION OF
DESIGNED TO ALIGN WITH THE
EXISTING RIGHT AWAY
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCES AGAIN.
MANAGING THE RISK.
AS I GO TO THE NEXT SLIDE THIS
IS ALSO CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE.
ONE BUT THE PROGRESS WE EXPECT
TO MAKE BY THE END OF THIS
CALENDAR YEAR BY DECEMBER.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND THE CHART
INDICATES THAT.
THE PLAN IS TO AB.
BRING ADDITIONAL.
SEGMENTS OF GUIDE WAY WORK AGAIN
THIS IS THE THE GRADING IN THE
EMBANKMENT WORK.
GROWING FROM ABOUT SEVEN MILES
TODAY TO EIGHTEEN MILES BY THE
END OF THE YEAR.
RIGHT NOW THERE ABOUT SEVEN
STRUCTURES IN PROGRESS IN FOR
COMPLETE BY THE END OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR THE PLAN IS TO
HAVE TEN STRUCTURES UNDER
CONSTRUCTION WITH TEN STRUCTURES
COMPLETE.
THE NEXT CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE IS
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE
[inaudible]
TO THREE THE ISSUES.
ON THIS SEGMENT ARE LARGELY
PROCUREMENT OF THE REMAINING
RIGHT AWAY.
AND RESOLVING THIRD PARTY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCE ISSUES.
THE TEAM IS IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS WORKING TO FINALIZE
ISSUES WITH THE THIRD PARTIES
AND BY ADDRESSING THESE ISSUES.
THE NEXT SLIDE OR SHOW WHERE WE
PLAN TO BE AT THE END OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR.
SO COMPARING THE TWO TABLES HERE
YOU SEE THAT -- WE GO FROM
HAVING -- IN JANUARY. TWENTY ONE
SECTIONS OF GUIDE WHERE TWENTY
ONE MILES OF GUIDEWAY IN
PROGRESS IN TWELVE COMPLETED TO
BY THE END OF THAT.
CALENDAR YEAR SHOWING A TWENTY
EIGHT ARE IN PROGRESS AND THIRTY
SEVEN MILES OF THE GUIDE WAY ARE
COMPLETE.
SEVERAL MILLION STRUCTURES THREE
STRUCTURES ARE IN PROGRESS NOW
BY THE END OF THE CALENDAR YEAR.
THE TARGET IS TO HAVE FOURTEEN
IN PROGRESS IN FOR STRUCTURES
COMPLETE ON THE SEGMENT.
LASTLY CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE.
FOR CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE FOR IS
THE CHALLENGES ARE LARGELY ON
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES IN A SMALL
NUMBER POTENTIALLY DIFFICULT
PARCELS TO ACQUIRE FOR THE RIGHT
AWAY.
WORKING THROUGH THOSE ISSUES.
BY THE END OF THE CALENDAR YEAR
YOU'LL SEE THAT.
THIS SEGMENT ANTICIPATES.
THE DAHLE.
MILES OF THE GUIDE WAY ARE
EITHER UNDER CONSTRUCTION OR
COMPLETED BY DECEMBER.
AND THEN AS YOU LOOK TO
STRUCTURES.
OF THE TOTAL STRUCTURES OF
ELEVEN I SEVEN WOULD BE IN
PROGRESS BY THE END OF THE
CALENDAR YEAR HAND FOR WOULD BE
COMPLETED.
S. IS THAT YOU ALREADY HEARD
TODAY FROM THE STATE AUDITOR.
WANT TO REITERATE THAT THE
AUTHORITY IS COMMITTED TO
ADDRESSING THE ALL OF THE
AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATIONS AND ON
THE ESTABLISHED SCHEDULE WE WERE
VERY PLEASED TO HEAR THAT -- THE
ODD THE OFFICE BELIEVES WE'RE
MAKING GOOD PROGRESS IN THAT
REGARD.
THE AUTHORITY WELCOMED THE AUDIT.
AND IS TAKING IT VERY SERIOUSLY
ITS FINDINGS AND RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE BUILT ON ISSUES THE
AUTHORITY HAD IDENTIFIED IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN
BUT THANKS TO THE AUDIT.
THAT SOME GAPS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED AND SOME ADDITIONAL
AREAS OF PROCESS DEVELOPMENT
WERE ALSO IDENTIFIED IN HIGH
SPEED RAIL UNDER THE LEADERSHIP --
IT OF THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
BRIAN KELLY IS WORKING ON THOSE
ISSUES.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO MEET THOSE
DELIVERABLES.
IT'S ALSO BEEN DISCUSSION AT THE
HEARING ABOUT THE FEDERAL
RAILROAD ADMINISTRATION LETTER
THAT CAME TO US ON FEBRUARY
NINETEENTH.
THREATENING TO DE OBLIGATE NINE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE MILLION IN
FEDERAL GRANT FUNDS.
IT IS ALSO MENTIONED AT THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY RESPONDED
ON MARCH FOURTH SENDING TWO
LETTERS.
STAY IN THE POSITION OF THE
AUTHORITY THAT THE PROJECT
CONTINUES TO FURTHER THE PURPOSE
FOR WHICH THE FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
OBLIGATED.
WE ARE MAKING STEADY PROGRESS
TOWARD MEETING THE GRANT
REQUIREMENTS.
THE LETTERS NOTED FRA IS TAKEN
ACTION DETRIMENTAL TO TIMELY
PROGRESS ON THE AREAS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS.
AND LASTLY WE INVITE THE F. R.
A. TO REESTABLISH THE VERY.
FUNCTIONAL RELATIONSHIP IN VERY
PRODUCTIVE RELATIONSHIP WITH HAD
FOR MOST OF THE GRANT CYCLE.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE HAPPENS
HERE WE HAVE NOT HEARD BACK FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT YET BUT
VERY MUCH HOPE THAT THEY WILL RE
ENGAGE WITH THE AUTHORITY.
THE AUTHORITY CERTAINLY ANXIOUS
TO ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS THAT
THAT THEY HAVE AN BELIEVE WE CAN
DO SO.
I JUST QUICKLY GET A RUN THROUGH
SOME OF THE STATISTICS ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENNETT HE SHOULD
BE THE ECONOMIC BENEFIT OF THE
PROJECT IN THESE WERE.
DISCUSSED AT THE LAST BOARD
MEETING -- THROUGH JUNE OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE PROJECT
SPENT ABOUT FOUR POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS.
AND OF NOTE THAT. 95% OF THAT OF
THOSE EXPENDITURES HAVE GONE TO
CALIFORNIA FIRMS AND WORKERS.
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
SINCE -- THROUGH AGE RATHER JUNE
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN HIGH SPEED
RAIL SUPPORTED APPROXIMATELY
FORTY THOUSAND DIRECT INDIRECT
IN INDUCED JOB YEARS OF
EMPLOYMENT.
ALL THIS ACTIVITY HAS RESULTED
IN ALMOST THREE MINUTES THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN LABOR INCOME
FOR CALIFORNIA WORKERS.
THIS INCLUDES AGAIN INCOME FROM
DIRECT INDIRECT AND INDUCED
ACTIVITIES.
THE INVESTMENT IN ICE BE ROUTE
HAS RESULTED IN ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY TOTALING OVER SEVEN
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS WITH
TOTAL PROGRAM PROGRAM
EXPENDITURES OF FOUR POINT EIGHT
BILLION.
THIS MEANS THAT EVERY DOLLAR
INVESTED IN HIGH SPEED RAIL
RESULTS IN ABOUT A DOLLAR AND
FIFTY CENTS AND ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY. 54% OF THE X. THIRTIES
EXPENDITURES HAVE OCCURRED AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
IN HERE USE THE DEFINITION OF
AREAS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WOULD SUFFER MOST FROM A
COMBINATION OF ECONOMIC HEALTH
AND ENVIRONMENTAL BURDENS.
THESE BURNS INCLUDE POVERTY HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT HEALTH CONDITIONS
LIKE ASTHMA AND HEART DISEASE AS
WELL AS AIR AND WATER POLLUTION
AND HAZARDOUS WASTE.
AS OF DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE AUTHORITY HAS HAD FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY EIGHT CERTIFIED
SMALL BUSINESSES WORKING ON THE
PROGRAM STATEWIDE.
THE AUTHORITY HAS A 30% SMALL
BUSINESS PARTICIPATION CALL.
INCLUDING 10% DISADVANTAGED
BUSINESS ENTERPRISE
PARTICIPATION.
AND 3% DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISE PARTICIPATION.
IN SUMMARY CALIFORNIA'S
DELIVERING HIGH SPEED RAIL.
BY GETTING TRAINS ON THE GROUND
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHERE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK IS NEAR
COMPLETION AND CONSTRUCTION IS
UNDERWAY.
COMPLAINING THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORK STATEWIDE BY.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO COMPLETING THE
BOOK IN COMMITMENTS IN NORTHERN
AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND BEING PREPARED TO EXPAND THE
SYSTEM CONSISTENT WTH PROP ONE
EIGHT AS FEDERAL IN OR PRIVATE
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
MATERIALIZE.
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS DURING THIS
BY BEING TRANSPARENT ON
OPPORTUNITIES AND CHALLENGES.
MAINTAINING OUR COMMITMENTS TO
THE PARTNERS.
AND DELIVERING HIGH SPEED RAIL
WHILE LIVING WITHIN OUR MEANS.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR PRESENTATION.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE
[inaudible]
OF IN TERMS OF YOUR TIME LINE
CAN YOU GIVE US AN IDEA ABOUT
THAT RICHARD.
TIME LINE'S GOING TO BE --
YOU'RE GOING TO CONSIDER A SOME
DOCUMENTS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
PRESENT TO US IN MAY -- IS THAT
DOCUMENT GOING TO BE REVIEWED BY
THE HIGH SPEED REAL.
OR COMMITTEE BEFORE THEN OR HOW
HOW ARE YOU PROCEEDING.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A WORKSHOP ON
HOW HOW ARE YOU PROCEEDING WITH
THAT.
FROM FROM NOW THROUGH APRIL AND
MAY -- MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT.
AS YOU KNOW THE HIGH SPEED ROSE
COMMITTED TO GETTING THAT.
PROJECT UP THE REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY MAY FIRST --
THERE IS A HIGH SPEED RAIL BOARD
HEARING IN APRIL AND I KNOW --
THE THE BOARD INTENDS TO DISCUSS
SOME OF THE COMPONENTS OF THAT --
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT NOT TODAY
BY BELIEVE NOT THE FULL REPORT
WILL BE RELEASED BUT SOME OF THE
PRESENTATIONAL BE PROVIDED BY
STAFF TO THE BOARD FOR COMMENT
AND ALSO PUBLIC COMMENT.
SO IS THE BOARD GOING ALONG.
CONSIDER VARIOUS OPTIONS -- TO
TAKE PLACE AT THAT TIME OR WHAT
HIS INTENTIONS.
BY THE A THE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT IS AS WAS STATED WITH THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN.
YEAH THERE'S WORK WITH THE EARLY
TRAIN OPERATOR. TO LOOK AT SOME
OF THESE OPTIONS IN MORE DETAIL
THE COST ISSUES THE EARLY
SERVICE.
OPTIONS AND SO THAT'S WHAT -- IS
GOING TO BE BUILT INTO THE PER
WHITES TAKING ON MORE TIME IS TO
YOU KNOW DAD GO INTO MORE DETAIL
ON THAT ARLY CENTRAL VALLEY
SERVICE.
AND PROVIDE MORE DETAIL ON WHAT
THAT SERVICE WOULD LOOK LIKE.
HEY ARE YOU -- GOING TO DEFINE.
THE DIFFERENCES IN THE BUSINESS
PLAN.
THE IT'LL TAKE PLACE WITH THE
PROPOSAL IN MAY.
SO YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SEE
[inaudible]
THE DIFFERENCES.
THAT YOU'RE PROPOSING SURE YES
TO THIS WALL THAT IN OF COURSE
IS THE STATUTORY STRUCTURE
ROUNDED THAT.
PROJECT UPDATE REPORTING THIS
WOULD PROVIDE THOSE UPDATES TO
THE VARIOUS COMPONENTS OF THE
PROJECT -- OKAY -- EIGHTEEN
THIRTY PEOPLE IN THE BAY AREA
SPECIFICALLY.
ARE INTERESTED IN.
WHAT CHANGES YOU'RE PROPOSING TO
THE VALLEY TO VALLEY SEGMENT --
RELATIVE TO ENGINEERING RIGHT
AWAY -- OTHER ACTIVITIES -- HOW
IT CONNECTS WITH THE?
OUR AREA AND I THINK THE SAME
THING WOULD APPLY TO LOS ANGELES
[inaudible]
AREA.
ONE CHANGES YOU'RE PROPOSING OR
ENHANCEMENTS.
YOU WANT TO CONSIDER EITHER ONE
OF THEM.
TERMS OF FUNDING.
IN TERMS OF RIGHT AWAY OF
ENGINEERING.
YOU KNOW GETTING THE PROJECT --
YOU KNOW READY FOR ANY FUTURE
FUNDS THAT WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
SUCCEED IN GETTING.
AND ARE YOU GOING TO BE LOOKING
AT A CONTINGENCY PLAN THAT COULD.
RESULT AS A RESULT OF THE WHAT
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S DOING.
TERMS OF THE NINE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION.
DOLLARS YOU LOOKING LIKE A
CONTINGENCY.
PREPARING ON YOUR CONTINGENCY
FOR THAT -- SO WE BUILD TO KNOW.
WHAT THE IMPACT WOULD THAT HAVE?
ON THE PROJECT -- IN THE IF THEY
DECIDE TO PURSUE THAT HORRIBLE
COURSE OF ACTION.
AND WEEKEND THAT TALK MORE ABOUT
THAT WHEN WE COME BACK -- TO
BRIEF THE COMMITTEE NEXT BECAUSE
CLEARLY A TAKING NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE MILLION OUT OF THE
PROJECT WOULD BE HARMFUL.
AND HAPPY.
TO DELVE INTO THAT IN MORE
DETAIL MISTER SECRETARY LOOKING
LIKE TO YOUR WAS I CORRECT IN
THE SENSE THAT CALIFORNIA ON THE
FORMULAS.
DON'T GET.
CHARLIE THE TAXES THAT WE PAID
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
TRANSPORTATION TAXES.
IN THE FORMALISM BACK TO
CALIFORNIA THAT WE SORT OF MAKE
UP THE DIFFERENCE BY THE GRANTS
THAT WE GIVE FOR VARIOUS
PROJECTS AND WAS THAT A FAIR
CONCLUSION.
YOU'RE HAVING AND THAT WAS
MISTER MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
PRETTY ACCURATE OVER A LONG TERM.
YOU TEND TO BE -- I THINK
CHARACTERIZES AS DONOR STATE
HONORS AND A LOT OF THE HIGHWAY
INVESTMENT IN SOME OF THEIR
COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS IN FACT
SOME OF THE COMPETITIVE PROGRAMS
HAVE 10% CAPS ON HOW MUCH ANYONE
STATE CAN GET AND OF COURSE OUR
POPULATION OF THE NATION'S ABOUT
12% SO -- WORD WERE LIMITED AND
AND MANY TIMES ARE ARE A
COMPETITIVE -- AB APPLICATIONS
CAN BE BELOW THAT 10% --
SOMETIMES SIGNIFICANTLY IN
DIFFERENT GRANT ROUNDS BUT AS
YOU SAY.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
INVEST SIGNIFICANTLY IN TRANSIT.
THAT'S BEEN AN AREA WHERE WIZ
RECEIVED -- YOU KNOW MORE THAN
OUR POPULATION SHARE TO MAKE UP
FOR SOME OF THE DEAF SHORTFALLS
IF YOU WILL IN OTHER MODES RIGHT.
AND THAT'S BEEN THE TRADITIONAL
WAY WE MADE IT UP THIS TRYING TO
GET THESE GRANTS AND YOU KNOW
TRY TO BALANCE IT OUT A LITTLE
BIT AS MUCH AS WE CAN I DON'T
THINK WE'VE EVER RECEIVED.
I HAVE HE ADDED UP FOR A LONG
TERM I THINK WE'RE STILL A QUOTE
DONORS STATE.
A TRUE.
THAT'S THAT'S CORRECT YEAH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS HAS BEEN
AUGMENTING -- THE HIGHWAY TRUST
FUND WITH FEDERAL GENERAL FUNDS
BUT IF YOU LOOK AS A PROPORTION
YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT -- NO IT
TIMES -- THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WOULD SET A 93% -- MINIMUM --
RETURN ON SOME OF THE HIGHWAY
FUNDS AND IN FACT WE WERE AT
THAT LEVEL FOR MANY YEARS AND
CHAU AGAIN AS THAT HIGHWAY FUNDS
BEEN SUPPLEMENTED WERE ABOVE
THAT BUT AGAIN STILL
PROPORTIONATELY WE HAVE THIS.
ISSUE OF BEING A DONOR STATE OF
THE AIR THE ERROR OF FUNDS --
SENATORS STONE IN CAP AND CENTER
GALGIANI TALKED ABOUT THIS THERE
ARE FUNDS WERE TO HELP THE THE
THE TIME IN OUR COUNTRY.
THAT WAS UNDER ECONOMIC CRISIS
AND WAS.
TO HELP STIMULATE THE ECONOMY.
AND IN CALIFORNIA GOT CUT -- THE
GRANT FOR THIS BECAUSE THE VERY
AREA THAT WE WERE SPENDING THE
MONEY IN. FOR THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROJECT WAS ONE OF THE
WORST HIT.
ECONOMIC AREAS IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND CALIFORNIA'S STILL HAS THE
HIGHEST.
PERCENTAGE WISE.
OF OF PEOPLE IN POVERTY.
IN THE UNITED STATES SO THE
ERROR FUNDS WERE MEN
[inaudible] TO FUN PROJECTS TO
HELP THOSE AREAS THAT HAD AN
ECONOMIC -- DOWNTURN
[inaudible]
AND IT'S STILL IN TERMS OF
PERCENTAGE OF ERROR FUNDS WERE
STILL.
AGAIN A DONOR'S STATE AND IN
THAT PART OF MONEY I I I I I
BELIEVE IS THAT TRUE.
AND YOU HAVE ANY CON MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
LOOKS LIKE MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THE LADY THAT WORKED YEAH GO
AHEAD YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT THAT
THE RECOVERY ACT FUNDS WERE TO
TRYING COURAGE -- ECONOMIC
GROWTH PARTICULARLY IN PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY THAT NEEDED THE MOST.
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OF CALIFORNIA
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE WERE TWO OF
THE HARDEST HIT SPOTS.
IN THE GREAT RECESSION AND SO
INVESTING THERE WAS A GOOD IDEA
AT THE TIME IT'S STILL A GOOD
IDEA.
OF AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS AS AN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT PROJECT FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THE IN
LINE AMP AND AT THROUGH THE
THROUGH CONNECTING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
INTO THE BAY AREA.
AND SO YOU'RE RIGHT THAT WAS THE
INTENT AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
CONTINUING TO INVEST THERE WAS A
REQUIREMENT OF THE FUNDS.
AND IT'S ALSO GOOD ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROJECT.
THE IDEA OF TAKING THOSE MONIES
AND SPENDING -- WHEREVER ELSE
WAS.
NOT PART OF OUR PLAN BECAUSE WE
WERE INDEED SPENDING IT AT ONE
OF THE POOREST AREAS OF
CALIFORNIA CORRECT [inaudible]
THE TRUE.
OKAY SO SO -- DO YOU DO.
IN.
CAN YOU KIND OF GIVE US --
OVERVIEW OF WHAT KIND OF FALL.
RELATIONSHIP OVER THE NEXT FEW
MONTHS.
ENTER INTERACTIONS ARE GONNA
HAVE WITH BOTH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE PUBLIC.
ON THIS REVISED PLANS CAN GIVE
SCOPE OUT THAT.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN OVER THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS -- RELATIVE TO
US WERE APPROACHING OUR BUDGET
SEASON -- WE'RE HAVING HEARINGS
IN THE COMMITTEE -- AND I GUESS.
CENTER WHITE HOUSE VIEW OF A
HEARING.
ON THIS SUBJECT COMING UP
CORRECT WE HAVE A HEARING ON
THURSDAY AND THE GREENHOUSE GAS.
FIVE ON THE CAP INTRIGUED
GRINNELL CAP AND TRADE FUND AND
NEXT MONTH FOR TRANSPORTATION --
SO I THINK AT THAT TIME YOU --
TERMS OF THOSE HEARINGS WE WON
THE WAR MAKE SURE A STRONG.
INTERACTION WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
AND OF COURSE THE PUBLIC ON ON
DISCUSSING THESE -- OPTIONS ARE
WHAT THE DIRECTIONS GOING TO BE
SO WE HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
ON DOING THAT IS.
CAN YOU COMMENT ON THAT. ONE NO
IT.
YEAH ABSOLUTELY I SING ME A LOT
BUT I DO I WANT OTHER MEMBERS.
YEAH I I THINK WITH WITH BIG
PROJECTS OF THIS TYPE OF THE
PUBLIC.
ABSOLUTELY NEEDS TO BE ENGAGE
THE LEGISLATURE ABSOLUTELY NEEDS
TO BE ENGAGE SO WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO GROW.
A SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH ALL OF
YOU AND AS I MENTIONED THAT THE
BOARD WILL MEET IN IN APRIL.
AND WE WE HAVE -- THERE IS
HEARINGS COMING UP SO
ANTICIPATED -- YOU KNOW THOSE
DISCUSSIONS GOING FORWARD AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THEM.
AND WE ALSO EXPECT THROUGH THAT
PROCESS BECAUSE ALL OF THE THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
MEASURES THAT ARE.
AS PART OF THE AUTHORITIES
DIRECTION.
WILL BE REVIEWED AT THE BOARD
MEETINGS ALL IN PUBLIC WE ALSO
EXPECT TO HAVE.
A ON A VERY ROBUST TRANSPARENT.
THE BILL WOULD BE TO SAY WHAT
EXACTLY WE'RE DOING AND HOW READ
GOING.
WE GET REGAIN TRUST BY HAVING
CONFIDENCE AND WORKS DOING WHAT
WE SAY WE'RE DOING.
I'LL JUST SAY THIS FOR THE BAY
AREA.
AND PROBABLY A LOS ANGELES A LOT
A LOT OF US -- IN TERMS OF THEIR
IN A REGIONAL REGIONAL AND OTHER
TRANSIT SYSTEMS THAT WE ARE.
SPENDING.
ACTUALLY PROBABLY FEDERAL UP WAY
MORE MONEY THAN YOUR SPENDING
WE'RE UP ALL THE TRANSIT
DISTRICTS IN.
WE'RE GONNA HEAR THEM NACS
THEY'RE PROBABLY IN TERMS OF
SPENDING MONEY SPENDING MORE
MONEY ON PROJECTS.
THEN THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
IN CALIFORNIA ALL THE TRANSIT
PROJECTS AND SO FORTH.
THE HOUSE IN SALES TAX ALL THE
ALL THE DIFFERENT AREAS
SACRAMENTO SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA LA ORANGE COUNTY IN.
SAN DIEGO RIVERSIDE ALL THESE
AREAS ARE SENDING A LOT OF
MONEY.
AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IN TERMS OF IN RELATIONSHIPS IN
TERMS OF ANY CHANGES IN THE PLAN.
THAT THE COMMUNICATION OF WORK
YOU'RE DOING.
DOESN'T CAUSE AN INCREASE IN
COST FOR ANY OF THOSE.
PROJECTS AT OTHER AGENCIES ARE
DOING THEY'RE GONNA TALK NEXT
WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT THIS ****.
BUT I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
THAT.
THERE BE THIS INNER CONNECTION.
OUR DISCUSSION LIKE FOR EXAMPLE
IN MY AREA THE SENATE IS A DERON
STATION -- PROJECT WHEN -- BART
PROJECT HAS BEEN UNDER
CONSTRUCTION.
IN DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE WERE WE
DON'T WANNA.
PUT TO THE BARD IN THERE THEN.
FINISH SHOULD THEN.
COUPLE YEARS LATER HAVE THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL DIG UP TO STATION
AGAIN.
HAVE TO DO A NEW CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT THERE.
AS EXAMPLES OF THE CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT --
ANOTHER ONE DAY A STRANGE.
A CAPITAL QUARTER -- OTHER BART
PROJECTS -- WE WANT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE TIMING AND
COORDINATION.
pLIKE -- LOSS OR TO REQUEST --
FROM THE CONSTRUCTION SIDE OF
THINGS WHAT IS YOUR CONSTRUCTION.
OUTGOING CONSTRUCTION COST THE
SPENDING THAT YOU'RE SPENDING
ARE SLOWING DOWN OR USE WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH THE THE
CONSTRUCTION.
ARE YOU -- ON A SPENDING MONEY --
AS PER PLANNED OR YOU SLOWING
DOWN OR OR WHAT'S HAPPENING.
WITH THE CONSTRUCTION.
AND RIGHT AWAY IN ENGINEERING
SAID SLOWING DOWN.
YES SIR RIGHT NOW AS YOU KNOW
WE'RE JUST COMING THROUGH THE
WINTER MONTHS A LITTLE BIT SLOW
DOWN.
BUT SHE TO THAT GREAT WET ON
FEBRUARY MONTH IN THE VALLEY SO
WE EXPECT T. SANO SLIDES.
IS IS UP TAKING CONSTRUCTION
WE'VE BEEN WORKING SPECIFICALLY
ON RELEASING SITES.
AND PIECES OF ALIGNMENT AS A
GOOD BILL WHICH THAT.
GET THE WORK GOING GET THE WAR.
VERY SPECIFIC FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUAL SITES INDIVIDUAL
BRIDGES INDIVIDUAL MILES
ALIGNMENT.
YOU CAN SEE WHAT HAPPENED COULD
AFFECT THEIR FRAZIER SOLD SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL BONDS TODAY SO I
EXPECT ALL THEIR MONEY TO BE
SPENT AS SOON AS POSSIBLE OKAY
JUST.
YOU KNOW WE WHAT THE WE WANT TO
CONSTRUCTION -- I THINK SOMEBODY
SHOULD -- THE FASTER YOU SPEND.
OF THE BEST VALUE IN GOOD TERMS
OF COSTLY ONE OF DO THOSE KINDS
OF CONSTRUCTION.
WE WANT TO SEE WHAT THE
CONSTRUCTION AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE IT ANALYZE A COURSE BY OR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S AND OTHER
PEOPLE TO FIND OUT -- IN TERMS
OF YOUR CONSTRUCTION SCHEDULES --
WE HAVE SOME OTHER MEMBERS THAT
HAVE QUESTIONS AS CENTER WHAT
COUNTS IN ANSWER GALGIANI AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON
INDICATED THAT ONCE UPON A TIME
THE FEDERAL RAILROAD ASSOCIATION
WAS.
A HAPPY PLACE TO COME FOR THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL I INTO MADE IN
MY OPENING COMMENTS THAT THERE'S
BEEN SOME.
UNNECESSARY DELAYS OR PROJECT
ACTIVITIES -- CAN YOU TOUCH ON
THAT IF.
WHAT'S THE SITUATION CURRENTLY
WITH THE FRA IN AND IF AND IF
THERE ARE DELAYS OR AB.
YEAH I'M APPROVAL OR ACTIVITIES
IS THERE A WORKAROUND POSSIBLE
ON THAT.
I MIGHT START IN AND JOE YOU CAN
CORRECT ME BUT YOU KNOW.
THAT WE HAVE THEY HAD A GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE F. R. A.
OVER THE YEARS ONE OF THE
PROJECTS WE KICKED OFF JOINTLY
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS THIS
ISSUE OF A NATIONAL ON VIA
VERMIN A POLICY ACT ASSIGNMENT
OR NEED BY SIMON AND YOU KNOW
DEVELOPED A PACKAGE -- I I
WORKED ON THAT WE WENT TO
WASHINGTON WORK COOPERATIVELY
WITH STAFF -- THAT NEED
ASSIGNMENT PACKAGE -- WAS
FINALIZED POSTED IN SPRING OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ON FEDERAL
WEBSITES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT --
THE GOVERNOR BROWN FORMALLY SIGN
THE APPLICATION IN JUNE.
AND THAT'S BEEN UNDER FEDERAL.
A CONSIDERATION SINCE BEEN
WITHOUT ACTION -- THE OTHER
THING THAT'S UNFORTUNATE IS
WHILE THEY'RE PHÃN CONSIDERING
THE NEED FOR ASSIGNMENT THAT
STOP WORK AT STOP THE NEED TO
WORK.
ON THE TO AN ENVIRONMENTAL -- AB
THE CHANGES THAT ARE INTO THEM
THAT'S THE BAKERSFIELD -- LOCAL
A PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE IN THE
WHY IN THE SOUTH OF MERCED.
AND SO THOSE ARE -- PROJECTS
WHERE THIS SEQUEL -- PROCESS IS
MOVING FORWARD I IN CALIFORNIA
BUT THE NEPA HAS STALLED AND IN
JODY I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD TO THAT.
YES SIR -- IT'S INTERESTING HERE
IS THE REFEREE'S CREATED A
PARADIGM.
THE SENSE THAT THEY'VE MANDATED --
FULFILLMENT OF THE ARE.
AND THAT IS YOU KNOW BASICALLY
THE VANCE IN OF THE RODS AND
THEN NODS RECORDS DECISION.
THROUGH THROUGH THE PROCESS BY A
TWELVE TWENTY TWO HOWEVER WITH
THE LACK OF PARTICIPATION IN
THAT PROCESS MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT IMPOSSIBLE.
NOW AS A SIGNATURE YOU SALUTE WE
ARE DANCING.
FANCY THAN VITAMIN A CLEARANCE
TO THE CALIFORNIA PROCESS.
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE NOT
PROCESS AS IN TO GAIN THE
INSIGHT THAT WERE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT OF THAT PLANNING.
THE FURTHER MEN OF FOR COST
ESTIMATES.
AND WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
COMMUNITIES TO EVOLVE AND
RESOLVE SOME OF THE ISSUES.
OKAY AT THE OTHER THING I WOULD
I GUESS I WANTED UNDERSTAND WHEN
YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING TO BE
REACHING YOUR ADMINISTRATIVE CAP.
THERE IS A PART PART OF THE ONE
A SET UP A MINISTRY OF CAP THAT
YOU HAD IN IN WHAT WAS THE
ALTERNATIVE.
OF FUNDING SOURCES FOR FOR THAT
[inaudible]
EVENT.
RESPOND CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
SO AT A CURRENT.
ADMIN BUDGET AND THE ADMIN
BUDGET AGAIN IS TO PAY STATE
STAFF -- IT'S AT FORTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- WE WILL
ACTUALLY RUN OUT OF OUR PROP
WHEN A TWO POINT 5% IN ABOUT TWO
YEARS BUT TO FISCAL YEAR --
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IF WE WERE TO
GET THE 5% INCREASE AND WE WE
ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
ALLOWS US TO INCREASE OF UP 25% --
AT THE CURRENT BURN RATE WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO EXTEND OUR
ADMIN BUDGET UP UNTIL FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX OKAY SO
WHERE DOES GET NOW THAT'S THAT'S
AT YOUR FINNISH.
OKAY SIR GALGIANI THANK YOU.
I DID READ THROUGHTHE BUSINESS
PLAN AND I HAD A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AND I THINK THAT YOU
ANSWER BUT I WANTED TO VERIFY.
THE BUSINESS PLAN SAID THAT THE
ALTERNATIVE.
IN THE BAKERSFIELD ERROR AREA.
HAD APPROVAL OF THE SEA QUEST
AND WAS AWAITING FINAL APPROVAL
I WANTED TO VERIFY THAT.
IT THE SEQUEL IS DONE AND THAT
IT'S THE KNEE BUT THAT WERE
WAITING ON YES MA'AM THE SEQUEL
IS COMPLETED AS OF NOVEMBER --
WE ARE CURRENTLY WAITING ON THE
NAY PO WE THIS SUBMITTED THAT TO
THE FRA. THREE GUARDS TO THE
REVIEW THEY HAVE NOT MADE ANY
COMMENTS AS A DATE.
OKAY AND THEN THE SECOND ITEM HE
THERE WHY THAT WE REFER TO WHERE
THEY TRAIN CONTINUES NORTH OR IT
SPLITS WEST. TO GILROY IN SAN
JOSE -- THAT WHY.
WAS I THE PREFERRED ALTERNATIVE
WAS I'D DONE A FIGHT IN MAY OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN DOES THAT MEAN
THAT THE SEQUEL WAS APPROVED.
IN MAY OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN MA'AM
ONLY IN THE NORTHERN MOST MORE
THAN EIGHT MILES OF THAT.
AS YOU APPROACH MORE SAID THAT
YOU HAVE BASICALLY SYKORA AND IS
FOR FILLED FOR THAT -- WE ARE
CURRENTLY PURSUING THE SEQUEL
FOR THE SOUTHERN PORTION OF THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AND THEN -- THE OTHER QUESTION I
HAVE WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE COMING
UP WITH THE COST THAT REMAINS TO
GET TO MERCED FOR THAT LAST
TWENTY FIVE MILES.
IS THAT INCLUDING THE WHY.
JUST TO MERCED OR YOU ALSO
INCLUDING IN THAT COST ESTIMATE
THE WHY THAT HEADS TOWARDS SAN
JOSE.
BECAUSE EMIGRATE IN OPERATIONAL
SEGMENT WE'VE INCLUDED BASICALLY
THE WESTERN PORTION OF THAT AS
AN TO COME INTO MERCED WE ARE
COUNTING THOUGH FOR THE TOTAL Y..
AS WE ADVANCE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROCESS WE HAVE NOT FORGOT OUR
COMMITMENT.
OKAY AND THEN -- WHEN WE CAN
WHEN WE COMPETED FOR THE ARE
DOLLARS IN TWO THOUSAND AND --
NINE CALIFORNIA IT ORIGINALLY
HAD MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD AS ONE
OF THE SEGMENTS WITH THAT WAS
OUTLINED IN PROP ONE NAY.
BUT BECAUSE WE WERE CONCERNED
THAT ONE SEGMENT COULD HOLD BACK
THE OTHER.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY AT
THAT TIME ACTUALLY SPLIT SPLIT
THAT ENTIRE USABLE SEGMENT UP
INTO MERCED FRESNO FRESNO TO
BAKERSFIELD.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS HAS
THERE BEEN ANY THOUGHT FOR OR
COULD THERE BE ANY THOUGHT FOR
TAKING THE MERCED TO SAN JOSE
SEGMENT.
AND LOOKING AT SMALLER BUILDING
BLOCKS IF YOU WERE PERHAPS AT
MERCED TO THE BASE OF THE
TUNNELS.
THE TUNNELS BEING A SECOND
SEGMENT AND PERHAPS THE GILROY
TO SAN JOSE SO THAT WE COULD
LOOK AT WHAT WOULD BE THE COSTS.
FOR EACH AND AS A BODY THE
LEGISLATURE COULD DECIDE WHETHER
WE WANT TO ADVANCE SOME MONIES
FOR LAND ACQUISITION.
AND ONE AREA OR ANOTHER AND AND
HOW HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO
THAT AND GET THEIR SIMILAR TO
WHAT WE DID IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE STRATEGY IS IS A GREAT
STRATEGY AND THAT'S CALM OF THE
APPROACH THAT WE HAVE AS WE CHE.
AS WE COME INTO THE VALLEY THE
VALLEY.
ALMOND LOOKING AT BASICALLY AND
THEN THE BIG PIECE THE STUDY
THERE IS IS THE PROJECT
O'DONNELL'S UNDERSTANDING.
UNDERSTANDING THAT TRUE COST US
THE BIG DRIVER IN THAT SEGMENT --
IN ADVANCING OF OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS WE HOPE TO
BE ABLE TO DO SOME THE GEO
TECHNICAL WORK.
SO THAT'LL GIVE US A GOOD IDEA
OF WHAT THE COST IS AND ALSO TO
WITH REGARDS TO MAKING IT A
COMMERCIALLY VIABLE.
THE MORE INFORMATION YOU NOW THE
LESS RESCUE HALF SO IT MAKES IT
MORE VIABLE TO HAVE THOSE P.
THREE TYPE CONVERSATIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE.
I'D WHEN I LOOKED AT YOUR
PRESENTATION.
WE LOOK AT PROJECTS SO THE
PROJECT UNDER WAY.
CONTRACTS UNDERWAY [inaudible]
OF AND YOU SEE THE RED IN HER
COULD YOU.
I WANT TO KNOW.
ARE THERE ARE VARIOUS SEGMENTS
ARE FALLING BEHIND SCHEDULE.
IN THOSE RED AREAS AND IF SO
WHAT ARE THEY YOU HAVE A YOU
HAVE A MONITORING SYSTEM FOR
THAT CORRECT.
SO COULD YOU GIVE ME A LIST OF
THOSE.
AND WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THOSE
WHY THEY'RE FALLING BEHIND.
I LIKE TO KNOW I MEAN -- I I I I
AM I'M SERVE I I SEE THAT IS SO.
WHEN THEY FALL BEHIND IT SIR
LIKE WHAT'S THE CONTRACTOR DOING
THIS THE QUESTION?
IS THE CONTRACTOR.
PROCEEDING EXPEDITIOUSLY WITH
THE PROJECT [inaudible]
OR TODAY THE LITTLE SPECIAL
TREATMENT.
ON BEHALF OF THE CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT PEOPLE.
OKAY SO I WANNA YOU KNOW THIS
KIND OF BASIC QUESTION.
IF YOU IF YOU HAVE DELAY
CONTRACTS THAN.
THEY'RE GOING TO EAT A PART CASH
BASICALLY.
THERE IS NO PART CASH BY
DELAYING THE PROJECTS.
SO WE HAVE TO KIND OF LIKE PUSH
IT.
YOU KNOW MOVE THE PROJECT SO WE
DON'T HAVE THEM.
DRAIN US.
WORSE THAN THEY ALREADY ARE OKAY.
YES SIR THAT IS THE STRATEGY.
IS BASICALLY IS TO WORK BY
OWNING GLOVES.
AND A PUSH AND A PUSH WITH THE
CONTRACTORS TO GET TO WORK WE'VE
TAKEN THE EVEN SOME VERY
STRATEGIC -- APPROACHES AS ONE
EXAMPLE WOULD BE IS BRINGING IN
FILL IN TWO THREE WHERE WE HAVE
OBSTACLE WITH RIGHT AWAY WE
CANNOT BRING IT IN FROM THE EAST.
SO WE PAID A LITTLE BIT
DIVISIONAL AS AN TO BRING AN END
TO THE WEST WAS A LONGER HAUL.
AND IN DOING SO KEPT THE PROJECT
MOVING.
A NEW HAVE A NEW RIGHT AWAY LAW
WE WE PASSED THE SB WHAT WAS IT
SEVEN ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO LAST
YEAR THAT.
I AUTHORED THAT WOULD.
ALLOW YOU TO DIRECTLY BY RIGHT
AWAY RATHER THAN.
THROUGH THE REGULAR STATE
PROCESS AND THAT'S GOING TO CAN
YOU COMMENT ON HOW THAT STILL TO
IN TERMS OF A EXPEDITING A RIGHT
AWAY PURCHASE PROGRAMS.
YES SIR WE ARE USING I'M ELEVEN
SEVENTY TWO TO OUR FAN H. WE
HAVE JUST STARTED THAT PROCESS
YOU'RE SEEING AN UPTICK IN WITH
THE CARDS THE NUMBER OF RIGHT
AWAY SO WE'RE ABLE TO PROCURE.
RIGHT NOW OUR STRATEGY IS IS
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT WE CALL
THOSE CRITICAL PARTIALS THOSE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO BUY IN
THE MEDIA.
AS AN TO KEEP THE CONSTRUCTION
MOVING FORWARD.
I THINK THE RIGHT AWAY -- JUST
REAL TO THE CENTER GALGIANI
COMMENTS THE TO RIGHT AWAY
BETWEEN SALAS AND WORSE -- THAT
OUGHT TO BE A PRIORITY.
THE THE YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY.
GIVEN WHAT'S GOING ON IN SILICON
VALLEY A HOUSING LAND USE
PROPERTY VALUES.
THE QUICKER YOU CAN BUY THE
PROPERTY THE BETTER I MEAN YOU
CAN'T.
IF I CAN'T EMPHASIZE THE MORE.
WHEN YOU START TO GET INTO THE
BAY AREA URBAN AREA THE PROPERTY
VALUES JUST GOING UP SO FAST?
IT'S A VERY COMMON FINE YOU.
TO TRY TO SECURE RIGHT AWAY IN
YOUR DECISION MAKING ON
PRIORITIES BECAUSE THE RIGHT
AWAY DELAYS.
WOULD BE VERY COSTLY.
AND ELISE'S SILICON VALLEY I
KNOW CERTAINLY AND ALSO TO SOME
EXTENT LOS ANGELES AREAS WORLD
PROPERTY VALUES ARE GOING UP
VERY QUICKLY [inaudible]
OKAY WITH.
MY FOLLOW UP ON YOUR QUESTION
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT THE
CONSTRUCTION PACKAGE NUMBER ONE
MAYBE WE CAN GET THAT UP THERE --
WHICH IS A THIS IS PAGE TWENTY
FOUR BEFORE THE IN JANUARY WE
HAD -- SEVEN POINT TWO FIVE
MILES UNDER CONSTRUCTION IN IN
DECEMBER WE'RE GONNA HAVE
EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE SO THERE'S
PROGRESS ON MILES IN THE
CONSTRUCTION.
THERE WERE WERE NO SEGMENTS THAT
WERE COMPLETED AND THERE WERE NO
AND IN DECEMBER THERE'S NO
SEGMENTS COULD BE COMPLETED.
WAS THE OTHER THE AD SHERMAN
BELLS WAS THAT.
ALWAYS ANTICIPATED BECAUSE IT'S
GONNA TAKE TWO YEARS TO BUILD
THOSE SEGMENTS OR WAS THERE
SOMETHING SOMETHING THAT.
AN INTERVENTION THEY CAME IN FOR
BECAUSE OF THESE DELAYS THAT YOU
KNOW. FOR FOR THE MILE SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE BUT WE JUST.
WE COULDN'T GET THE CLEARANCE OR
WEAKENED CONTRACTOR DID
SOMETHING I MEAN IT WAS THAT THE
SCHEDULE THAT WE EIGHT WOULD
HAVE ANTICIPATED TWO YEARS AGO
OR THREE YEARS AGO.
SIR NOW THAT IS NOT TO SCHEDULE.
AS YOU CAN SEE BY THE REGIONAL
CONTRACTING POLLUTION DATES AND
ALL THREE OF THOSE WE ARE.
AT THEM OR PASS THEM BASICALLY
ALL THREE THE SEGMENTS WHAT IS
HAPPENING ALL THROUGH THE
SAVINGS IS WE JUST ARTICULATED.
THROUGH THROUGH THE ISSUES THAT
WE HAD BASICALLY WITH
PROCUREMENT OF RIGHT AWAY.
AND WHAT WE CALL CALL BASICALLY
CONTRIBUTING SCOPE SO SHE TO
PREDOMINATELY WITH THIRD PARTIES
A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS WOULD BE
THE INTRUSION PRODUCTION BARRIER
SYSTEMS.
ASSOCIATED WITH THE CHANGE AND
RAILROADS SINCE WE DID NOT HAVE
A MASTER AGREEMENT IN PLACE AT
TIME OF AWARD.
RIGHT WE NEGOTIATED THOSE MASTER
AGREEMENT SIEGE TO MAKE THAT
REQUIREMENT.
OUT NOW THAT WE HAVE THOSE
AGREEMENTS AND WE KNOW WHAT THE
REQUIREMENT IS WHICH IS REQUIRED
BASICALLY ACTUAL CONSTRUCTION
AND THAT IS WHAT WE'VE WE'VE
ARTICULATED BEFORE.
IN THE PROPOSED COST OVER RUNS
AT THOSE KASTRO RUNS A BIG PIECE
OF THEM HAD BEEN TO SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTION TO CONSTRUCTION.
DOES SHE ALSO HAVE IN THAT CASE
MORE TIME MORE TIME.
THE GAL JENNY.
ALSO TO RESPOND TO MY COLLEAGUE --
THERE WAS AN EMPHASIS ON EARLY
WORKS PROJECTS SO IN OTHER WORDS
THE BRIDGES AND THE GRADE
SEPARATIONS SO THAT COMMUNITIES
WOULD FEEL SOME BENEFITS.
BEFORE THEY WOULD JUST FEEL HIGH
SPEED RAIL COMING IN AND TEARING
THROUGH THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
TEARING UP THE ROADS AND SO
FORTH.
AND ALSO TO MA'AM THATIS THE
CRITICAL PATH OF THE PROJECT IS
THOSE STRUCTURES.
IF YOU LOOK AT AND THEN FRESNO
THOSE ICONIC STRUCTURES YOU
DRIVE BY.
THOSE THOSE MILE LONG VIADUCTS
THAT IS THE CRITICAL PATH TO THE
CONSTRUCTION.
OKAY ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
YOU BEING HERE AND KEEP WORKING
HARD AND LET'S TRY TO GET THAT.
NINE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS STAYING IN CALIFORNIA WE
DON'T WANT TO GO.
TO WE DON'T WANT TO GO THE TAXES
ARE FLORIDA TO BE HONEST ABOUT
IT.
BECAUSE I I I I THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S OUR MONEY.
LET'S NOT GO TO THE SITE HAVE
THEIR MONEY SLIP AWAY.
OKAY WE HAVE AN EXPAND ONLY A
JIM HARDEN A CALTRAIN AND
STEPHANIE WIGGINS'S -- CO
METROLINK [inaudible]
AND JENNETTE -- LANCE'S SENIOR
EXECUTIVE AT LA METRO SO WE'RE
GONNA HEAR THE REGIONAL
INVESTMENTS AND HOW THAT'S GOING
AND AND GUYS FIGURE OUT GET YOUR
STUFF.
WHO'S GOING FIRST
[inaudible]
OKAY.
STEPHANIE OR YOU.
YOU JUST GOT APPOINTED RIGHT.
WELL I JUST WANT TO SAY I'M SO
EXCITED CONGRADULATIONS FIND THE
THE IN OUR NEW IG.
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER AT
METROLINK IT'S IT'S GREAT. TO TO
SEE YOU HERE WITH US FOR THE
FIRST TIME IS YOUR IN YOUR NEW
POSITION.
SO CONGRATULATIONS TO YOU AND
WE'LL START WITH JIM AND JIM --
ARNETT AND HE'S THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER.
AT CALTRAIN SO.
THANK YOU TEARS.
ANSWER BILL IT'S A PARTICULAR
PRIVILEGE TO BE HERE TO TO
PRESENT AGAIN ON A UPDATE ON OUR
CALTRAIN SYSTEM ELECTRIFICATION
PROGRAM -- AND IT'S SOMETIMES
DIFFICULT TO PRESENT TO CENTER
BILL TO YOU SINCE YOU WERE ON
THE BOARD YEARS AGO AND NO MORE
ABOUT.
TO THE TRAIN SYSTEM THAN MOST IS
SO -- I HOPE BY I DON'T BORE YOU
WITH SOME THINGS THAT TO YOU YOU
KNOW ALL TOO WELL [inaudible]
SAID THE BUT AS YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE PROBABLY ONE OF THE
FASTEST GROWING TRANSIT REGIONAL
BOARD IN NINETEEN NINETY TO
NINETEEN NINETY TWO A YOUNG AND
TENDER AGE.
YES.
A LONG TIME AGO YES SO WEB BUT
IT AS YOU KNOW YOU LAID THE
FOUNDATION FOR A A A FAST
GROWING TRANSIT SYSTEM THAT'S
BEEN ONE OF THE FASTEST GROWING
AND IN RECENT YEARS.
WE HAVE CURRENTLY ABOUT SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND RIDERS PER DAY ON
NINETY TWO TRAINS HONOR WEEK
DAYS -- CONNECTING SAN FRANCISCO.
SAN JOSE AND SELL TO GILROY --
WE ESTIMATE.
AT LEAST I I DO A SIMPLE
CALCULATION EVERY SINGLE WORK
DAY THERE'S ABOUT ONE MILLION
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND MILES NOT
DRIVEN BECAUSE OF FOLKS -- WHO
RIGHT ARE CALTRAIN SYSTEMS WE
FEEL THAT WE HAVE A PRETTY GOOD
IMPACT ON CONGESTION?
IN THE REGION TO JUST BY WHAT WE
DO TODAY.
BUT THE ELECTRIFICATION OF
CALTRAIN IS CAN ALLOW US TO DO
MORE -- AS SOON AS SOME OF YOU
KNOW WE ARE GOING THROUGH A VERY
EXTENSIVE BUSINESS PLANNING
PROCESS IT IS LOOKING.
TO WHAT THE DEMAND WOULD BE FOR
OUR SERVICES AS FAR OUT AS
TWENTY FORTY AND HOW WE CAN
CAPTURE THAT DEMAND WHAT THE
INVESTMENTS -- WOULD BE NEEDED
TO DO SO WE WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WE CAN -- EASILY DOUBLE OUR
RIDERSHIP IN IN LIKELY TRIPLET
WITH THE RIGHT INVESTMENTS BUT
THE ELECTRIFICATION IS THE
FOUNDATION FOR THAT -- YOU KNOW
OUR OUR RIGHT OF WAY -- BEGAN TO
EXIST IN THE DAYS OF ABRAHAM
LINCOLN -- WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
A FOUNDATIONAL CHANGE NOW BY
WHAT WE DO WITH OUR INVESTMENTS
TO BRING US INTO THE MODERN.
ERA BUT OUR BUSINESS PLAN THAT
WILL BE COMPLETE OF LIKELY BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR IS GOING TO
PROVIDE THE ROADMAP FOR AN
EXPANDED.
ELECTRIFIED SERVICE THAT
EVENTUALLY WILL INCLUDE HIGH
SPEED RAIL OUR BUSINESS PLAN IN
INCLUDES A HIGH SPEED RAIL -- WE
ARE -- WE ARE PARTNERS IN A
STRONG BLENDED PLANNING SYSTEM
AND ANALYSIS.
IN WE WORK VERY WELL TOGETHER
AND BLENDED PLANNING.
BUT WE ARE SEPARATE AND TO
PROJECTS -- THAT DISTINCTION IS
MADE CLEAR THROUGH OUR OF
VARIOUS -- LEGAL AGREEMENTS AND
LEGISLATION AND COURT DECISIONS.
AND THE COURT DECISIONS ACTUALLY
HAVE BEEN HELPFUL FOR BOTH OF US
IN THE SENSE THAT -- AS WITH ANY
BIG PROJECT -- BUT THE LECTURES
CATION PROJECT -- WENT THROUGH
LITIGATION BUT THE LITIGATION
WAS AIMED MORE AT STOPPING OUR
ASSOCIATION WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND MAKING IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL TO COME THROUGH
THAN IT WAS.
TO STOP OR ELECTRIFICATION.
BUT OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM IS STILL GOING THROUGH
ITS OWN ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS
FOR OUR OUR LEGO OF OF HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
OURS IS COMPLETED IN THE CORD --
WHEN IT RULED THAT IN A WAY THAT
I THOUGHT PROTECTED BOTH OF US
SAID THE ARE?
CALTRAIN CALTRAIN PROJECT IS ONE
OF INDEPENDENT UTILITY.
THAT CALTRAIN HAS BEEN SEEKING
TO EMPLOYMENT FOR NEARLY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
I THAT THAT IS ABSOLUTELY TRUE
THE ELECTRIFICATION HAS BEEN --
PART OF THE PLANNING PROCESS FOR
CALTRAIN FROM THE NINETEEN
NINETIES -- AND AS THE COURT
SAID THAT YEAR.
ELECTRIFICATION IS DISCRETE FROM
HIGH SPEED RAIL FUTURE BLENDED.
SYSTEM DESIGN CONSTRUCTION AND
OPERATION.
AS TO WHICH SEPARATE
ENVIRONMENTAL ANALYSIS AND
CERTIFICATION WILL BE REQUIRED
HAVEN'T BEEN THAT'S WHAT HIGH
SPEED RAIL IS WORKING ON NOW IS
TO GO THROUGH ITS.
IT'S ANALYSIS AND WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THIS.
BUT I HAVE TO SAY THAT.
YOU KNOW I A REAL REALLY
APPRECIATE THE CONTEXT THAT
SERVER GALGIANI GAVE AND WITH
RESPECT TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
I YOU KNOW IT IT REALLY BROUGHT
TO MIND A TIME WHEN I WAS ON THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY BOARD
AND AND HER GREAT SUPPORT.
OF FOR THE FOUNDATIONAL.
REQUISITES FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL.
IN AYE AYE AYE AT THAT TIME AND
IN IN STORE NOW BELIEVE THAT THE
INVESTMENT OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL FOR THE A
REASONS THAT SHE ARTICULATED.
AND BECAUSE SPINE YOU CAN'T
COMPLETE THE SYSTEM.
IT JUST AS THE INVESTMENTS IN
THE BOOKENDS NORTH AND SOUTH ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
THOSE INVESTMENTS IN THE
BOOKENDS HAVE INDEPENDENT
UTILITY AS THE REST OF THE
SYSTEM IS IS GETTING IN PLACE
AND THAT INDEPENDENT UTILITY.
HAS TREMENDOUS BENEFIT FOR THE
REGION AND FOR THE STATE.
I IN FACT AT THE REFERENCE TO
ACING CAPITOL CORRIDOR AMTRAK --
YOU KNOW THEY CONNECT UP TO OUR
CALTRAIN SYSTEM.
AND SO -- WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE TO US IN TERMS OF --
CONNECTIVITY WITH US IN A REAL
ROBUST STATEWIDE REAL SYSTEM SO
THAT INVESTMENT IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IS IMPORTANT TO US.
TO JUST AS THE COMMITMENT TO OUR
THE INVESTMENT IN THE BOOKENDS
IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE THE
CONFIDENCE THE STATE HAS PUT IN
US.
WE RECEIVED I IN ADDITION TO THE
FUNDS ALREADY MENTIONED WE
RECEIVED A AND T. I. R. C. P.
FUNDS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY NINE
MILLION DOLLARS.
UNDER SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS --
TO PURCHASE ADDITIONAL ELECTRIC --
UNITS -- SO WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL
OF OF LIKE THE TRAIN SETS -- TO
FURTHER -- CAPACITY AND HAVE A
CLEANER ELECTRIFIED SERVICE.
BUT I CAN SAY TO YOU THAT -- WE
ARE -- OUR PROJECT IS IS
FORECAST TO BE COMPLETE OUR ON
TIME WITHIN -- TWENTY TWENTY TWO
WITH -- FULLY OPERATIONAL LECTER
FIGHT SERVICE IN IS FORECAST TO
BE COMPLETED WITHIN BUDGET.
AND AS SUCH TIME AS A HIGH SPEED
RAIL IS IS READY TO COMMON
COMPLETES ITS -- IN FAR MENTAL
WORK AND AND HAS HAS OTHER
THINGS IN ORDER WE KNOW THAT
WILL BE WORKING TOGETHER IN THE
QUARTER AND ARE ARE BLENDED
SYSTEM AND AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT [inaudible]
OKAY -- STEPHANIE I BELIEVE YOUR
SOMETHING WE CAN SIMPLY HIS NECK
SO [inaudible]
METROLINK.
THE DEL PERRO.
OF GOOD AFTERNOON THERE ARE THE
FOR ALL GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
WHILE THEY WORK ON THE
TECHNOLOGY.
NOW THAT.
TENANTS.
I WANNA THANK TERRIBLE TERRIBLE
KASKI IN THE SENATORS -- FOR
INVITING ME TO SPEAK ON OUR
AGENCIES CONTINUED COORDINATION
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY.
METROLINK PROVIDES COMMUTER RAIL
SERVICE TO SIX SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES -- THAT'S
VENTURA COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SAMITY DINO
COUNTY SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY.
AND WE TO LIKE CALTRAIN OR NOT
ALTERNATIVE TO DRIVING A
REGION'S SEVERELY CONGESTED
FREEWAYS.
AS METROLINX NEW CEO I AM
COMMITTED TO DELIVERING A
CUSTOMER FOCUS SYSTEM THAT FULLY
INTEGRATES METROLINK WITH ALL OF
OUR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PARTNERS.
METROLINK IS POISED TO DELIVER
SUCCESS ON MANY OF THE
PRIORITIES IN THE STATE'S RAIL
PLAN.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO DOUBLING
OUR RIDERSHIP IN THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS.
I'M ACTUALLY CONNECTS PEOPLE TO
OPPORTUNITY EVERY DAY.
MY VISION FOR THE REGION IS TO
EMERGE AS THE SAFEST MOST
RELIABLE INNOVATIVE AND CUSTOMER
FOCUSED REGIONAL RAIL AGENCY
ANYWHERE.
WE ARE PART OF A LARGER TRANSIT
ECO SYSTEM THAT BRINGS TOGETHER
ALL FORMS OF TRANSPORTATION TO
CONNECT COMMUNITIES AN
OPPORTUNITY.
MORE THAN 85% OF OUR WRITERS
MAKE THE SMART CHOICE EVERY DAY
BY LEAVING THEIR CARS AT HOME
AND TAKING THE TRAIN.
SO MEASURE LINK SERVICE IMPROVE
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE AND
REAFFIRMS OUR COMMITMENTS TO A
SUSTAINABLE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY TWO WE
HAVE OPERATED IN OUR REGION'S
MOST TRAVELED CORRIDORS AND
URBAN AND RURAL AREAS.
OUR FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MILES OF TRACK WE SHARE WITH
INNER CITY SERVICE ALONG THE LOS
AND CORRIDOR.
AND BOTH BNSF AND UNION PACIFIC
ARE HIGHLY CONSTRAINED IN
SUPPORT CRITICAL RAIL OPERATIONS
IN A REGION OF NATIONAL
SIGNIFICANCE.
COMMUTER RAIL SERVICE IS KEY TO
REDUCING VEHICLE TRIPS
CONNECTING HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT CENTERS AND AVOIDING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
WE KNOW THAT RAIL KEEP SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MOVING.
AS THE PORTS OF LOS ANGELES LONG
LONG BEACH A WHINY ME CONTINUE
TO FORECAST A GROWING INFLUX OF
SHIPMENTS COMMERCE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE CARRIED VIA RAIL ON SHARED
METROLINK RIGHTS OF WAY. TO
DESTINATIONS ACROSS THE NATION.
METROLINK SERVICE ALSO PROVIDES
A CRITICAL CONNECTION BETWEEN
THE STATE'S TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENTS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
ACROSS ALL MODES INCLUDING LIGHT
RAIL BUS AN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION COMMUTER RAIL IS
THE LINK TO LOCAL SYSTEMS ACROSS
THE REGION.
WHEN THE STATE FIRST BEGAN
DISCUSSING THE INTRODUCTION OF
HIGH SPEED SERVICE CONNECTING
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA?
METROLINK ECHO THE VOICES OF
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS IN COLLEGE
CLOSE COORDINATION WITH EXISTING
PASSENGER RAIL OPERATORS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
METROLINK TRAINS CAN CURRENTLY
TRAVEL AT SPEEDS UP TO SEVENTY
NINE PARK MILES PER HOUR WITH
HIGHER SPEEDS POSSIBLE.
OUR NEW TWO YEAR FOR LOCOMOTIVES
ARE CAPABLE OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILES PER HOUR WITH IMPROVE
TRACK AND OPERATING CONDITIONS.
IN OUR EARLY DISCUSSIONS OUR
REGION COMMUNICATED ITS SUPPORT
OF BEING BOLD AND OUR
INVESTMENTS IN CONNECTIVITY AND
BOOK AND OPERATIONS.
IT WAS IDENTIFIED THAT THE NEED
FAR OUTWEIGHED THE AVAILABLE
INVESTMENTS AND WE REMAIN
FOCUSED ON ENCOURAGING THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY TO IDENTIFY AND
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS THAT SUPPORT
EXISTING OPERATORS.
ALONG THE IDENTIFIED PHASE ONE
AND PHASE TWO ROUTES.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL PROGRAM.
AS THE VISION AND PHASES HAVE
CHANGED OVER TIME THE
INTRODUCTION OF HIGH SPEED
SERVICE AND SHARED URBAN
CORRIDORS CONTINUES TO REAFFIRM
THE NEED FOR COORDINATION WITH
EXISTING RAIL OPERATORS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS RECOGNIZED
THIS NEED AND PROVIDED CRITICAL
CONNECTIVITY AND BOOK AND
INVESTMENTS FOR LOCAL OPERATORS
WE APPRECIATE THE STATE'S
INVESTMENTS OF PROP ONE A
REVENUES TO PROJECTS.
ACROSS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING THE LINK UNION STATION
PROJECT AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
TIMELY COMMITMENT OF REMAINING
OBLIGATIONS.
THE LINK UNION STATION PROJECT
WILL TRANSFORM PASSENGER RAIL
SERVICE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
THE PROJECT IS A CENTRAL PART OF
METROLINX LONG TERM CAPITAL
PROGRAM.
AND UNION STATION IS THE HUB OF
OUR RAIL NETWORK AND
TRANSFORMING THAT STATION WITH
RUN THROUGH TRACKS WILL
ACCOMMODATE FUTURE
TRANSPORTATION DEMANDS IN THE
REGION.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE STATE'S
COORDINATION WITH LA METRO TO
FINALIZE THE FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
THREE MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING
COMMITMENT FOR THE PROJECT.
IN ADDITION AS HAS BEEN
MENTIONED IN AN EARLIER PANEL
THE SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION
IDENTIFIED FOR THE ROSE QUITE AS
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT GRADE
SEPARATION PROJECT.
WILL IMPROVE THE SAFETY IN
OPERATIONS OF ONE OF THE MOST
TRAVERSE PASSENGER AND FREIGHT
CROSSINGS IN THE STATE.
PROJECT BENEFITS ALSO INCLUDE
INCREASING PASSENGER RAIL
CAPACITY TO THE INLAND EMPIRE BY
60%.
AND PROVIDING A CRITICAL A
TENTATIVE TO THE FIVE FREEWAY.
WE APPRECIATE THE STATE'S
RECOGNITION OF RAIL FUNDING
NEEDS IN THE REGION.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S INTEREST IN
COMPLETING THE FIRST PHASE
BETWEEN MERCED IN BAKERSFIELD
THERE ARE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITIES
TO SUPPORT THE EXISTING RAIL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND COORDINATE
WITH MET CHILLING FOR THE
ANAHEIM TO BURBANK CORRIDOR.
WHILE ENVIRONMENTAL PLANNING FOR
PROJECTS SEGMENTS BETWEEN
BAKERSFIELD AND SAN DIEGO
CONTINUE WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUING FUNDING DISCUSSIONS
FOR THE NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN
CONNECTIONS.
AND THE METROLINK SERVICE AREA
THERE ARE PROJECTS WITH
INDEPENDENT UTILITY THAT CAN
DELIVER SERVICE IMPROVEMENTS TO
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIA'S.
CALIFORNIANS RATHER THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OPTIMIZE RAIL
EXPANSION OUR SCORE PROGRAM IS A
TEN BILLION DOLLAR CAPITAL PLAN
TO UPGRADE THE REGIONAL RAIL
SYSTEM TO MEET THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE NEEDS OF THE TRAVELING
PUBLIC.
BY ADDING TRACKS GRADE
SEPARATIONS AND UPGRADING SIGNAL
SYSTEMS ACROSS THE ENTIRE IMAGE
LINK SYSTEM TRAINS CAN OPERATE
MORE FREQUENTLY AND RELIABLY
MAKING REGIONAL RAIL EASIER AND
MORE CONVENIENT TO USE.
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WILL ALSO BENEFIT
FROM A REDUCTION IN VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED.
BY WHICH WOULD THERE WILL BE A
REDUCTION IN GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS OF MORE THAN FIFTY
MILLION METRIC TONS WE'RE
EXCITED THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY IS SUPPORTIVE OF OUR
SCORE PROGRAM.
THE GOAL IS TO DELIVER THE
PROGRAM IN TIME TO CONNECT OUR
REGION FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OLYMPIC AND PARALYMPIC
GAMES.
THE STATE'S COMMITMENT.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL BUT CAN
PROJECTS IS JUST THE BEGINNING
OF THE SCORE PROGRAM.
MAJOR LEAGUE RECEIVED A HISTORIC
GRANT AWARD FROM THE TRANSIT IN
INNER CITY CAPITAL PROGRAM TO
BEGIN FUNDING PROJECTS ACROSS
THE SYSTEM.
AND IN ADDITION WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED OVER EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN CAPITAL PROJECTS THAT
ARE SHOVEL READY IN THE BURBANK
TO ANAHEIM CORRIDOR AND READY TO
BE DELIVERED TO THE REGION IF
FUNDING CAN BE SAID.
IN CONCLUSION.
A HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT WILL
BE COMPLEX AND REQUIRES CAREFUL
PLANNING WITH PARTNERS
THROUGHOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING METROLINK.
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNICATE EARLY AND OFTEN AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING TOGETHER
AND DELIVERING A PREMIER RAIL
NETWORK FOR THE REGION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FROM
METROLINK -- WILL NOW HEAR FROM.
GENERAL ONES FROM THE SENIOR
EXECUTIVE OFFICER LA METRO
[inaudible]
NUMBER OF YEAH OKAY THIS IS WHAT
I WANT TO HEAR ABOUT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BALLOTS
CHAIRMAN WITH KASKI COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND SENATORS.
MATCH CHAU HAS BEEN WORKING WITH
A HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
SINCE ITS INCEPTION IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINE AND LIKE ALL
NEW LARGE SCALE TRANSFORMATIVE
RAIL PROJECTS.
MACHU IS FULLY AWARE OF THE
CONSIDERABLE CHALLENGES FACING
HIGH SPEED RAIL.
FROM PLANNING ENVIRONMENTAL
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN BUSINESS PLAN WAS AN
HONEST ASSESSMENT OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
AND WE RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL COMPLETING
THE INITIAL ONE HUNDRED AND
NINETEEN MILE OF OPERATING
SEGMENTS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
HOWEVER AT THE SAME TIME.
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT BENEFITS
THAT COME FROM MAKING MORE
INVESTMENTS IN THE RAIL SYSTEM
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
THAT SPEED UP RAIL SERVICE IN.
THAT WILL INCREASE TRAVEL TIMES
AND IMPROVE COMMUTES FROM PEOPLE
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHO ARE ALREADY MAKING TWO TO
THREE HOURS COMMUTE ONE WAY?
DESPITE THESE CHALLENGES.
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF A HIGH SPEED RAIL
GUIDING PRINCIPLES MAKING
STRATEGIC CONCURRENCE.
INVESTMENTS IN THE EXISTING RAIL
SYSTEM.
THAT WILL BE RULING.
OVER TIME WITH THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE MOBILITY ECONOMIC AND
INVOKED ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WHILE POSITIONING HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY TO CONSTRUCT
ADDITIONAL SEGMENTS AS FUNDING
BECOMES AVAILABLE.
Q. KEY BOOK AND INVESTMENTS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA ARE THE LINK
UNION STATION PROJECT AND THE
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT GREAT
SEPARATION AND I'LL JUST GIVE
YOU A QUICK OVERVIEW OF THESE
TWO PROJECTS.
LOS ANGELES UNION STATION IS THE
LARGEST MULTIMODAL HUB IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
SERVING APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PASSENGERS A DAY WITH
OUR MATCHES SUBWAY LIGHT RAIL.
AND OVER A HUNDRED OVER A
THOUSAND BUSES METRO BUSES
MUNICIPAL BUSES INCLUDING
INTERCITY AMTRAK BUSES.
UNION STATION WITH BUILT IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE AS
SEVENTY TRACKS AS YOU CAN SEE
HERE IN THE PICTURE ALL TRAINS
ENTER FROM THE NORTH OF THE
NORTH IS WHERE THE THROAT AREA
IS THE SOUTH IS WHERE YOU
SEATING BOTTOM THAT THE US ONE
AND ONE FREE WAY.
TODAY EIGHTY YEARS LATER TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FROM TWO FROM.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE IT IS
LARGELY THE SAME.
WITH THE EXCEPTION THAT WOULD BE
BUILT ANOTHER SEVEN PLATFORMING
UNION STATION SO YOU MAY THINK
SIX BACK FROM HERE THERE'S
ACTUALLY SEVEN PLATFORMS ALREADY
THERE.
SO THAT'S THE CHANGE AND EIGHTY
YEARS.
WELL AT LEAST UNION STATION
PROJECT WILL TRANSFORM HOW ARE
REGIONAL RAIL SYSTEM OPERATES IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
BY PROVIDING RUN THROUGH TRACKS
THAT WILL IN ABLE ONE SEAT RIDES
FOR INNER CITY AMTRAK.
TRAINS AS FAR NORTH AS SAN
FRANCISCO AND AS FAR SOUTH AS
SAN DIEGO.
THIS IS A GAME CHANGER FOR A
REGIONAL RAIL SYSTEM.
IN ADDITION TO THAT IT WILL ALSO
ACCOMMODATE A FUTURE HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
WITH UP TO WITH UP TO FOUR TWO
PLATFORMS AND FOUR TRACKS.
DELINKING IN STATION PROJECT HAS
BROKEN OUT INTO TWO PHASES OF
YOU SEE HERE IN THE CHART.
YOU'LL HAVE THE RUN THROUGH
TRACKS ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
THAT WILL BE PART OF THE PHASE
ONE THAT WILL ALSO INCLUDE EARLY
TRACK AND SIGNAL WORK.
AND THE FACE TIãU ARE WHAT WE
CALL PHASE BE WILL ALL WILL NOW
INCLUDE THE FULL PLATFORM AND
RAISING OF THE RAIL YARD OVER
THE US ONE AND ONE FREEWAY.
SO HERE IS THE FUNDING PLAN FOR
THE FREE FOR THE LINK UNION
STATION PROJECT PARTICULARLY THE
FIRST PHASE WHICH WE CALL PHASE
HEY.
AS YOU CAN SEE THE BOOK AND
PROJECT INVESTMENTS FROM THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS ROUGHLY FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY TO
SECURE A FUNDING AGREEMENT FROM
THEM.
AS EARLY AS SUMMER OF THIS YEAR
BUT NO HOPEFULLY NO LATER THAN
FALL OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN IN
ADDITION TO THAT.
THE T. I. R. C. P. AS PART OF
METROLINX OVERALL SCORE PROGRAM
AWARDED THE LINKING AND STATION
PROJECT APPROXIMATELY. THREE
HUNDRED AND NINETY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS AND THE REST OF THE
REMAINING IS LOCAL FINDS.
HERE IS WHAT WE'RE BUILDING IN A
LINKING AND STATION AS PART OF
PHASE ONE THE REAL CONSTANT
SIGNALS DATES BACK.
TO NINETEEN THIRTY NINE AND SO
IT WE WILL TRANSFORM THAT BY
COMPLETELY REVAMPING THE RAIL
CONSTANCE SINGLES AT UNION
STATION AND COMPLETING ACTION
THE ACTUAL BUILD OUT OF THE
ENTIRE RUN THRILLED TRACKS.
THE ENTIRE STRUCTURE THAT WILL
ALSO A COMEDY THE FUTURE HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
BUT IT'S PART OF AN INDEPENDENT
UTILITY WE WILL START OUT WITH
Q. OPERATING RUN THROUGH TRACKS
AS PART OF PHASE A SO WE WILL
TEMPORARILY BUILT A RUN THROUGH
TRACK PLATFORM ON WHAT WE CALL
PLATFORM FOR WHICH IS RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE RAIL YARD.
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROCESS WE HAVE
MOVED FORWARD WITH SEPARATING
THE KNEE BEND THE SEQUEL.
THE SEQUEL IS ANTICIPATED TO BE
COMPLETED BY JUNE OF THIS YEAR'S
AND A COUPLE OF MONTHS WE'VE
ALREADY COMPLETED -- WE'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED THE COMMENTS TO
THE DRAFT DIR AND WE HOPE TO
FINALIZE THE SEQUEL PROCESS.
BUDGET.
NOW I'M GOING TO SWITCH OVER TO
ONE OF THE GREAT SEPARATION THE
FIRST BOOK AND PROJECT BY THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL WHICH IS THE
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT.
IT WILL SCAN SMARTCARD IS
LOCATED IN THE CITY OF SANTA FE
SPRINGS.
IT IS A DIAGONAL CROSSING SEE
YOU CAN SEE HERE THE DIAGONAL
CROSSING IT'S LOCATED IN ONE OF
THE BUSIEST GOODS MOVEMENT
CORRIDOR IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IT IS OWNED BY BURLINGTON NORTH
SANTA FE.
AND OPERATED BY BNSF AS WELL.
THIS BECAUSE OF THE DIAGONAL
CROSSING IN BECAUSE OF A OVER A
HUNDRED AND TWELVE FREIGHT AND
PASSENGER TRAINS THAT PASSED BY
EACH WEEKDAY.
WITH OVER FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
VEHICLES IT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS ONE OF THE MOST HAZARDOUS
CROSSING BY THE CP YOU SEE IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SO
ESSENTIALLY TRAINS COME ACROSS
THAT THIS GREAT CROSSING EVERY
TEN MINUTES.
AND FREIGHT TRAINS UNLIKE
PASSENGER TRAINS IT SEEMS LIKE A
LONG STRETCH I JUST KIND OF WANT
TO POINT THAT OUT.
HERE IS THE GRADE SEPARATION
PROJECT OF THE PROPOSED
CONDITION THIS ACCOMMODATES UP.
TO FOUR ACCOMMODATES HIGH SPEED
RAIL BY INCLUDING UP TO FOUR
TRACKS AND JOURNEY FIFTH GRADE
SEPARATION.
RIGHT NOW BEING A STEP IS
COMPLETING THE THIRD -- MAINLINE
TRACK BY THE END OF THIS YEAR
WHICH WILL ALLOW ADDITIONAL TIME
SPOTS BECAUSE THIS IS OPERATED
AND MAINTAINED BY BEING A STAFF.
PASSENGER RAIL SERVICE IS
THOUGHT IS PROVIDED TIME SLOTS
ALONG THE CORRIDOR.
THE WITH THE THIRD MAILING TRACK
AND WITH THE GROCERY AS
MARQUARDT GRADE SEPARATION IT
REALLY PROVIDES ADDITIONAL TIME
SLOTS FOR METROLINK AN AMTRAK
TRAINS.
SO HERE'S THE FUNDING PLAN AS
YOU CAN SEE.
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS PROVIDING 50%
OF THE INVESTMENT IN THE
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT WE'VE
ALREADY RECEIVED THE BENEFITS OF
THIS WE'RE IN IN THE PROCESS OF
REAL ESTATE ACQUISITION.
WE WE HAVE ALREADY SUBMITTED AT
LEAST TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL FOR THEIR
INVESTMENTS IN THE RESIDENTS
MARQUARDT GRAY SEPARATION.
WE HOPE TO SICK COMPLETES THE
CONSTRUCTION AND UP BY TWENTY
TWENTY THREE AND HOPE TO WARD
CONSTRUCTION BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THE NOW I'M JUST
GOING TO PLAY A VIDEO OF THE
LINK UNION STATION PROJECT I DO
YOU WANT TO ADD A QUALIFIER THAT
I'M GOING TO SHOW YOU A VIDEO
THAT THE ROLLS ROYCE OF WHITE.
LOS ANGELES UNION STATION COULD
BE.
AND SO SOME OF THESE ARE NOT
BLINDED AND IT'S MORE OF A
VISION OF WHAT WE CAN IMAGINE IT
TO BE.
I AM I'M NOT SURE IF YOU'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THEIR NOKIA STATE
THEATER DOWN IN DOWNTOWN WITH
THE STABLE CENTRE NIKITA THEATER.
IT WAS THE RIBBON CUTTING WHEN I
ATTENDED A RIBBON CUTTING IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX YOU ONLY SIGN A
KIA THEATER BUT NOW WHEN YOU GO
BACK THERE TEN YEARS LATER.
IT'S COMPLETELY DIFFERENT AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
CREATE HERE AT THE LOS ANGELES
UNION STATION.
SINCE NINETEEN THIRTY NINE LOS
ANGELES UNION STATION HAS
CONNECTED COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
LOS ANGELES REGION TODAY.
WE SHOULD OF OVER TWENTY MILLION
PEOPLE.
UNION STATION IS CENTRAL TO THE
TRANSPORTATION FOR THIS.
TAKING PLACE IN LA TODAY.
THE NEW LANDSCAPE WEST PLAZA
SITS BETWEEN THE RETAILER IN THE
IN READING [inaudible]
PROVIDES ACCESS.
THE PASSENGER PLATFORMS OF
SERVICE TO THE BAGGAGE HANDLING
CAROUSELS CAN BE SEEN TO THE
RIGHT.
RETAIL KIOSK ADJACENT TO THE
FULL RETAIL SPACE. FOR THE AT
GREAT KIND OF COURSE
.
THE CITY DOWN. TO THIS ARE
LOCATED IN THE IF IT'S TO THE
RENOVATED RATED.
AS WELL AS TAKING IS IT.
THE LINK UNION STATION.
IS. TO BE [inaudible]
UNION STATION.
IT TO A WORLD CLASS.
IN THE LASTLY I JUST HAVE ONE
MORE VIDEO WHICH IS THE
ROSECRANS MARQUARDT GRADE
SEPARATIONS.
REYES GRANTS IN A CART GREAT
INTERSECTION HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS ONE OF THE MOST HAZARDOUS
CROSSINGS CALIFORNIA. FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND VEHICLES CROSSES
RECEPTION DALY.
EACH WEEK THE CLASSIC ARMS ARE
DOWN.
BY.
PLEASE PRESS MCCARTY RICH.
THE COMPLETE SAFETY BY
SEPARATING THE STRANDS BICYCLES
AND BEING. FOR TAX OF TRAINS
YEAH.
METROLINK.
TRAIN AS WELL AS THE FUTURE HIGH
SPEED RAIL.
THIS WILL GREATLY REDUCE TRAFFIC
CONGESTION ELIMINATE DELAYS.
IN HAD SOME THE REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES AND OVERALL.
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR THE
COMMUNITY
.
AND THIS CONCLUDES MY
PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- DOES THE QUESTION
THAT -- I HAVE IN TERMS OF THERE
WERE THE WORKING RELATIONSHIP
YOU'VE HAD TO COMPLETE YOUR
PROJECTS -- WITH THE PRIOR
RAILROAD COMPANIES AND THE HIGH
SPEEDRAIL.
IN TERMS OF COLLABORATING ON THE
USE OF THE PROPERTIES THAT YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT AWAY.
THE TRACKAGE.
HAS THAT.
BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S GOTTEN
BETTER.
IN THE PAST FEW YEARS IN TERMS
OF WORKING OUT CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS.
AND PLANNING TOGETHER.
I NOTICED THAT YOU HAD SOME FREE
TRAINS GO THROUGH.
THAT PARTICULAR A PROJECT.
SO THE ROSE FANS MARKET IS
ACTUALLY BEEN QUITE
TRANSFORMATIONAL WITH -- OUR
DEALINGS WITH A HIGH SPEED RAIL
THE BEING A STAFF HIGH SPEED
RAIL BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE BEING A STAFF AND ALSO
AS PART OF THE SCORE PROGRAM.
THERE -- IT INCLUDES A FOURTH
MAINLINE TRACK SO I'M SHOWING A
RESTAURANTS MARKET GRADE
SEPARATION IT.
PROVIDES -- THE ABILITY FOR HIGH
SPEED BILL TO COME TROUGH AND
BE IN A STAFF AND HIGH SPEED
RAIL AS A GREAT RELATIONSHIP IN
THAT REGARD -- HIGH SPEED RAIL
IS ALSO ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEARING --
THE FOURTH MAILING TRACK ALONG
THIS CORRIDOR SO IT'S THE FOURTH
MAILING TRACK THAT CAN CALM BE
ACCOMMODATED THE RESIDENTS MARK
MARKET GRADE SEPARATION.
SO THE OUR RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
HIGH SPEED AS A GONE A LOT
BETTER -- IT'S ALWAYS BEEN GREAT
WORKING CLOSELY IN CLOSE
COLLABORATION WITH THEM -- AS
YOU KNOW LINKING IN STATION ALSO
WORKING WITH NATURAL LINKS.
SHARES THE TRACKS WITH THE HIGHS
IS PROPOSED TO SHARE THE TRACKS
WHEN HIGH SPEED RAIL COMES INTO
LOS ANGELES.
SO -- WHAT -- THE UNFUNDED
PROJECTS.
WITH FACILITATE -- BETTER
CONNECTIONS.
WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT
ULTIMATELY IN YOUR AREA.
SO MAYBE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
SECURE.
WHAT ARE YOUR PRIORITIES -- FROM
EACH AGENCY.
GO AHEAD OF STEPHANIE MY WANT TO
START DRILLING.
SURE WELL AS PART OF OUR
METROLINK SYSTEM THE ANAHEIM TO
BURBANK CORRIDOR IS THE PLAN
SHARED QUARTER WITH HIGH SPEED
RAIL ANAHEIM BEING THE SOUTHERN
MOST TERMINUS.
AND WE'VE IDENTIFIED A NUMBER OF
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENT
PROJECTS THAT WE WOULD NEED TO
HELP US OPERATE HIGHER SPEED
RAIL IT IN ORDER TO CONNECT WITH
HIGH SPEED RAIL WHEN IT
EVENTUALLY COME SOUTH -- I
MENTIONED EARLIER WE'VE
IDENTIFIED EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF CAPITAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
COULD BE SHELVE READY OVER THE
NEXT TWELVE MONTHS INCLUDES.
ADDING ADDITIONAL TRACK IT
SHOULD BE NOTED THAT 60%.
OF OUR RAIL NETWORK IS SINGLE
TRACK.
SO WE HAVE WITHIN OUR RAIL
RIGHTS OF WAY ROOM TO ADD A
SECOND TRACK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ADDITIONAL
GRADE SEPARATION PROJECTS
ADDITIONAL SIGHTINGS THAT WILL
HELP FACILITATE OUR DESIRE TO
HAVE HIGHER FREQUENCY SERVICE.
TO ATTRACT MORE WRITERS ALL
AGAIN TO IMPROVE CONNECTIVITY
WITH HIGH SPEED WELL WHEN IT
COMES FARTHER SOUTH AND ALSO --
TO PROVIDE AN INCREDIBLE RAIL
SHOWCASE BY TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
WHEN THE OLYMPICS IS HERE AND WE
CAN SHOWCASE.
A CONNECTIVITY IN CALIFORNIA
THAT'S THE ANAHEIM ANAHEIM TO
THE LA METRO STATION ON A LITTLE
FURTHER NORTH TO BURBANK FRANK --
SOWE CONNECT THE BURBANK
AIRPORT RIGHT TO ANAHEIM YES SO
THAT'S OUR MAJOR SEGMENT THAT'S
ALL -- JOINT WITH THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL THE ROLE.
SECTION IS THAT TURNING OUT TO
BE ONE OF YOUR BUSY IS -- LINES
THAT YOU HAVE IS THE BUSIEST
QUARTER WE HALF BECAUSE WE SHARE
IT WITH AMTRAK'S LOS AND CORD OR
ON THE ALSO I'M SURE THAT CORD
OR WITH THE FREE BOTH FREIGHT.
OPERATORS [inaudible]
AND S THE SAN BERNARDINO SO --
TO LA UNION STATION A BUSY
CORNER AT THIS POINT.
THAT WATER KIND OF PROBLEMS
WITHOUT.
ONE ASSEMBLY DINO LINE IS OUR
TOP PERFORMING LINE.
PRINCIPALLY BECAUSE BOTH OF THEM
LOSANGELES METRO AND SENATOR DO
YOU KNOW COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY PURCHASE THOSE RAIL
RIGHTS AWAY FROM THE CLASS ONE
RAILROADS SO IT'S PRINCIPALLY
OWNED BY THE MEMBER AGENCIES
RATHER THAN A PRIORITY FREIGHT
CORRIDOR -- IS ABOUT THE OTHER
TWO AGENCIES THE METRO AND
CALTRAIN SO I'LL JUST PICK IT
BACK ON STEPHANIE'S COMMENTS IN
REGARDS TO UNFUNDED PORTION OF
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL WE HAVE A
LOT.
SO FROM THE BURBANK TO UNION
STATION SEGMENTS WE HAVE GRADE
SEPARATIONS AND INVESTMENTS AND
DOUBLE TRACKING -- WILL
DEFINITELY HELP FACILITATE THAT
IT'S THE READY BURKE IT'S
ALREADY DOUBLE TRACK FROM
BURBANK TO LOS ANGELES UNION
STATION BUT FURTHER NORTH LIKE
FROM PALMDALE WHERE HIGH SPEED
RAIL DOESN'T TEND TO HAVE.
IT CONNECTIVITY HUB UP IN THE
NORTH AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY -- THAT WILL THAT
REQUIRES ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY WE WITH OR
ASKING TO LOOK INTO.
ENHANCE INVESTMENTS IN THE RAIL
CORRIDOR ALL THE WAY FROM PALM
DEL DOWN TO BURBANK -- I EIGHT
DEPENDING ON HOW HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND WHERE THEY WANT TO CALM AS
AN OPTION THAT WE ARE OPEN --
THAT WERE THAT WE HOPE THAT'S
OPEN THAT YOU CAN LOOK INTO
DOUBLE TRACKING THAT RAIL
CORRIDOR THAT CAN BE USED MAYBE
AS AN INTERIM OPERATING SEGMENT
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL WHILE THE
BILL TO MORE DEDICATED. HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE MILES PER HOUR
STILL TO BURBANK.
YES FROM PALM DELTA BURBANK YES.
AS A BEEN STUDIED.
IT HAS BEEN STUDIED WE HAVE A A
DOUBLE TRACKING PROJECT ROUGHLY
FROM BURBANK TO GO FURTHER NORTH
UP TO YOU.
ON THE OUTSKIRTS LIMITS OF LOS
ANGELES THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
THAT'S A LITTLE OF AN MILE
STRETCH.
AND THEN WE WOULD NEED FURTHER
DOUBLE TRACKING FROM THAT
SEGMENT ALL THE WAY UP TO
PALMDALE TO MAKE IT A FULL LEAD --
OF FOR HOPEFULLY DOUBLE TRACKED
CORRIDOR [inaudible]
CALTRAIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I I GUESS
TO THERE ARE THREE DIFFERENT
AREAS IN THE CALTRAIN SYSTEM
WHERE I THINK -- FOR HIGH SPEED
RAIL PURPOSES ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT WOULD BE NEEDED WHICH
WOULD BE -- SUPPLEMENTAL TO OUR
SERVICES.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO PUT IT IN
CONTEXT AS HAS BEEN DESCRIBED IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THERE'S A
HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES.
OF RIGHT AWAY IN A CIVIL WORK
BEING DONE -- IN OUR SAN
FRANCISCO TO SAN IS A SYSTEM
THAT WE OWN THE RIGHT AWAY
OTHERS FIFTY TWO MILES.
AND SO AS PART OF THE CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT M. THE
INVESTMENT THAT THE STATE IS
MAKING THROUGH HIGH SPEED RAIL --
AS A GRAND TOUR IN A AND TO US --
AMONG OTHER FUNDING AGENCIES --
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS IS RECEIVING
A PROPERTY INTEREST IN.
OUR RIGHT AWAY SO THAT IT WILL
HAVE A PROPERTY RIGHT TO
ACTUALLY.
OPERATE.
IT IS STILL AS I MENTIONED TO A
SEPARATE PRODUCT A PROJECT THAT
AS THE COURT SAID -- YET
INTERESTINGLY WAS A VERY
INTERESTING BUSINESS AND FACTUAL
STATEMENT THE COURT SAID IT IS
QUITE CLEAR THAT A HIGH SPEED
RAIL TRAIN CANNOT SIMPLY BE
PLACED.
ON ELECTRIFYING CALTRAIN TRACK.
MANY OTHER CHANGES AND
IMPROVEMENTS WILL BE REQUIRED.
TO IMPLEMENT THE BLENDED SYSTEM
IT BRING HIGH SPEED RAIL TO THE
PENINSULA -- SHOWED IS A
SEPARATE PROJECT BUT WE HAVE THE
FOUNDATION BOB BY THE INVESTMENT
IS BEING MADE AND
ELECTRIFICATION.
AND ON LIKE TO CENTRAL VALLEY
WE'RE NOT A CONTRACTOR
PERFORMING WORK ON BEHALF OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL THIS IS A
PROJECT THIS GOT MULTIPLE
FUNDERS.
AND TOTAL COSTS FOR WHAT.
WE AND OUR TWO BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT -- APPROXIMATELY FOR
ELECTRIFICATION BUT THE THREE
AREAS I THINK THAT ARE OF MUTUAL
INTEREST TO US IN HIGH SPEED
RAIL ONE IS THAT SAN JOSE TO
GILROY -- THE ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT DOES NOT EXTEND PAST SAN
JOSE TO GILROY -- BUT IT WOULD
BE IN THE MUTUAL INTEREST OF OF
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND AND CALTRAIN
FOREVER THE ELECTRIFICATION TO
CURB WE RUN DIESEL SERVICE THERE.
ON UNION PACIFIC TRACKS -- AND
WE DO NOT OWN THAT RIGHT AWAY WE
ARE -- THERE'S A TRACKAGE RIGHTS
AGREEMENTS WITH THE SERVICES
LIMITED IT IS NOT ELECTRIFIED
SERVICE.
AND WE KNOW FROM THE FROM THE
LAST BUSINESSPLAN OF OF HIGH
SPEED REALTORS AN EMPHASIS ON
SAN JOSE. TO TO GO RIGHT
COMPLETED THAT THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL STATION A PROPOSED THAT GO
RIGHT OR CORRECT YES -- SO
THAT'S ONE AREA WERE -- RIGHT HI
WELL IT'S WE CAN WE CAN SERVE
THAT WITHOUT ELECTRIFICATION
WITHOUT HIGH SPEED RAIL I THINK
THAT'S ONE OF A MUTUAL INTEREST.
THE SECOND IS WITH RESPECT TO
WHAT MAY HAPPEN AT THE SAME AS A
DIRT ON STATION THAT YOU'RE VERY.
FAMILIAR WITH -- BY THE WITH THE
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL COMING INTO
SAN IS A WITH PART COMING INTO --
THE DO DIRT ON STATION AREA.
WITH EXPANDED -- CALTRAIN
SERVICE -- AND WITH THE MAJOR
DEVELOPMENT THAT'S OCCURRING IN
AROUND -- THAT STATION THERE
WILL BE SIGNIFICANT CHANGES THAT
WILL BE REQUIRED -- END OF WE
KNOW THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
FOR ITS OWN PURPOSES SEPARATE
APART FROM OF ALL THE OTHERS IT
WILL THERE WILL HAVE TO BE AN
INVESTMENT MADE.
IN THAT STATE XIN.
AND THERE'S A PLANNING PROCESS
IN PLACE THAT INCLUDES MULTIPLE
PARTIES.
AND CLEAN UP HIGH SPEED RAIL
CALTRAIN -- THE THE VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION ASSOCIATION CITY
SAN JOSE. TO WORK ON ON PLANNING
FOR THAT STATION AREAS SO THAT'S
AN AREA IN WHICH I I I'M NOT
SURE WHETHER OR NOT HIGH SPEED
RAW ACTUALLY WILL HAVE TO FIGHT
THE FUNDS IT'S THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL FOLKS WILL KNOW THAT THAT
THERE WILL BE SOME.
FUNDING REQUIREMENT AND THAT
WILL BE MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL.
FOR THE CITY OF SAN JOSE AND AND
ALL THE PARTIES ARE JUST MENTION.
IN THE THIRD AREA IS IN SAN
FRANCISCO BY THE DOWNTOWN
TERMINAL -- IN THE EXT EXTENSION
FROM -- FOR THINKING STATION IN
SAN FRANCISCO TO THE DOWNTOWN
TERMINAL THAT'S OF INTEREST TO
CALTRAIN TO HIGH SPEED RAIL.
AND THE CITY OF SAN FRANCISCO --
AND SO -- YOU THAT THAT'S A VERY
EXPENSIVE PROJECT -- THERE'S A
PLANNING GOING ON IN THERE OR
YOU JUST NEED TO BUILD EXTENSION.
BY ALL RIGHT KIND OF THEIR YEAH
IT SHOULD YEAH THIS KIND OF
THEIR OWN.
WE HAD A A STEEL BEAM THAT IDEA
AND THEY JUST NEED TO BUILD THE
THE EXTENSION IS IS A LITTLE OF
AN UNDERSTATEMENT -- BUT IT
WOULD BE A VERY COMPLEX -- BUT
INTERESTING PROJECT IT'S IT'S
OUR MUTUAL INTEREST AGAIN
CALTRAIN -- DOESN'T HAVE TO
EXTEND FROM FOR THINKING TO THE
DOWNTOWN TERMINAL WE WE HAVE --
YOU KNOW LOTS OF TRAIN SERVICE
TO SAN FRANCISCO WHERE WE ARE
BUT IT WOULD BE IN OUR INTEREST
AS WELL FOR THEIR AN EXTENSION
TO BE MADE.
SO THOSE ARE THE THREE SPECIFIC
AREAS THAT COME TO MIND IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION.
DO YOU ALL THINK THAT -- IF WE
GET INTO THE NEXT.
PHASE OF THE TRANSIT FUNDING --
THEY'RE ALL THESE PROJECTS WOULD
ENHANCE THE ALL TWO MILLION
HANDS THE RIDERSHIP.
OF BOTH YOUR SYSTEMS AND THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL BOTH.
YOU THINK THAT'S TRUE AB SO BOTH
WOULD BENEFIT.
IN TERMS OF RIDERSHIP OF TAKING
THE AIR POLLUTION NOW THERE'RE
SO FORTH AND SO ON ABSOLUTELY
OKAY -- CENTER STERN AS A
QUESTION.
SIR HENRY STERN.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
MISTER CHAIR.
I'M SORRY I MISSED THE FRONT
FIRST HALF YEAR YEAR HEARING I'M
I'M JUST SHOWING UP FOR WHAT IN
MY OPINION IS THE GOOD PART -- I
TRULY THINK WITHIN YOUR AGENCIES
AND THE INVESTMENTS WERE MAKING
IT THESE BOOKENDS.
THE ENTIRE.
POLITICAL FORMULA FOR GETTING
BUY IN FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALL THE VOTERS TO
APPROVE THESE MONEY IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THIS IS WHERE IT STARTS AND ENDS
TO ME YOU TALK ABOUT THE TWO
MOST POPULOUS AREAS OF THE STATE
SO I COMMEND YOU OFFER THE
INTEGRATION YOUR EFFORTS AND I
WANTED TO GET SOME CONFIRMATION
THOUGH.
BEFORE HAVE TO POP IN AND OUT.
DO WE DID WE HEAR EARLIER IS
THEIR COMMITMENT TO FOLLOW
THROUGH ON THE BOOK IN FUNDING
FROM THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY ON THESE OUTSTANDING
PROJECTS ON SCORE CALTRAIN --
MINE AND AND METRO THE RUN
THROUGH TRACKS IF WE IF WE DO WE
NEED TO RUN THAT TO GROUND HERE
IS THAT.
BEEN MADE CLEAR BY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICER HR SORRY
WILSON.
NOT YET NO NO WE'LL SEE WHEN THE
PRESENTER.
OKAY IT'S IN THE CURRENT
BUSINESS PLAN YOU CAN CREEK AND
PANEL CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG.
IT'S IN THE CURRENT BUSINESS
PLAN.
BUT WHEN THEY PROPOSED ON THE
REVISED -- UPGRADE BUSINESS PLAN
IN MAY [inaudible]
THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT WILL SHOW AND ONE
OF THE FOR THE SCARY FACTORS
PROBABLY.
IS THE NINE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS.
IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TAKES
IT AWAY [inaudible]
HOW WOULD?
IMPACT THESE PROJECTS.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW AND
LAWS ARE CLEAN I I IT IN IN
TERMS OF THE SIX HUNDRED AND IT
IS THE SECRETARIES COMING TO
JOIN OKAY GREAT.
YEAH I THOUGHT I MIGHT BRING UP
HERE TO GET SOCKED RIGHT HAVE A
SEAT.
YEAH THANK YOU IN TERMS OF THE
SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OR
PROP ONE A FUNDS THAT HAVE BEEN
DIRECTED TO THE CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT THERE WE
HAVE IT AN AGREEMENT BY WHICH
THOSE FUNDS WILL BE PROVIDED
WITH FACTUALLY STARTED DRAWING
DOWN ON THOSE FUNDS.
AND THE THE STATE HAS HAS
INDICATED.
THAT THE THOSE FUNDS ARE
SEPARATE FROM -- ANY ISSUES AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OR THE
FEDERAL FUNDS THOSE ARE NOT
THOSE ARE.
STATE FUNDS DOT FEDERAL FUNDS IN
THAT AYE IMPACTED BY -- THE
DISPUTE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MY HEAD BRIAN
NUCLEAR ABSOLUTE RIGHT OUT OF
STATE SECRETARY.
OF TRANSPORTATION FOR YEAH THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR WITH FAT --
THAT CLARIFIED THAT.
TO YOU KNOW NOT ONLY CLEAR FIND
THEY WERE STILL COMMITTED TO
THESE EXISTING COMMITMENTS BUT
AS WE MENTIONED EARLIER THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE SOLD SOME
BONDS -- EARLIER TODAY AND SOME
OF THOSE BONDS I THINK WILL BE
AVAILABLE TO JIM TO EXISTING
AGREEMENTS FOR THE CALTRAIN
ELECTRIFICATION AND WE'VE ALSO.
COMPLETED THE FUNDING PLAN FOR
THE ROSECRANS MARQUARDT PROJECT
AND SO THOSE FUNDS AS WELL OR
AVAILABLE TO THAT PROJECT AS IT
MOVES FORWARD HIS IN. TO CLOSE
THE LOOP AT THE UNION STATION
WILL HAVE -- TO IS SAID GENET
SAID THERE'S A FUNDING PLAN TO
BE DONE WITH THAT PROJECT WHEN
IT'S READY TO GO BUT THEY
COMMITMENT REMAINS TO WELL THE
BOOK AND PROJECTS AS WAS SAID --
STARTED IN TWENTY TWELVE WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE APPROPRIATION OF
MONEY FOR THOSE PURPOSES.
WHAT'S THE TOTAL COST OF THE
UNION STATION AND HOW MUCH
REMAINS TO BE FUNDED AS THAT.
IT MIGHT BE ARE YOU CLEARLY FUND --
INNER SO WE HAVE TO PHASES GO
AHEAD SO THE FIRST PHASE IS THE
RUN THREE PHASE YEAH SO THAT IS
PARTIALLY THAT'S FULLY THAT WE
HAVE.
RECEIVED A FINING AWARD BY
TERROR C. P..
WE HAVE FINING COMMENCEMENTS BY
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL. TO
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
NINE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WILL COMPLETELY CHANGE
THE RATE CONSTANT SIGNALS AND
BUILD A COMPLETE RUN FOR THIS.
THE SECOND PHASE OF THAT IS
RAISING THE RAIL YARD TO HAVE
ALL PLATFORMS.
BE RUN THROUGH CAPABILITY.
AS WELL AS BUILDING A NEW
PASSENGER CONCOURSE BECAUSE
RIGHT NOW AT UNION STATION THERE
IS NO PASSENGER CONCOURSE YOU
COME THROUGH EIGHT AN EXISTING
TWENTY NINE FOOT PASSAGE WAY
THAT WAS BUILT IN.
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE AND SO THE
INTENT IS TO TURN THIS INTO YOU
USE.
LEVERAGE THE LINKING AND STATION --
TO TO TRANSFORM IT TO A WORLD
CLASS OF TRANSIT MOBILITY HUB --
FOR THE NEXT EIGHTY YEARS AGO
TOOK EIGHTY YEARS WEST'S
REVAMPING ANOTHER EIGHTY YEARS
MORNING.
SO THIS IS WHAT WILL IT BE FOR
THE NEXT CD YEAR SO THAT.
TOTAL COST OF THE PROJECT IS
ROUGHLY NORTH OF TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND ONLY NINE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS PART OF
PHASE A HAS HAD FINANCIAL
COMMITMENT THAT'S THE ONE YOU
HOPE TO GET DONE BY THE OLYMPICS
ARE CORRECT.
LET ME JUST SAY THANK YOU
SECRETARY ANISE DEAD SINCERELY
AND DON'T STOP THERE.
THERE'S MORE TO BE DONE.
SAID OLYMPICS TO BE HAD BUT ALSO
HOW MANY MORE GRADE CROSSINGS DO
WE HAVE WITH MARQUARDT TYPE --
THROUGH PUT ME TED.
FORTY FIVE THOUSAND TROOPS TODAY.
HOW MANY MORE LIKE THAT WE HAVE
ANOTHER WE HAVE SEVERAL ONE WE
HAVE DOOR ENDING GREAT DORK
DOREEN AND BROADLY IN BRAZIL
BETWEEN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AND CITY OF GLENDALE?
THAT'S ONE HAS IT IS COSTING
THIS BUSY IS IN YOUR SET
INTERESTED THAT'S A BUSY RAIL
CORRIDOR BECAUSE WE BOTH HAVE
THE LOW SAN CORD AROUND THE
MATCHING LINKS WE HAVE SEVERAL
MORE -- AMONG THEM METRO LINK.
TO THE GOT THE SIGNS BUT YEAH
NOTE THIS IS IN THIS IS AND THIS
IS YOUR YOUR FIRST DAY.
UP HERE RIGHT GRETA WELCOME IS
WEEKENDS THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING THE NEW CEO WE'RE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT YOU.
THE IS THERE A LOT OF PHONE
GRADE CROSSINGS FOR METROLINK
ALSO YOU.
YES WE HAVE A FIVE HUNDRED
THIRTY PLUS ROUTE MILE NETWORK
AND UNFORTUNATELY HAVE A HIGH
NUMBER OF AT GRADE CROSSINGS ON
SO YEAH.
CALDERON BY WERE SMALL POTATOES
COMPARED TO THAT BUT THE THERE'S
A LOT WE HAVE IT JUST IN THE
MAIN LINE WE HAVE FOR OVER.
FORTY OKAY.
SIR GALGIANI HAS SOME QUESTIONS
SENATOR -- WELL FIRST OF ALL
WHEN IT WITH THE WHOLE HIGH
SPEED RAIL SYSTEM THERE WERE
OVER EIGHT HUNDRED GRADE
SEPARATIONS.
ALONG THE WHOLE ENTIRE NORTH TO
SOUTH CORRIDOR SO -- QUICK IT'S
EASY TO SEE HOW QUICKLY EVERY
DOLLAR OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
DOLLARS CAN BE SPENT SIMPLY ON
GRADE SEPARATIONS BECAUSE THE
STATE HASN'T PROVIDED.
ENOUGH FUNDING FOR GRADE
SEPARATIONS BUT I JUST WANT TO
REMIND MEMBERS THAT THE WAY THAT
PROP ONE IT WAS WRITTEN IS THAT.
ANY MONEY THAT WE SPEND
ESSENTIALLY HAS TO BE A
COMMITMENT TO DO THAT CORD OR AS
A USABLE CORD OR BECAUSE THE
INTENTION WAS SO THAT WE
WOULDN'T -- END UP USING THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL MONEY FOR THIS
PURPOSE ALL OVER THE STATE BUT
RATHER.
ANY PROJECT THAT WE COMMIT TO WE
WOULD THEN HAVE THE INTENTION OF
FOR FILLING THE ALL OF THE TRACK
HAVE A HIGH SPEED RAIL STATION
AT EACH END.
SO WE COULD USE IT FOR THAT
PURPOSE AND THEN THERE WAS --
GREATER WEIGHT WOULD BE GIVEN TO
USABLE CORRIDORS THAT WOULD
CONNECT WITH REGIONAL RAILS SO
AT THIS POINT -- THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HAS COMMITTED.
TO THE L. A. TO ANAHEIM SEGMENT
IN MY VIEW BECAUSE OF THE FACT
THAT WE'VE COMMITTED THE FUNDING
FOR THE ROSE CRANS MARK WHAT
GRADE SEPARATION.
AND TO BE COMPLIANT WITH PROP
ONE A WE NEED TO HAVE A USABLE.
SEGMENT THE S. STATIONS AT EACH
END EVENTUALLY.
IT'S BURBANK RIGHT BURBANK TO
ERA [inaudible]
SO.
YEAH THAT'S THE FOCUS.
AND THROUGH THE MAIN STATION.
SO GETTING THAT.
OKAY -- WELL THANK YOU -- FOR
THE PANEL ANDPUBLIC COMMENTS ON
THIS SUBJECT.
HIGH SPEED RAIL -- WIN RIGHT TO
PUBLIC TO COME FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OF WE HAVE A MICROPHONE WE WANT
TO HAVE EVERYBODY -- A CHANCE TO
MAKE COMMENTS -- TWO MINUTES A
PIECE OF ALL TIME YOU KNOW.
AND WELCOME TO OUR HEARING.
GOOD EVENING SIR -- MAN THANK
YOU -- TO DO THE LATENESS OF THE
HOUR I WILL MOVE THIS ALONG BUT
THANK YOU TERMS BELL AND
CHAIRMAN OF Y. KOWSKI AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME STEVE
KERR AGAIN.
ON THE CITY MANAGER FOR THE CITY
MERCED I'M HERE TODAY OR THIS
EVENING ON BEHALF OF MAYOR
MURPHY WHO'S ON A LONG OVERDUE
VACATION.
MERCED HEARD IS THAT MISTREATED
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S RURAL
RESILIENCE STRATEGY WHICH
INCLUDES IMPORTANT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION IN THE HEART OF
CALIFORNIA THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS A KEY ELEMENT
TO THAT STRATEGY PROVIDING A
COMMITMENT TO CLEAN LOW AND NO
CARBON TRANSPORTATION.
STRATEGIES THAT HELP REDUCE
POLLUTION AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY
HOME TO SOME OF THE NATION'S
WORST AIR QUALITY AND HIGHEST
ASTHMA RATES.
WE'RE SAID FRESNO BIGGEST FILTER
ON GENERALLY ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS IN THEIR RESPECTIVE
COUNTIES MERCED FRESNO AND KERN.
AND THEY HAVE A POPULATION X.
THE IN EXCESS OF TWO MILLION
PEOPLE.
THE CITIES IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
AMONG THE SIX CALIFORNIA'S
FASTEST GROWING COMMUNITIES
RIGHT WITH OPPORTUNITY TO CARRY
CALIFORNIA INTO A SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE.
THE GOVERNOR'S HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROPOSAL IS TRANSFORMED OF FOR
THE CENTRAL VALLEY CAN TRAVEL
TIME AND HAVE TO MOVE BETWEEN
CITIES THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY.
COMPARED TO TODAY'S RAIL SERVICE
IN TRAVELING BY CAR WHILE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
TRANSFORMED IT FOR THE CENTRAL
VALLEY IT MAINTAINS IMPORTANT
TARGET INVESTMENTS.
ADOPTED BY THE AUTHORITY AND THE
BAY AREA AND LOS ANGELES OPENING
OF VALLEY TO VALLEY ACCESS TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMPANIES TO EXPAND TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND OFFERING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROSPECTS THAT ALIGN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL GOALS TO
ENSURE STATEWIDE COORDINATED
INVESTMENTS.
HIGH SPEED RAIL ALSO CONNECTS
MERCED IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY TO
THE MEGA REGION EFFORTS FROM THE
BAY AREA PROVIDING A REGIONAL
PERSPECTIVE TO HOW WE ADDRESS
HOUSING WORKFORCE AND
EDUCATIONAL ISSUES.
THIS INCLUDES LEVERAGING STATE
INVESTMENTS AND DYNAMIC
INSTITUTIONS SUCH AS UC MERCED.
AND FINALLY THE THE CITY MERCED
HAS BEEN AND REMAINS SUPPORT OF
A HIGH SPEED RAIL LOOKS FORWARD
TO OUR CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP IN
DOING ITS PART TO RIDE TO
SOLUTIONS TO CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM CHALLENGES.
THANK YOU AND KEEP UP THE GOOD
WORK REALLY APPRECIATE IT THANK
YOU.
FORMER SAID THANKS FOR COMING
ALL THIS LONG WAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE KEITH ON
HER BEHALF THE ASSOCIATION FOR
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED TRAINS
MADE UP OF BUSINESS AND LABOR
GROUPS WHO SUPPORT THIS PROJECT
FROM BEGINNING.
I'LL BE BRIEF AND JUST TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE NATURE OF
SOME THE CONVERSATIONS THAT TOOK
PLACE TODAY AND THIS REALLY IS A
TRANSFORMATIVE INNOVATIVE.
PROCESS TO MODERNIZE OUR SYSTEM
AND WE NEED TO REMEMBER THAT
IT'S NOT JUST THE CENTRAL VALLEY
BUT AS YOU HEARD FROM THE LOCAL
AGENCIES TODAY THIS IS.
TRANSFORMING IN MODERNIZING OUR
TRAIN SYSTEM WHICH SERVES ALL OF
US HERE IN CALIFORNIA ALSO THE
CENTER STONE I'M SORRY HE'S NOT
HERE BECAUSE TALKING ABOUT THE
AIRPORTS.
IN FLIGHT TRAVEL WITHIN OUR
STATE IN CALIFORNIA IS
RESTRICTED AND LIMITED DUE TO
NUMEROUS THINGS BUT MILITARY
BASES OTHER ACTS AB.
LIMITATIONS ON AIR TRAVEL THE
STATE SO WE'RE BUILDING THE
SYSTEM FOR THE FUTURE WE HAVE
CONGESTION IN THE CARS WHICH WE
SEE BUT WE ALSO FORGET ABOUT
CONGESTION IN THE ERRORS.
ADDITIONAL AIRSPACE IS NOT AN
OPTION HERE IN THE STATE AND IN
IN INNOVATING OUR TRAINING
TRAVEL WITHIN THE STATE ON THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS GOING TO HELP
THE SKIES AS WELL.
I'M LET MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES MISTER SMITH
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
ECONOMICS AND JOB CREATION OF
THIS PROJECT BUT IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AND WAS A SHOT IN THE
ARM FOR THE CENTRAL VALLEY IT
RIGHT AT THE TIME THAT WE NEEDED
IT.
AND WE'RE JUST COMPLETELY
SUPPORTER OF THIS PROJECT MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE RIGHT SOLUTIONS
I THINK WE'VE GOT A GREAT TEAM
ON BOARD -- WHO ARE GONNA MAKING
TOUGH DECISIONS BUT MOVING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO THANK YOU
FOR THIS HEARING IN THE
OPPORTUNITY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO BOTH CHAIRS HERE
TODAY AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH YOUR
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL --
AS POINTED OUT IN THE WHITE
PAPER CREATED BY THE COMMITTEE
STAFF ON THE LAST PAGE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THOUSANDS
OF JOBS.
IN -- WORKER HOURS THAT HAVE
ALREADY -- BEEN PUT INTO PLACE
IN THIS JOB NOT NOT TO MENTION A
TRANSFORMATIVE.
ECONOMIC INVESTMENT IN THE AREAS
OF THE STATE WHAT IS HAPPENING
PARTICULAR THE CENTRAL VALLEY --
BUT OUTSIDE OF THE ECONOMIC THE
POSITIVE TO THIS PROJECT -- IT'S
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION OF THOUGHT PROCESS
THAT WE NEED TO KEEP AT THE
FOREVER MINE FIRST OF ALL -- YOU
KNOW IT'S CENTRAL TO THE
GREENHOUSE GAS.
REDUCTION GOALS.
THAT WE HAVE -- PROMOTED IN THE
STATE.
IT'S ALSO CENTRAL TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS AND IT
IS ESSENTIAL ANSWER TO THAT.
IF WE CAN MOVE PEOPLE FROM
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO WHERE THE
JOBS ARE -- THAT IS GOING TO
HELP FIX THAT CRISIS AS WELL IN
FACT WE WOULD ARGUE THAT IF YOU
SUPPORT SOMETHING LIKE A GREEN
NEW DEAL.
THEN YOU NEED TO SUPPORT A
PROJECT LIKE THIS.
BECAUSE THIS GETS AT THE HEART
OF WHAT IS IS -- PROVIDING A LOT
OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
OF THE STATE AND THAT'S VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED.
ARE GETTING CARS OFF THE ROAD IS
GOING TO HELP US MEET OUR GOALS.
UNDER AB THIRTY TWO AND THE
SUBSEQUENT LEGISLATION.
AND IF -- THE LEGISLATURE SPOKE
ABOUT BY PASSING AB THIRTY TWO
IT.
ALSO SAID WE WANT TO BE BELIEVE
IN THESE TRANSFORMATIVE PROJECTS.
THAT ARE GONNA SOLVE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE CRISIS AND IN SITUATION.
THOSE PROJECTS ARE BIG AND
COSTLY AND TAKE A LONG TIME TO
FINISH WHAT THEY'RE VITAL. TO
MEET OUR GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
GOALS AND TO FIX THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE.
AND SO FINALLY I WOULD SAY WE
SUPPORT THE PROJECT MOVING
FORWARD CONTINUOUS IT IS -- WITH
THE CONTINUED ROBUST OVERSIGHT.
I NOT ONLY OF THE TWO COMMITTEES
REPRESENTED HERE TODAY -- BUT
THERE -- THE COMMITTEES IN THE
US ON THE ASSEMBLY SIDE AS WELL
IN THE PEER REVIEW GROUP THIS IS
A BIG PROJECT -- IT'S GOING WE
THINK WELL -- COULD ALWAYS BE
IMPROVED EVERY BIG PROJECT
ALWAYS BE IMPROVED BUT FOR THE
MOST PART WE NEED TO CONTINUE
FOR ON THIS PROJECT BECAUSE IT'S
VITAL TO THE STATE'S.
ECONOMIC IN -- CLIMATE CHANGE
INTERESTS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR ARE BOTH CHAIRS I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT AND
CENTER GALGIANI TO THIS PROJECT --
JOE CRUISE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE.
WE ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
PROJECT -- BUT WE CONTINUE TO
WORK TOWARDS A REALLY VIABLE
SEGMENT OF THE VALLEY TO VALLEY
PIECE WHICH CONNECTS.
A RESIDENTIAL AREAS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH GOOD JOBS IN
THE SILICON VALLEY -- I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT SPECIFICALLY A COUPLE
OF OF SORT OF FUNDING ISSUES
THAT ARE BEFORE THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL.
THERE WE WOULD WANT TO CONTINUE
TO SEEK FUNDING FOR IN THAT ONE
IS THE CALTRANS ELECTRIFICATION.
THE ELECTRIFICATION OF THE RAIL
LINE AND ALSO THE UPGRADES TO
THE ROLLING STOCK -- WE WOULD
ALSO -- RESPECT THE REQUEST THAT
THEY MOVE FORWARD WITH INCLUDING
GRADE SEPARATIONS AT SKY WAY
BRAND HAND.
AND SIGNED OFF IN THE FINAL E.
I. R. E. I. S. -- CAN MISTER
MISTER HARNICK -- TOUCHED UPON A
COUPLE OTHER ITEMS ONE IS THE
ACQUISITION OF VITAL RIGHT AWAY
ALONG THE UNION PACIFIC RAIL
CORRIDOR FOR THE EXPANSION AND
DEVELOPMENT OF THE RAIL LINE
FURTHER.
ON PASSED GILROY WHICH IS
IMPORTANT TO DEVELOP IN THE
OVERALL PROJECT.
AND THEN LASTLY -- AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN MEMBER AGENCIES -- THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE VC A CALTRANS
AT HIM TO SEE. TO ADVANCE A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN TO DEVELOP
AND FACILITATE THE THE PLANE OF
RAIL LINES IN YOUR ON STATION SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
COMMITMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING CENTERS MY NAME IS
ROLAND TO RUN OUR I'M FROM SAN
JOSE AND BRIAN I'M NOT IN ANY
PARTICULAR HURRYTO HEAD BACK TO
MY COT STOPPED RUBBING HER.
I KNOW IT TO ME THE PROBLEM AS I
SEE IT IS NOT TOO IS A LACK OF
FUNDING THE REAL ISSUE IS WE SAY
FATALLY FLAWED ALIGNMENT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
WHICH AS DESIGN CANNOT POSSIBLY
HAVE A BE A COMPONENT.
OF A COMMOTION THE VIABLE HIGH
SPEED LINE WHICH IS ON THE SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES.
MY ADVICE YOU TWO DAYS TO STOP
ALL CONSTRUCTION SOUTH OF FRESNO.
AS WELL AS ANY FURTHER TO WORK
ON THE ONE BILLION DOLLARS SO
CALLED FRESNO TRENCH.
AND WE ARE LOCATED THIS FUNDING.
TO CONNECTING A MONDAY OR AND
MISS SAID [inaudible]
NEXT.
HE'S BURIED THE AUTHORITY TO
FOCUS ON THE HIGH RIDERSHIP
CORRIDORS.
STARTING WAS BURBANK TO ANAHEIM
AND SAN FRANCISCO. TO GILROY.
AND AFTER THAT TO START WORKING
ON THE ENVIRONMENT CLEARANCE ON
A DARK TIME IN BETWEEN GEAR --
IN FRESNO.
BUT WE'LL SAVE FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO BUY ANY MIDI TAKING
THE PARTICLE TUNNELS.
AND OPEN THE DOOR. TO A TRAVEL
TIME OF UNDER TWO HOURS BE TWO
IN SAN JOSE AND LOS ANGELES READ
MY LIPS UNDER TO RISE BETWEEN
SOME SANDALS IN LOS ANGELES.
MOVIE ON TO STAFF ISSUES LET THE
LAST TIME I ATTENDED A HEARING
ASSEMBLYMAN FRASER ALSO THE
RESIGNATION WRISTBAND RICHARD.
BUT MR RICHEST DOWN FULL
ULTIMATELY WAS A DIRECT RESULT
OF FREE SOLOING ADVICE FROM
SENIOR STAFF WOULD LIKE BASIC
HIGH SPEED WHO LACK BASIC HIGH
SPEED RAIL ENGINEERING SKILLS.
SPOTTING WAS ALL I AM AND
DECISIONS.
IN CLOSING TODAY I'M ASKING YOU
FOR THE RESIGNATION OF MR FRANK
VACCA WE SETTLED ULTIMATELY
RESPONSIBLE FOR HAPPEN TO HIGH
SPEED RAIL IN CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRENDA AND I'M
FROM FRESNO AND THE PART OF IOWA
RIGHT HAVE BEEN A PART OF IT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND I
LOVE IT.
TOO SO -- I'VE STAYED THE WHOLE
DAY LISTEN TO EVERYTHING AND TO
BE HONEST WITH YOU FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE I'M.
TWENTY SIX I'M GOING INTO THE
ECONOMY I'M GOING TO BE A WITH
THE ONE WRITING THIS I'M GOING
TO BE THE ONE RAISING KIDS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY AN
ECONOMY THAT IS THE FIFTH
LARGEST IN THE WORLD AND NUMBER
ONE IN AMERICA.
IS REALLY HAVING ALL OF THESE
CRAZY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
FUNDING I MEAN I I GET IT BUT I
DON'T GET IT BECAUSE THERE'S NO
REASON WHY WE CAN'T GET THIS
REAL DONE.
WE HAVE RESOURCE AS I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF OUTSIDE LIKE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT BUT WE ALL KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT.
AIR IS WHY IT'S IMPORTANT
CONGESTION TRAFFIC IS WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT SAFETY IS WHY IT'S
IMPORTANT I WAS GOING TO LA FROM
FRESNO ABOUT A MONTH AGO.
LOCKED BEHIND A GREAT BAND FOR
FORTY FIVE MINUTES HAD TO GO
THROUGH THE HOT CHICK PEAS
WEATHER SNOW ON THE GROUND ALL
KINDS OF STUFF.
THERE'S LOTS AND LOTS OF REASONS
WHY THIS JUST NEEDS TO GET DONE
AT SOME POINT WE KIND OF JUST
NEED TO MAKE THE DECISION NOW
WE'RE GOING TO DO IT I'M GOING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW AND SOME
PEOPLE MIGHT BE UPSET.
BUT IT NEEDS TO HAPPEN SAID I
HEARD A LOT OF PROPOSALS ABOUT
MAYBE SOME TAXES I KNOW THAT'S A
LOT OF THINGS I KNOW THAT THERE
IS IDEAS BUT WE JUST GOT TO
FIGURE IT OUT YOU GUYS.
THIS IS BEEN GOING ON HAVE BEEN
COMING TO THESE HEARINGS FOR
THREE YEARS.
AND WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN A LOT IN
THOSE THREE YEARS AND IT'S IT'S
GETTING A LITTLE RIDICULOUS TO
ME THAT NOW THE PROPOSAL IS TO
MERCED.
I'M SPEAKING AS AN INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT THIS IS MY PERSPECTIVE.
I REALLY WANT TO BE ABLE TO GET
ON A TRAIN AND GO TO THESE
PLACES I WANT MY AIR BETTER IN
THE VALLEY.
I WANT TO SEE PROJECTS BE
COMPLETED WE HAVE THE CAPABILITY
WE NEED TO START ACTUALLY
GETTING OVER IT THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
ILLEGITIMATE AND JUST DOING IT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND I
HOPE YOU GUYS HAVE A GOOD NIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I LIKE TO THANK EVERYBODY CAME
TO THE MERIT MEETING AND WE
CERTAINLY -- ARE.
GETTING PREPARED TO HAVE THIS --
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OVER THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AND THE THE
REVISED -- PLANS THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE PROPOSING.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO MODERATE
THROUGH OUR COMMITTEES AND
THROUGH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY.
BOARD SO WE WILL STAND ADJOURNED
FOR THIS COMMITTEE [inaudible]
BOB